I now call the January 8th, 9th, 2020 meeting of the State Board of Education to order.
I'd like to commence by saluting the flag.
Vice President Strauss, will you lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance?
So, good morning all.
Item one is our state board projects and priorities item to take up the annual election of officers only.
We now hold an election for the position of president and vice president for 2020.
The bylaws require that the state superintendent preside over the election of the president and such other business as the state board may direct.
I'll turn the gavel over to Tony.
You get the fun part.
Thank you, Madam President.
Good morning, all.
In keeping with Article 4 of the state's board's bylaws, I'd like to call for nominations for the office of president.
No member may nominate or second the nomination for himself or herself, and six votes are necessary to elect an officer, and each officer elected shall serve for one year or until his or her successor is elected.
I will now open the floor for nominations for the Office of President.
Are there nominations?
Yes, sir.
I would like to nominate Dr. Linda Darling-Hammond as our Board President and State Board Vice President.
Is there a second to this nomination?
I'd second that.
There is a second.
Are there any other nominations?
Seeing none.
I would entertain a motion to elect Linda Darling-Hammond to the Office of President for 2020 by acclamation.
Been moved by the Vice President.
And there is a second.
All in favor, please say aye.
Congratulations, it's my pleasure to announce our president for 2020.
It was so short-lived I returned to the gallery.
Do you want to bang it once before you send it back?
It's okay, it's okay.
Well, I'm not going to make a speech but just say I'm really honored and humbled and privileged to work with all of you.
We're moving a great agenda forward with the department.
kind of in chapter two of the California story, building on the work that was done in the previous board, you know, to turn this system around.
And I'm excited about what we'll be doing together in the year ahead.
So thank you very, very much.
And in keeping with Article 4 of the State Board's bylaws, I'd like to call for nominations for the Office of Vice President.
No member may nominate or second the nomination for him or herself.
Six votes are necessary to elect an officer.
Each officer elected shall serve for one year or until his or her successor is elected.
And I now open the floor for nominations for the Office of Vice President.
Are there nominations?
I would like to nominate Eileen Strau as Vice President.
And is there a second for that nomination?
I'm happy to second that.
Okay, thank you very much Member Navo.
Is there any public comment?
All right, I'll entertain a motion to elect Eileen Strauss to the Office of Vice President for 2019 by acclamation.
Can I have such a motion?
I'll move my acclamation.
Member Sun, thank you.
Second?
All right.
Thank you, Member Patia Bronson.
All in favor, please say aye.
Any nays?
I don't think so.
It is my pleasure to announce that your Vice President for 2019 has been elected by acclamations.
Congratulations, Eileen.
All right, we have a few other announcements.
I have the pleasure of announcing that Edmundo Aguilar is retiring from state service after 30 years, oh wow, of which nearly 25 years were with CDE Legal Affairs.
He has worked under six superintendents, including Superintendent Honig, Dawson, Easton, O'Connell, Torlakson, and now Thurmond, a little walk down memory lane.
Please join me in thanking him for his many years of dedicated public service on behalf of our public school service students, and I would like to present him with this certificate that represents and thanks him for his service.
Hopefully these are on.
Yeah.
Well, thank you.
Thank you for bringing me back.
It's odd coming here as a private citizen.
So this is actually my third day as a private citizen.
But as Board President Darlene Hammond mentioned, I've worked for the state for 30 years.
Close to 25 I've been with the Department of Education.
And my tenure is broken up into two terms.
I was here in the 90s and left in 2002.
In those seven years, I worked for school superintendents and I worked for Sacramento State President Alex Gonzalez, which were great years, but I came back.
I felt it was time to come back home in 09 and I left last Friday.
But it's interesting.
I will take just a few minutes.
I know you have a busy agenda.
But the two tenures were different with regard to the state board.
In the 90s, I defended you in the school reorganization before state appellate court as well as in trial court.
It was an interesting time in the 90s for those of you that know what was going on.
It was a completely different board, a completely different relationship.
But also, I don't know if anybody here knows, but I was your first counsel.
in the early nineties.
It was before you hired, created a separate office, but I was the person designated from the legal office to represent you and to provide you counsel.
So I go back and I had thought about that.
I realized that I was your first attorney.
So as your first attorney, I'm telling you that with a second tenure, I'm most impressed.
This has been the most impressive.
And as I say, the best came for last.
You folks, I've been impressed the last eight years with your dedication, what you do for the children of the state of California,
I've just been so impressed with this board the last eight years and I never thought, to be quite frankly, in the 90s we'd be where we are today and it just warms my heart to go out there to know that what you folks are doing and what goes on and the hard work you do and the dedication.
So I want to thank you as an employee of the department and as a citizen today.
Thank you for everything you've done and for taking the time to have me here today.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I think you just dropped the mic.
Alright.
Boom, I'm out.
That was awesome.
He didn't leave any room for any rebuttal or for any cross-examination.
I think he clearly dropped the mic.
He did.
He dropped the mic.
And I'd also like to announce that after serving as the department's liaison to the State Board of Education office for the last four and a half years,
Stephanie Pappas has taken another position within CDE, so we're happy that she's still in CDE, but we'll miss her working directly with us with the State Board.
And Stephanie, if you would please accept our warm appreciation for the work that you've done for the Board.
We're glad you will not be a stranger.
You are always welcome at our meetings and otherwise.
Thank you so much, Stephanie.
We will take up, we have a few changes in the agenda.
I just want to quickly announce.
We'll take up item one again tomorrow afternoon for approval of the November 2019 minutes consideration of the SBE screening committee's recommendations for appointments to the ACCS and liaison reports.
Um, item 12 related to the career technical education incentive grant program has been pulled from the agenda by the yesterday.
So it will not be heard tomorrow.
Um, waiver number 7, a waiver request by Ontario Montclair United school district regarding resource specialist caseload was withdrawn by the district yesterday.
Waiver 13 by Torrance unified regarding the process for sale lease of the surplus property was withdrawn by the district So it will not be heard Item 15 approval of charter numbers had an update to the attachment as a charter school withdrew its numbering request So those are all the changes to the agenda.
There are three public hearings on our January agenda item 9 which will be heard later today and item 17 and 18 which will be heard tomorrow
For the consent calendar, there is a handout on the table in the lobby identifying the proposed items on the consent calendar.
The proposed regular consent items are items 6 and 13 through 16.
The proposed consent waiver items are waiver 01 through 06 and 8 through 12.
I'd like to remind board members that any members wishing to remove any items from the proposed consent calendars can please advise our executive director, Karen Staff-Walters, by 11 o'clock today.
And we will take up the waiver consent items and the regular consent items tomorrow morning.
Uh, in terms of public input speakers should sign into the table just outside the room binders are on the table with separate pages for each item number signing in on the page that identifies the item number on which you would like to speak will help ensure that we keep track of all the speakers for a particular item.
Item 20 is the general public comment item during which members of the public may provide comments on items that are not specifically listed on the board's agenda.
Public comment will be limited to one minute per speaker.
In order to ensure that everyone gets their minute, there is a timer at the podium that will flash a red signal to each speaker when the one minute time limit has been reached.
And now I'd like to invite State Superintendent Thurmond to provide his superintendent's report.
Thank you Madam President.
Congratulations on the election Madam President and to Madam Vice President.
I'd like to wish the board and those who are here a happy new year as this is our first meeting in 2020.
2019 was a very productive year and I am hopeful
for an equally productive year.
And as I enter my second year in this office, I am humbled by the incredible work of this board and the staff at the California Department of Education.
I'd like to start my remarks by also thanking another member of the CDE family,
who has served well and has chosen to take another opportunity.
But I'm of the belief that everyone always comes back to CDE, as you heard from Raimundo's remarks.
I'd like to ask Michelle Senter to prepare herself just to say a brief set of words about her experience here at CDE.
As you know, she has served as the Director of our Assessments Division, and she has led us
and very important work.
She has served the agency since 2001 doing the heavy lifting and helping us to usher in new systems that are reflective of the standards and LCFF priorities.
She will be, you know, she organized a statewide assessment conference where practitioners from all across the state
came together to talk about the importance of assessment, and it was profound, and I'm hopeful that there will be others.
We are hopeful that we will have an opportunity to work with you again, Michelle.
Thank you, and if you would like to have a few remarks, the mic is yours.
Thank you.
This was very unexpected.
I had no idea so many people liked me.
So I do want to thank and acknowledge the mentors that I have had in the department as well as on this board.
When I started in the department in 2001,
I wasn't even a consultant when I started in this department.
I was an education assistant with absolutely no background in education.
And because of the strong mentors that I had, I thrived here.
became a pretty good leader, I would say.
And I'm so proud of the work that my division has done, which they are all standing in the back.
This is the division that actually does all the work.
I want to also say that my division is ready for me to move on and try something new.
I mean, it's exciting for me to try something new and learn something new, but they're ready and I am confident that we're in good hands because, you know, I'm the one who gets a lot of the credit, but they're the ones that have been doing all this work for so many years.
So, thank you.
Thank you, Michelle.
Michelle is going to be overseeing licensure at the Department of Consumer Affairs.
And so we like to know that you're right around the corner or wherever that building is.
Thank you for your service.
And thank you to all of the folks in your division for your service.
Let's give them all a round of applause.
Continuing the theme of transitions, there are also some new faces that you will see, as you all know, that our former deputy superintendent of operations and administration next white, sir, also moved on to take another position after a long time state service.
I'm pleased to tell you that we have had the good fortune.
to elevate none other than Lisa Constancio, who has been serving for 13 years at CDE as the head of the Charter Schools Division, and most recently as the School and Fiscal Services Division.
She will now be skippering our efforts in the Operations and Administration Branch.
Stand up, Lisa Constancio.
She's no stranger to this board, but she will be you will be seeing her in a new capacity and we're happy to have her her leadership and she's hit the ground running in her new role.
Filling in after her, we are also pleased to announce a new director of the charter schools division.
Also someone who will not be a stranger to you as she has worked for many years on charter issues around authorizing.
She's worked with charter schools.
She's worked with school districts in her consultancy.
She worked for the California School Boards Association for 13 years and in that,
Capacity was also the principal point person for charter schools and a former teacher at Hiram Johnson High School here in Sacramento None other than Stephanie Farland Let's acknowledge Stephanie Farland
and welcome her.
There's one other new person that we like to acknowledge.
She cannot be here today but she will be the new, she is the new director of our state special schools division and that's Robin Zane who had been working in the assessment center and has also been a teacher previously at the California School for the Deaf in Fremont and she will be overseeing
those programs.
We're excited we have rounded out and now have a complete executive team.
Many of them from positions in CDE and some who come to us from outside, but a very bright team, talented team, and hard-working team.
Many of them are here.
I'd ask them to stand and we just acknowledge them one more time.
The entire executive team, if you would.
I'll just give you a few highlights.
We rounded out the year with a great STEAM symposium.
There were hundreds, thousands, more than 3,000 participants, students, and educators engaged in conversation.
As a moment of personal privilege, I had the opportunity to sit on stage
with Kareem Abdul-Jabbar who's become a champion for engaging school-age youth in STEAM.
I'm honored that we were sitting on stage and not standing because he is as tall as you have seen but he has really become a champion for STEAM and it was an honor to have him
Many of our staff had the chance to hear directly the story from Ellen Ochoa, who was the first Latina to go into outer space.
And for her to tell her story was an opportunity for many young women and others.
All of us can be proud of her accomplishments and learn about STEAM and hope and wish for what we can provide for our students.
December also marked the release of dashboard data.
I'm pleased to let you know that there's progress on four out of our six statewide indicators.
We saw graduation rates go up, suspension rates go down, college and career readiness rates grew, and math and English language arts test scores are up.
The number of school districts that are eligible for state assistance is also down.
We have much more work to do clearly in
in closing the gap in achievement and opportunity for our students, but I'm happy to report to you these improvements in these indicators in the release of dashboard data.
To alert you that the
The CSU trustees will be taking action this month to potentially add a new requirement for our students.
It would be a, you know, it's been shorthanded as a fourth year of math.
It's a quantitative reasoning requirement that the trustees
voting on.
There have been a number of conversations about the benefits.
There have been conversations about any unintended consequences that could result in adding another requirement at a time when we continue to work to increase our work and A to G requirements and how students get prepared for college.
The CSU, I'm sorry, at CDE we hosted a number of roundtables on the subject and most recently we hosted a meeting between the leadership of the CSU and a number of the advocates who have expressed concern about the proposal.
The Lieutenant Governor also participated in a robust conversation and so we wanted to alert you that this is the month that the CSU trustees will be voting on the quantitative reasoning proposal.
There's also, as you all know and know that from this agenda, there'll be a great deal of discussion about LCFF.
And today you'll hear a presentation about the LCAP and some redesign efforts that are being recommended for you.
As you know, at the same time, there's a robust conversation taking place statewide about LCFF, in particular about concentration grants funding and supplemental funding.
and how it is used to reach those students who need all the additional support that they can get.
And so the state auditor released the report just before the end of the year that has led to a lot of statewide conversation.
We created an ad hoc working group of practitioners and educators and experts and others to have a conversation about LCFF, to talk about what are the opportunities around LCFF and are there ways to better track how those dollars get spent
But bottom line, how do we maximize the resources that are made available?
We invited a number of data experts to present, and what they've shared with us is that LCFF is working.
and that there are examples of places where there need to be enhancements.
One of the things that our experts have pointed out is that in spite of these investments, many of the districts where our students struggle the most have the teachers who have the least amount of experience.
And so we certainly can see that there is a need for coaching.
and training and professional learning that supports our teachers and to continue to work on closing our teacher shortage and to support educators, retain them and make sure they get the best training.
Our CDE work group will continue to engage in conversation.
Just know that at the same time, there have been a number of bills in the area of LCFF that have been introduced and more may be introduced.
You may hear from legislators,
even as recent as today, who would like to share with you their feelings that there needs to be more ability to track how every single dollar that has been offered, particularly in supplemental and concentration grants, how those dollars get spent.
And so I wanted to alert you to that and let you know that we have a broad group
that represents all the educational stakeholders, folks who work in the financial side of the house, administrators, educators who are advocates and parents.
We've invited parent groups to be a part of our work group.
And so you will hear, we will share with you and report out what we find from those groups and have it help shape the conversation around LCFF.
With that, I would submit to any questions.
This concludes my report, Madam President.
Thank you.
I thought maybe you had a question.
Good report, yes.
You get an A on that report.
For all the times I didn't get an A, it's much appreciated.
So I'll just add a few additional comments.
And again, welcome to all of you to the first meeting of 2020.
Hope you had a wonderful holiday season.
I'd like to add just a note about the accomplishments of Michelle center and her assessment team and the accountability division.
You know, we have the most substantial testing operation in the country.
Um, you know, smarter, balanced technology based operation, which for year after year after year has been undertaken without glitches.
I don't know if you've watched the news across the country, but there are places that crash and burn annually.
as they try to engage in these kinds of assessments.
Enormous amount of work done to help educators in the field learn how to engage with the assessment process.
Innovative work at the pioneering edges of assessment and how we can measure more ambitious problem solving skills and so on.
So I just wanted to
I add that we're not only appreciative in a general way of that work, but we also appreciate the high quality of the work that she and others in the division have led.
And they've all gone back to their desks and they're busy doing that work, but we can tell them.
As Tony noted, the CDE launched the dashboard last month, which was available for the first time in Spanish, Vietnamese, Mandarin, Tagalog, and English.
So that's another part of that.
And of course, this is the first time we've launched the dashboard and data quest reports simultaneously.
And what that does is really allow us to demonstrate how California has publicly embraced a multiple measures accountability system.
So that's a very important benchmark as well.
As Tony mentioned, the dashboard shows that our schools are making slow and steady progress on nearly all of the student success measures.
I was particularly struck by the fact that the state graduation rate, which increased two percentage points from 84% to 86%, is up 11 percentage points from what it was a decade ago.
So that's quite an extraordinary achievement.
A steep slope of progress over that time and African American students gained the most all groups of students gain in that process, but African American students just in this year, I gained 6 percentage points.
So that's a very noteworthy accomplishment as well.
Our suspension rate fell again from.
3.5 to 3.4%, but again, if you go back about seven years, it was almost twice as high, closer to 6%.
So, we're seeing the slow and steady progress is really, over time, making substantial progress.
State college career readiness rate grew 1.8% 44% of our students are now graduating ready for post high school paths Obviously lots more to do there, but we can see that folks are working on it And as the superintendent mentioned we increased in math and English language arts scores that we saw some narrowing of gaps But there's a lot more work
that we want to do there.
And the results show that we need to particularly focus in on students with disabilities, long-term English learners, students living in poverty, where there's progress being made, but we need to increase our efforts.
Uh, we did see a rise in chronic absenteeism rates, a 1.1% rise.
A number of factors could have contributed to that, um, including some of the natural disasters that were experienced across the state, uh, which can create all kinds of disruption, homelessness, you know, disruption of food, healthcare, transportation, as well as housing.
Um, county offices of education will be working to determine the specific local causes, and that's an area where we obviously want to double down and be sure that we're
I'm doing all of the work that is needed to help kids be in school.
I just want you to know that you can tap this treasure trove of information.
Now there's a dashboard mobile app for your smartphone and your tablet.
You can download it at the Apple Store or the Microsoft Store or the Google Play Store.
And if this is what makes you excited, Ting is ready to go.
Please feel free to browse around.
It's a lot of great information.
I also want to thank Cindy Kazanas and the AMART staff for their hard work on the dashboard.
Thank you, Cindy, and team.
And yeah, the rollout went off without a hitch.
And all of the work that went into it, 73 separate data files, each containing millions of pieces of data, go into the dashboard.
And Cindy personally, yeah.
Make sure that all of that happens.
It takes about two months for the staff to put the dashboard together for the launch.
So congratulations to Cindy, to the CDE.
I look forward to more great work from your team and to more progress from all of us in the year ahead.
Uh, and we'll now take up item 2 to discuss the local control and accountability plan template, which we are now queued up to discuss.
Uh, the CDE recommends that we adopt the proposed revised template and allow the CDE in collaboration with.
State board staff to make any necessary typographical or formatting corrections as the document is prepared for posting on the C. D. E. website and further that the state board adopt the 2019 20 L. cap annual update template.
This item is presented by Jeff Breshears of the C. D. E. and.
Also, by Stephanie Gregson.
So Stephanie and Jeff, please begin.
All right.
Good morning.
Happy New Year.
I'm Stephanie Gregson, Deputy Superintendent of the Instruction and Measurement Branch.
And beside me, behind me, is Jeff Breshears of the Local Accountability Systems Support Office.
We're both excited to be here and talk through the recommendations for the Local Control Accountability Plan, otherwise known as the LCAP.
This process all began in September 2018, when Assembly Bill 1808 was signed, requiring the redesign of the LCAP template.
Since then, CDE, with Jeff and his team leading, has engaged with stakeholders in a feedback cycle that shaped the LCAP redesign template and instructions we present to you today.
As we know, the LCAP template is a document that memorializes a plan for how a district will effectively serve their students.
The critical element is the implementation and the progress monitoring of the LCAP.
Once the State Board takes action on the template and instructions, training opportunities will be rolled out utilizing multiple partnerships and ongoing development and implementation support will be provided because that is the key.
As I mentioned previously, Jeff and his team conducted a very inclusive stakeholder feedback process.
They started with an LCAP clean slate, meaning they began only with the statutory requirements and purposely didn't include the previous template so stakeholders could be innovative and not be beholden to the previous template.
The cycle of engagement started with what the field said.
That input was provided to the advisory group to begin shaping the template.
The advisory group consisted of representatives from districts, county offices of education, charter school, California Teachers Association, the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence, and advocacy groups represented by public advocates.
Their work was then shared with the planning group of CDE and state board representatives.
Thus, the cycle was repeated.
Get input from the field on the template options.
Share that with the advisory and planning groups.
Provide update to the State Board of Education.
Seeking input from the field again through the online survey.
Synthesize the results with the advisory and the planning groups.
And what you will hear today will be the recommended redesign that was developed through the stakeholder engagement process.
You will see we have been as responsive as possible within the confines of the statutory language.
In fact, we were so responsive, we were doing add-ups up to the day of posting, and we have more that Jeff will be presenting today.
And here are just a few numbers and dates that represent the stakeholder engagement process I explained, with 24 in-person presentations to over 1,300 participants, 316 participants in a Tuesday at two webinar, and over 1,000 participants in the online survey.
And all of these meetings.
So I'd like to thank all of those that provided input and feedback throughout this entire process.
I'd also like to publicly acknowledge and appreciate Jeff and his team for their work in this inclusive stakeholder engagement process.
Because of their due diligence, all their traveling, and their work, we were able to bring this LCAP template to you today.
So with that, I'll hand it over to Jeff to walk you through the LCAP changes.
Good morning, Jeff Breshears, local agency system support office.
Get my binder right and we'll get going.
So part of the statute that was changed, set forth, brought all the separate
sections of Ed Code that required the LCAP and the annual update into one section, which is 52064.
And then within that section brought some responsibilities and requirements of this LCAP and the LCAP redesign to include the instructions and just the way we would move forward.
One of the changes was the accessibility of language.
And very similar to what we did, and you approved the budget overview for parents,
was to have the outward-facing, if you will, prompts of the template as really kind of a lead sentence to let the public know what they would be reading within the response.
It's a paradigm shift.
I'll acknowledge that, and I have fallen prey to that shift as well.
In the current template we have now, much of the requirements and much of the instructions and the technical aspects of the template is in the prompts, and so the instructions have been kind of secondary, if you will.
Now, the instructions, the outward facing, like I said, is for the public and I'll demonstrate that in a little bit.
And then the instructions are those, the technical nature for LEAs to provide them and guide them as they develop their LCAP.
It's very important to say that the instructions are very much part of the LCAP and guide and have those requirements.
Also with the changes is to encourage a different planning process, looking at data from the dashboard and local data, and take that data and prioritize one's approach and LEA's approach to develop goals and service to really meet student outcomes.
Looking at the dashboard, like I said, and also to however the goals, and we'll talk about the goals and it has changed from what we presented to you in September.
However the goals are developed by the LEAs, the LEAs must continue to track progress on all the metrics of all the LCFF priorities.
Also developed was and required was the development of an expenditure summary table.
Some of the changes within that in the funds is that there's no longer the requirement to track expenditures for actions using SACS code.
and it does not delineate or differentiate of LCF funds between base supplemental and concentration grant funds rather than their LCFF funds that are utilized to increase or improve services for our unduplicated student groups.
However, they are required, LEAs and the LCAPs are required to identify the fund source for the actions that will be implemented to meet the goals and then also break those actions down between personnel and non-personnel expenditures.
The expenditures table, also the idea was to substantially reduce the size of the LCAPs.
And our office took a current county office LCAP and the information from that and input it into the prototype and draft that we're recommending to you and actually reduce that LCAP almost in half, actually a little greater than half and brought it down.
So we believe that the expenditure tables and the new redesign will in fact
lessen the length and shorten the length of the LCAPs which has been problematic and part of the feedback.
One of the also part of the expenditure tables is consolidating all in one table the actions that are considered to be meeting the increase for improved services requirement.
And I'll say that in one of the public feedback sessions in Ventura, there was quite a number of parents and as we presented this table,
that was well received by the parents and their comments were that it puts it in one spot.
They can see within the LCAP and the summary table in one place those actions and those expenditures and those resources that are being used to meet the needs of these higher needs students.
So one of the also in the instructions specify that any LEAs that have a numerically significant group of English learners must include actions at a minimum about its EL language acquisition programs and also professional development activities related to English learners within the LCAPs.
I'll remind the staff now or the board now, pardon me, that the statute also says in enumerating the instructions and enumerating what needs to be in the template also says that
That is only, which is identified to be in the statute, is only what the board can put in the template.
And to add an action, which is part of the public feedback, is to add an actual box, if you will, or a template within the template for actions for English learners, it goes beyond statute, we believe, and it is in the instructions.
And I would also just remind, again, as I said, that the instructions are part of the LCAP and are part of the requirements.
However these actions are, LEAs will continue to report progress on its metrics.
So now I'm going to go through by section.
We'll talk about it and move on.
So here is the plan summary in almost its entirety.
We did not highlight the CSI prompts because we're not asking for that change.
We took action.
We'll discuss that a little bit in the process in item eight, but those are not being changed and not asking for changes to that.
I would point here, and we'll discuss a little bit of it, but looking at the prompt, especially for general information, you'll see it's very pretty straightforward and simple, telling the stakeholders that they're gonna read a description of the LEA, its schools, and its students.
And then as you look at the instructions, I'll point out a couple things.
You can see, again, the general information talks more about what the expectation is within that prompt to talk about the general information of its LEA.
All of the instructions, we've also included a statement of purpose, again, to guide the LEA, what a well-written, if you will, and also, I'm going to get in trouble for that again, a well-developed plan summary looks like and how to develop that, and then, again, the requirements and instructions.
Here are the general information.
the reflections of successes, and then reflections of identified need.
You'll see throughout my presentation some blue text.
I think it's just a highlight point because there's not a highlight, ability to highlight, but just talk about some of the stakeholder feedback and just to address that as we go along.
One of the statements and part of the feedback was on the identified need is as we continuously improve, what if we get to the point and we hope we get to the point that we have no students in red and orange, we have not necessarily a performance gap, there's gotta be other ways to have identified need.
And responsive to that, then we added this, that other needs may be identified using local data and also data that would inform the self-reflection tool.
It is available, you can go beyond just if you're not red and orange and if you don't have performance gaps.
As Stephanie mentioned, we opened up a plans, a LCAP redesign survey.
We had over 1,000 participants and there is different number of responses for each section.
One is very dissatisfied with the section, four being extremely satisfied, two being somewhat dissatisfied, three being somewhat satisfied.
So you can see here within the plan summary as this was presented to the survey that overall the plan survey was well received.
So moving on, and I'm showing survey results, because if you remember in September, we presented a stakeholder engagement section that was really vertically aligned.
It identified all the groups that needed to be consulted with.
And to the right was, it looked like just a checkbox.
And I would say in error, I mean, it was good for the feedback.
It looked like it was just a checkbox.
It was intended for a narrative response.
so with that we we took that information back and feedback from from you from the board and Changed all of that information from a vertical orientation to a horizontal orientation that that lent to more of a Narrative response and then also in talking with the planning group and the advisory group we came up with another
Version alternative and you'll see where we landed is is closer to alternative B But you can see that it was pretty flat with the alternative a on what we presented to you in September and even when we change it like I said to a horizontal orientation it's pretty flat as far as reception and
Some of the themes about alternative A is tedious, it's repetitive, what if your teacher said one thing, your parents said another thing, you're just cutting and pasting, it just felt very compliance driven.
Though there was some response that it did support that inclusion process.
Alternative B skews a little bit more to the right with the satisfaction.
Again, it's more of a narrative that allows the LEAs to tell a story about their stakeholder engagement process.
We really tried to model, as Stephanie said, during this redesign project to really model stakeholder engagement and receive feedback for it.
Again, some of the themes from Alternative B.
Again, it doesn't identify each stakeholders.
Again, we address that, and I'll show you that.
The positive is streamlined, concise.
You can read that.
Overall, we ask in the question in the survey, what do you prefer, A or B?
You can see that Alternative B had about a 60-40 split.
The Alternative B was preferred.
So where we landed, again, with talking within the planning group and the advisory group, we landed here.
You'll see the red specific.
That is a proposed change that we'll be asking you in the recommendation.
It's one of the continued responsive.
And we appreciate this, is we added specific, you'll see in prompt two, and we had specific in the instructions, we just missed a couple specifics in two and three, and so we're adding it there, that's an add.
So that would be one of the recommendations to accept this change.
Part of also is you'll see in the red, again the red is recommended changes to what we're asking you to change and part of the feedback was stakeholder engagement historically has been problematic for the development of the LCAP.
So we're responsive to that and we really want to support how that is and when we talk about rollout and some of the trainings we have partnered with
And you'll see with different organizations to really roll this out and share the responsibility of what this looks like with the different groups and their constituents to really hopefully to hone this as better.
We did specify the regulations and statutes says what you need to do and what it looks like and then also the again in the red is to say that superintendents of school districts and county offices with their parent advisory committees and if they have the numbers that require an English learner parent advisory committee that LCAP must be presented to those committees for review and comment.
And then the superintendent is required to respond to those comments in writing.
And a request was to articulate that within the LCAP and the instructions.
And we have done so there.
I'll also point out, though it's hard to see at the bottom right-hand corner, the website and a link to a CDE's web page.
And again, being responsive.
And what you saw there is show on that web page is the LCAP web page.
But with that, talks about the orientation
the composition of the parent advisory committees, the composition requirements for English learner parent advisory committees, and also a definition of student engagement and what that looks like and what it means to engage students in what student consultation looks like.
Here's prompt one, an instruction again that we put
And an excerpt from the audit guide showing that these are the legal requirements for the consultation and the development of the LCAP and just highlighting that within the LCAP.
Here again, you look, prompt two, the addition of specific where we missed it again, like I said previously.
And also those seeing that in prompt one, within their response, within their storytelling, they need to describe how they met the obligation to meet and consult with all the required stakeholder.
And then also you can see in prompt two that the feedback, again, the response is talk about what was provided by the specific stakeholder groups and how it influenced, you'll see in prompt three, how did it influence the development of and how did the LEA respond to the stakeholder feedback that described in prompt two.
You can see that the aspects and just kind of talk about the themes and this is what may be included in that response for prompt three.
So now moving to goals and actions.
Again, if you remember in September, again, responding to you and to the feedback, we had the idea because the statute says that the instructions must encourage LEAs to consider prioritizing their approach and prioritize an approach to LCFF metrics and priorities.
And so we brought to you two options.
Pardon me.
One option A was a prioritized goal or a focus goal, very focused and lasered in like a SMART goal.
And then option B, what we'll talk about in a second, was very much similar to what is being developed now within the LCAP.
Again, you can see the pretty flat of the liking of the option A of just a template for a focus goal.
You can see that it was complicated, tedious, cumbersome, confusing, and we found even as we tried to explain it, it was complicated, tedious, cumbersome, and confusing.
So we just, you know, moved from that, and you'll see again where we landed.
Option B, again, was more of what is currently in the template, and that was felt more positive in response, and you'll see, and we'll discuss where we landed and what we're asking you to approve.
Again, some of the themes of option B, one is more concise, but it was easier to read and better for the stakeholders.
So here is the goals, measuring the metrics, if you will, and the actions.
And we'll talk about that more section by section as we move forward.
So the goal here is pretty straightforward.
And again, in the instructions, we'll talk about a focus goal, we'll talk about a broad goal, and we'll also talk about maintenance of progress goal that we talked about last time in September.
And just this pretty straightforward description of what they want to accomplish and why they developed this goal.
You'll note here that we didn't ask for them to identify is this a focus goal, is this a broad goal, is this a maintenance of progress goal.
But within the explanation, the LEA has an opportunity to say what and how it is.
And it doesn't have to have a label.
You're able to see how the goal is developed.
And then you'll see that that goal, the expectation, regardless of what goal is written, that there is a tie between the goal and the metrics that are associated with this goal.
So again, the purpose, well-developed goals will clearly communicate.
You can see this.
And then I'll talk about here the changes that was requested and we had some conversation.
Originally we had LEAs were strongly encouraged to assess the performance of the students looking at dashboard.
That opportunity is in back up in the reflections of needs, identified needs.
There was an ask to put shall instead of should in this where you see should and where we landed.
And the shall, we talked about it, one of the unintended consequences is one, how do you enforce that and how do you ensure that in such a way as this is going through the review and progress.
The should is consistent with the instructions and consistent with statute.
Again, if you look at this in a picture, as LEAs look at their data,
and have the data tell a story, they're going to, again, they're responsive in the plan summary, but they'll be responsive in looking at the student groups and their performance as they develop goals.
So again, this is a requested change that we're asking you to consider and adopt when I finish.
So here's the discussion is, and it's kind of redundant here in the next slide, but we'll talk about the types of goals, what they are.
Again, you don't have to identify it, but these are the expectations and types of goals of what you could do, and make sure more detailed in the explanations and expectations and an explanation of why you develop these goals and how you link these goals to the actions and the metrics within that goal section.
So here is one benefit and also responsive to the LCFF audit report.
I'm glad to say that we were already in the process of doing this because of the statute, but it's nice to know that we were in line with the audit report and what we're doing.
In that, you can see here that you have year one outcome, year two and three outcomes.
It is bringing together the actions and the annual update.
In the current template, and we'll talk about it for the bridge for later for the 19-20 school year, there's a complete separate section for the annual update.
A lot of copy and pasting, pretty tedious work that was not well received.
And so here, it's in one place.
The metric, the baseline, we'll talk a little bit about.
The year outcomes will be blank for now in the first year because we'll look at the outcomes for first year.
But again, and consistent with what the board did three years ago is went from a year-to-year rolling LCAP to a three-year inclusive LCAP, really encouraging a long-term, long-range goal setting.
So the last column there is where do you want to be three years from now?
Where are you going to be and how are you going to, you're setting your course and that's where you want to be.
Instructions, don't need to read them, it's just again, just highlighting what they are and looking at it.
I would say that the baseline data is the, and any of the data, is the most recent data available.
Sometimes it's gonna be from the dashboard in the year previous, pardon me, such as the graduation rate.
But you can also have a point in time as an LEA develops at LCAP to look at
data that it owns.
It owns the data.
I appreciate Cindy Kazanis.
She works with LEAs.
It's your data.
We're massaging it and putting it forth in the dashboard.
And so looking at your data, and the most recent data you have is the metric, is how you would report those metrics, the baseline will remain unchanged for the three year.
Where we are now, where do we want to be three years from now, and make that comparison as to your progress.
The the instructions talking about the outcomes just just reiterating using the most recent data consistent with the instructions We just talked about So here's the actions again this will tie back to the Expenditure tables because if one is using and again as I said in September this redesign really begs the use of an e-template and
Because this would all be automated for you.
If you use the posted version of a Word doc and an Excel document, there will be some cut and pasting and some duplication of Word.
But the eTemplate is being developed in that.
that data that is put in the data entry box, and as one fills out the LCAP on the e-template, the total funds is drawn from the expenditure tables with the breakdown of funds, but the total funds, and then whether or not these actions are contributing to meeting that increase for improved services requirement for unduplicated students, and the description allows to begin that process of explaining if it is,
What are those needs and circumstances that brought about that one would write these actions to meet the goals?
Again, the instructions.
I would point out again the English learners, the actions for English learners that's consistent with statute.
And also in response to and appreciate the feedback from stakeholders is foster youth have very unique needs, very similar to homeless students and very unique barriers to their education and to their access to the education.
And they just encourage, the stakeholders encourage to provide language to encourage LEAs to consider that and write actions specific to their foster youth.
You'll note the difference in language in that action for English learners, if they have a numerically significant group of English learners, they must do this.
We can't say you must do this for foster youth because it would be outside of statute, but certainly asking to look at and encourage inclusion and look at those unique needs of foster youth and appreciate that feedback during this process.
Another aspect, again, of combining the goals and actions is the annual update and annual analysis, pardon me, of the goal.
Again, it's not a separate section.
It is here.
You can see at the bottom there that it says that the actual expenditures will be inputted in the data entry table.
Again, goal analysis, the instructions, looking at it, at the overall implementation, how well did you do?
And if there's any substantially difference from what you intended to do and what you actually did, you would respond in the first, in that first response measure taken from that that might result in a material difference of what you plan to expend and what you actually expended.
And then you can read that.
I won't read it to you and go through.
And then the last bullet is, describe changes as a result.
I mean, that's part of that continuous improvement expectation is, as a result of your analysis, what changes are you going to make to that heading of where you want to be three years from now?
couple changes here that we'll talk about probably in the instructions but I would say even the title this is again brought about and asked about in stakeholders instead of just saying unduplicated students or increase for improved services call them out who are and just to remind the public and the stakeholders that are foster youth English learners and low-income students really have those unique needs and they are our unduplicated student groups and and what does that look like
The instructions and talking about, again, the purpose and what it would look like to do that, and again, the requirements for those, the percentage based on the increase of the allocations based on the number and concentration of students, of unduplicated students, and what is the expectation to increase or improve the services over and above to all other students.
In the first prompt, you'll see here,
for each action being provided.
That is the same prompt in bold at the top of the slide.
And you notice the language that says we're considered first.
Part of the ask and part of the feedback from stakeholders is this should say was prioritized.
And we chose and landed with and stayed consistent with we're considered first.
Because this is consistent with the uniform complaint procedures that we have written, appeals that have come to the CDE, our office, and the reports that we have issued.
Some of the language looking down below for principally directive, excuse me, is consistent with that language.
And so we felt to be consistent with the guidance that has been put forth that we would stay consistent with that and use considered first.
There was a call to make sure that the instructions talked about district-wide.
District-wide is the same as LEA-wide or school-wide basis because this is pertinent to districts, to county offices and charters, and so this is more inclusive of LEA-wide than just using the language of district-wide.
point out to the next is the actions continued from and these are actions that are being considered as meeting the increase for improved services requirement and at some point one must evaluate are these actions effective and can they still be considered as meeting and contributing to meeting that increase for improved services requirement.
Again, consistent with what the board did in moving from the year-to-year rolling to a three-year LCAP and where you want to be three years from now.
We're asking LEAs to look at what is in the current LCAP and any actions that they're considering as contributing to meeting that requirement.
Are they effective?
And if they're not effective, or if they still want to continue on, then there's the requirement and the expectation is to explain why they're continuing these actions from the last three-year LCAP into this template and how it meets those needs.
Again, looking at this is, you don't necessarily see improvement after one year, right?
It is a three-year goal, it is a long-term goal, and that's where we want to be from there.
I point out the principally directive and effective language and that which follows, and then also the conclusory statements that is serviced and those language that follows.
This again is responsive to the LCFF audit report.
Again, we were looking at that, but the audit report really needs to talk about within the instructions within the LCAP.
how one considers the needs of our students, the unduplicated students, in developing those actions that are being considered as contributing to meeting the increase for improved services requirement.
This talks a little bit more about the percentage of students and the expectations and the threshold of the expectation of explanation of how one would do based on enrollment of those students.
And then again, a description of how students, how they are meeting the increase or improved services requirement.
And again, this is compared to services that the LEA would provide to all students in that year.
It's not a year-over-year requirement, but in that year, how are you increasing the services for your foster youth, English learners, and low-income students over and above what you're providing to all students.
So here's the expenditure table, and one is the data entry.
I would just point out a couple things, again, being responsive and appreciate this, is the fourth column there, you say student groups, and part of the feedback is, okay, so what if we have a specific need for a student group that is not an unduplicated student group?
How do we identify that these actions are focused toward a specific need?
Let's say we have a high rate of suspension, we have a low reading rate for a specific group.
We want to be able to develop an action and then identify that student group.
And so that was an addition that we put there.
The location would be in conjunction with any provision of service, but specifically if you're doing it for unduplicated students.
Time span would be, is this for the entire three years?
Is this a one-year action, a two-year action?
You can see the breakdown of personnel and non-personnel, and then the other funds.
From this data entry,
That will inform these other tables, the total expenditures.
Again, you can see and then look at the bottom, the total of breakdown of dollars for personnel and non-personnel and the other funds.
Again, it will inform the contributing table that we talked about.
These are the actions that are considered contributing to meeting the increase for improved services requirement.
I mean, you can see there the totals of the different types of approach, the totals and that which is LEA-wide targeted to a specific, just to a specific group or a school-wide total.
The annual update, this is again with the only thing that would be, that's not fed from the data entry would be the total estimated actual expenditures and that would be where that point in time when an LEA is developing its LCAP
They would then, at that point, look at where they are, where they expect to be at the end of the year, and then estimate what those actual expenses will be for these expenditures.
Again, instructions.
I'm talking about the scope, the unduplicated, the, again, I would say the student groups, indicate the student groups that will be the primary beneficiary of action.
If it's all, you would say all, but again, it provides the opportunity to highlight any service specific to a group.
More instructions.
And again, here is the survey results, and you can see that with these changes and with the survey, it was skewed to the right pretty well, accepted and favorable and comfortable with the summary table.
The negative, you can see.
I would say the positive, and this is from an LEA, is like, wow, we're already doing this, and now you provide the tool that we have been developed with it, and thank you for that.
It helps with the work.
So now moving to the annual update template, the statute requires that every year that the LEA develops an LCAP and its annual update, and looking at it and the desire to keep the current three-year template, 2017 through 2020,
Separate from the 2020 to 23, 2023 template, we need to have an annual update that would not, again, to keep them separate.
So this template is very similar, almost exact to what we're doing now.
The thought was that is like, let's not teach yet another new aspect and a new requirement to LEAs, but continue on with what they're used to doing for this annual update.
Again, very, very straightforward.
The only change that is with this is the last prompt.
The current prompt is, reflecting on your analysis, what changes have you made and where can we find it within the LCAP?
Well, it's a new LCAP, so we're just asking is, how did this inform the development of your goals for the 2023 LCAP?
Again, the instructions, very straightforward, taken from the instructions in the current template with, again, just the
difference of that last prompt.
Again, this is our timeline that Stephanie shared with us.
We're here, hopefully SBE takes action in that green arrow or that green dot.
Our first training, and I'll show the next slide of our opportunities, but true, our first training opportunity and partnership opportunity is this Friday at nine o'clock with some county offices and the student services group.
Ongoing we have we will begin a I'm Tuesday at 2 I think that's the second bullet starting next Tuesday a series of six or seven presentations Which was trying to figure it out just to roll out each of the section the expectations and what that would look like Friday is the student program and services steering committee and then you can see our partnerships that we have already Worked with to meet the needs of their groups specific and we'll do the training the L caps yell cap can't change the L cap but certainly to
to look at what would meet their specific needs within this.
We're negotiating dates with the public advocates and also with the California system support and the geographic needs.
With that.
So this is, again, a revision of the recommendation that's in the posted item, and that is that we recommend that the State Board of Education adopt the proposed revised LCAP template to include the suggested revisions made on pages three, 10, 11, and 12 of the posted version of the LCAP, and then allow the CDE in collaboration with the SBE staff to make any necessary topographical or formatting corrections as the document is prepared for posting on the CDE website.
Further, CDE recommends that the SVE adopt the 2019-2020 LCAP annual template update.
And with that, I'd be glad to answer any questions.
All right.
Thank you very, very much.
First, I just want to start by thanking you and all the staff for the amount of both work and analysis and responsiveness to the feedback that you have been engaged with over many months.
I think when we were chatting about it the other day, Dave said it might have been three and a half years that we've really been involved in developing this.
So, thank you very much for that.
I want to turn to Sue Burr and Eileen Strauss, our accountability liaisons, if they have any initial comments.
And then if there are specific clarifying questions, we'll take a few of those as needed, but then we'll get to public comment and come back for more media discussion.
So, Sue?
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
And I would just echo her comments about you saw from the timeline and Stephanie helped lay out what an arduous process this has been.
So I really appreciate it.
I think your commitment to transparency and to including everybody who has any stake in this game in these discussions has borne fruit.
So I really appreciate that.
I just, for purposes of sort of context, and I hope the public comment, want to call to your attention, it's kind of buried here, but in the instructions on attachment one, page eight, I think in the middle of that document we kind of get to the heart of what this is, what the LCAP template is and is not, and that it's a document, not a process.
It talks about what the three main components are,
reflect comprehensive strategic planning.
We emphasize that over and over again.
That's what this is.
That it's through meaningful engagement with stakeholders and that it meets legal requirements.
And then there's a lot of additional text there that I think really helps provide the context for this.
And there's a specific question in the middle of that page that I think if LEAs will keep in mind that given their present performance across the state priorities, how's the LEA using its money to make sure that they're meeting the needs of students?
It's easy to kind of get lost.
Honestly, this kind of makes my eyes numb over it.
It reminds me of what school facilities used to be like.
And so it's easy to kind of lose what this is about, but I think you've really captured it here in the narrative and I just wanted to call that out because it's kind of buried in the middle of this item and again express my appreciation for all of your work.
Sue?
So I just appreciate, Jeff, first of all, the comprehensive process that you went through, the patience and the detail that you listened to.
I appreciated the feedback that after you looked at the strategy to improve the feedback to see if you were on track with the
with the stakeholders.
The other thing is we had asked you to clarify for us as a board what was the statute and what could the LCAP do based on the statute.
So I thought that was really helpful.
I would say based on talking to school districts, it's really helpful that you reduce by half the length of the LCAP.
So I think that was actually really helpful.
I think it's still really clear to focus the county offices on how they review the LCAP to make sure that the districts have followed what they needed to do.
It's very comprehensive in a district process, but what the role of the county offices is and how I'm hoping that county offices will help districts in making sure they're focused.
I know there is some concern, not that the plan's not comprehensive sometimes, but does the county office look at the specifics, particularly with the subgroups?
I appreciated the rollout strategy and the partnership that you've reached out to with all the different organizations and just to encourage continuing that to make it relevant to those groups.
And I just appreciate also the issue of trying to better explain the services that were increased or improved for the subgroups.
I think that's really our concern is, are the subgroups getting the support they need?
And if it's district wide, how is it going to help those subgroups?
Sometimes, in fact, focusing on math standards to improve math instruction actually does really help all kids.
But I think that's really important.
And I just think it's such a comprehensive process.
We promised that we would stay in an evolving process, but we wouldn't change the LCAP every single year because we will drive districts nuts, but that every three years we would improve it.
And I feel like this has been just a huge process.
So I know we're gonna listen to input from our public here who are making comments, but just so appreciate the thoroughness of addressing what the board asked you to do in this process.
Thank you.
Uh, I'm going to take the prerogative of the chair to ask 1 clarifying question and then see if there are any other clarifying questions for members of the board and then we'll get to public comment.
Um, thank you so much.
And, um, so, uh, Eileen just mentioned the fact that, um.
you reviewed the statute and what it does and doesn't allow us to do.
And having reviewed the letters and not having heard specifically as much about this yet, I'd just like you to kind of link that to the questions about the inclusion of the English learner strategy on the template itself as opposed to just in the instructions, because I think those issues are related.
So can you kind of clarify that for us?
have the opportunity to rely on counsel if they yeah please feel free certainly be the instructions that the the Ed code is laid out in such that in in section B says this is what shall be included in the template and it lays out the expenditure tables it's you know the goals and actions and what that would look like
In section E, it talks about what the instructions shall include and how to develop those instructions and what must be.
In section D of that section, there's two, I forget what one, I didn't print it, but subparagraph two under subparagraph D says, except as provided to the allow to inclusion of
information for federal law that the board shall not require school districts, county offices of education, or charter schools to provide any information in addition to that which is included in subparagraph B, which is all of those expectations in the template in itself.
And so the instructions say you must include in the instructions actions to tell LEAs that they must include actions for their English learners if they have a numerically significant group.
And so that is in the instructions, but it does not allow for the, if you will, a template within the template for those actions.
And practically, what that also does is if it was there, it kind of limits the local control of where it would best fit within their development of their plans, actions, and services, and their goals of if you put it in a specific spot, it would be limiting to that.
But overarching is that we believe that to do so would be contrary to what's allowed in statute.
Okay.
Thank you.
I really appreciate that.
We've got a few clarifying questions.
We'll start with Member Rucker and then we'll come around.
Okay, so first of all, I want to add my kudos to this work.
When we started with this LCAP and created the first template, we knew it was woefully inadequate, both as a planning tool and the guidance that was given to district resulted in a continuum of responses for monitoring from county offices across the state.
I, in particular, remember one county office that rejected every single LCAP that they received.
You guys remember when that happened?
because of the way the guidance was working.
So I do appreciate how much this template is evolved.
And what it also represents to me, however, and this is going to lead to my particular clarifying question, it's on the point that you just made.
What this plan has done in developing and evolving
as it shows, is that we really didn't understand the full impact and the flexibility and the authority the board had in developing the template originally.
And with the addition of guidance from the legislation that was subsequently added, more work was done to improve this template.
So I'm going to say I still think we are not fully flexing the authority that we have in crafting this template, particularly in the guidance or even in the guidance we're giving to county offices in supporting districts.
And I'm particularly... Is there a clarifying question?
Yeah, so this is where the question is.
So I'm particularly concerned knowing that our board president has said that English learners in particular English long-term English learners are going to become a state priority because that's what the data in the dashboard shows.
I need to understand what does the stat what flexibility does the statute actually give us in providing either a request for additional consideration
or how the counties or the LEAs are making their priorities as it relates to this one issue, because I just heard you say, we can't ask for more information.
I need to understand what that would mean.
given the fact that we have, that this is the student subgroup that's going to clearly emerge for many districts that need to be the priority, how do you not ask for additional information about those students?
I think we can ask.
I think it's just a question of where, but I see council is at the podium, so.
Does that make sense as a clarifying question?
I need to understand, if that's the priority, how can you ask for it but not be allowed to ask for it?
David Sapp, Assistant Legal Counsel at the State Board of Education.
I think I understand the question, but please follow up if I don't address it.
It's still polite to ask.
So I think one of the issues here is that the template lays out general requirements for what must be addressed.
As the board knows, sort of fundamentally at the baseline, is that the LEA must establish goals that address the eight or 10 priorities, depending on the LEA type.
The statute was clarified to make clear that that means all of the statutorily defined metrics under those must be included as well.
So I think that this idea of the metrics was not actually in the statute until AB 1840 sort of pulled it in.
The board had sort of articulated that concept in the initial template.
It's now called out in the statute.
And essentially it is you must establish goals that address all of those and there is nothing in the statute
about the template that gives the board authority to say, and you must include a goal that is X. So I think your question, Member Rucker, is can the board include something that says districts must do particular actions or services or focus
within the LCAP development process and the final adopted LCAP.
And the answer is, as council, do not believe that there is authority for the board to require particular goals or actions to be included in the template.
With one exception, which is the one that I think has been the focus of the letter, is that the statute, AB 1840, the changes, said that the board must
including the instructions, which have the force and effect of law, that is something that when the counties review whether the template was adhered to, the statute says explicitly, including any instructions adopted by the State Board of Education for the template.
So to the extent there's any confusion about that out there, the statute has been clear since 2017 that adhering to the template means following these instructions, and so that is something that counties must review.
And so to the extent there's any uncertainty or confusion,
We will be following up just to confirm to make sure everyone is on the same page about what that means.
But what was added was the requirement the board shall include in the instructions the statement that when there are at least 30 English learners, there must be a specific action under a goal in the LCAP that describes the language acquisition programs and professional development.
So what that means is the instruction shall specify that within one of the goals adopted, that has to be there.
You answered my question, so I'm back to what I said before.
I don't think we've gone far enough to make that requirement clear in the instructions.
We can come back to this in the discussion then.
Thanks.
I'm glad we got that clarified.
Yes, Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
So I'm also very interested in coming back to that.
Happy New Year, by the way.
I have big thoughts, but I'm gonna stick to one concrete question, one clarifying question.
So let's say that a district that has a significant EL population submits their LCAP, does not include an action, does not describe their language programs, does not describe the PD.
Can the county office then deny that LCAP?
Do they have authority to deny the LCAP?
Yes.
Because I've heard mixed things that they're, you know, they're pretty much adhering to three points and content is not one of those.
So what I would say, sure.
I would slightly modify the question and say, do they have the authority?
Absolutely, but there's an actual duty to disapprove the LCAP because it is a required thing that must be included.
So again, I think to the extent there's any misunderstanding or confusion, there is now an explicit statutory requirement that is now reflected in the instructions that this information, these actions must be included.
if they meet that threshold of the number of students.
And so that is a basis where if a county approves an LCAP, or sorry, if a district adopts an LCAP that lacks that, the district has not followed the statute or the template instructions.
And if a county approves the LCAP, then the county would have not followed Education Code 52070-D1, which requires one of the elements to review of whether the LCAP adheres to the template, including instructions adopted by the State Board of Education.
And I think if I understood, not only will we be putting that in the instructions, but also training people to be alert to the fact that it's there.
Absolutely.
If I may, just with that, it's absolutely part of the rollout would be just to reinforce that and what that would look like and working with all the partners to make sure that that's understood and to really get that message out and follow that message.
Right.
I'm seeing no more clarifying questions being asked for.
Are there any others?
Before we go to public comment, then we'll come back and have a full discussion.
So, are there public comments?
Yes, we have 26 speakers signed up.
Would the following individuals please line up at the podium?
Sarah Bacchus, Enrique Rocho, Edgar Zauzuta, Steven McMahon, Nancy L. Barron, Shayla Seaton, Liz Guillen, Angela DeRamos,
Andrea Ball, Eduardo Munoz, Cherise Guerrera, Ruth Barajas, Catalina Rupert, Olivia Yahia, Caroline Cerna, Frederick Gale.
Good morning, Sarah Botches with CASBO.
Our members, public stewards of public resources have engaged with the department and state boards LCFF stakeholder sessions and thank your staff for all of their hard work.
We believe that the changes reflected in the amended LCAP template are aligned with the statutory changes approved under AB 1840.
and demonstrate substantive improvements to address accessibility and readability for all stakeholders.
We continue to support the board's ability to make modifications that reflect a genuine system of support that focuses on prioritizing action and services that meet the needs of our students while allowing discretion on how over 1,000 local education agencies will serve their students and support the educators and staff.
Thank you.
Good morning, Enrique Rocha with the San Diego Unified School District.
And I'll start by thanking the State Board and the Department of Education for your work in developing the revisions to the LCAP.
San Diego Unified supports the work that you have done.
And in the spirit of continuous improvement, the only thought we would share is to include a reference guide or a glossary of definitions to help improve the understanding for parents and community stakeholders.
But with that, thank you very much.
Yeah.
Good morning.
Edgar Sasueta on behalf of the Association of California School Administrators.
I just echo the comments of thank you for the extensive and genuine stakeholder process and engagement throughout this entire initiative.
We also believe that the changes being considered today strike the appropriate balance.
one that gets at the accessibility of improvement with the LCAP, but also keeps the spirit of the law in terms of discretion for our local educators to do the work that makes sense to those closest to the students.
So we appreciate just the effort that's been put into kind of striking that balance.
As we know, LCFF and then the accompanying LCAP, it's been an evolution, one that's been challenging both to the community and to the field at any given moment, but we do think that this is a process that's working.
As our Madam President indicated, the research shows that LCFF is working for students and we think the actions being taken today continuous on that journey.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Steven McMahon, I'm the Deputy Superintendent for the San Jose Unified School District.
Similar to Superintendent Thurman's comments, I believe that once you experience San Jose Unified, you always find your way home.
I was a student in the district K-12, I went away to college, I've come back to be a career employee.
Decades of experience with the same school district, I can emphatically say the experiences of our students today far exceed what I had as a student.
Our state has very much to be proud of.
It's a public education system that's complex and challenging, but we have a lot to be proud of.
These proposed revisions are something to be proud of.
Kudos to you for your leadership and your staff for your hard work.
They're not perfect, but they're the right direction.
As a district that's the largest in Silicon Valley and the most diverse, we've been LCFF supporters from the very beginning.
LCAP's been hard as support.
We support this.
Not only do we encourage you to adopt the revisions, we hope you stick with them.
The school districts now need to go into implementation.
We need to stop talking about changes to the template and making sure we're actually implementing that template.
We would love to see several years of using this document that we hope you approve today to improve outcomes for students.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name's Nancy Albron and I have the privilege of serving as the superintendent of San Jose Unified.
I want to thank you for the work that you've done and the work of your staff.
It's a document.
It's as good as it's going to get, we think.
We also believe that
It's time to get back to teaching and learning.
Our staff has spent a lot of time learning about the new LCAP template and we'd love to spend all that time focusing on changing outcomes for all of our students, particularly the ones that we've historically underserved for decades.
So thank you for the work.
We support the changes and we look forward to implementing for several years before there are new changes.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm representing California Teachers Association and the over 300,000 classroom teachers and educators across our state.
CTA extends our appreciation to the State Board of Education and the CDE for their extensive stakeholder engagement regarding development of the revised LCAP template.
The efforts of the staff to engage stakeholders via various input sessions, advisory groups, and online surveys is commendable and definitely reflected in this template.
We believe that the revised LCAP template will allow for more streamlined content that will in turn be more accessible to stakeholders.
CTA would also like to remind the LEAs that although stakeholder engagement section of the LCAP has been streamlined, the instructions on page 10 of the template still clearly highlight that teachers in the local bargaining units of the LEA as well as other key stakeholder groups be included in the ongoing annual process of LCAP development.
CTA urges the board to adopt the revised LCAP template.
Thanks.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond, members of the Board, Superintendent Thurmond.
I'm Dr. Shelly Seton.
I am the LCAP Director at Sacramento County Office of Education, and I am speaking on behalf of the California County Superintendents Educational Services Association.
And we are in support of the State Board adopting the CDA's recommendation of the revised template today.
As COEs, we are committed to supporting our LEAs in the development of high-quality LCAPs that really uphold the LCFF principles of equity, transparency, and accountability, and we're very much in favor of the revised instructions.
They will help to guide our work.
especially the enhancements to the instructions around the increased and improved section because it will help to ensure that our districts are considering the needs, the conditions, the circumstances of our unduplicated students as they're articulating their actions and describing how they increase and improve services for our students.
Ed Code 52070D1 states that the County Superintendent of Schools shall adopt or excuse me approve an LCAP that adheres to the template and we are committed to ensuring that we have followed the instructions as they are part of the instructions.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Jennifer Hicks.
I'm assistant superintendent for Placer County Office of Education and I'm here speaking on behalf of CSESA as well.
I'd like to share a little bit about how County Offices of Education are preparing to support districts in the development of their LCAP.
First I'd like to thank the CDE and SB staff for their collaborative approach and continued support of this work.
CCESA and COEs began discussing the necessary mindset shifts months ago in September when the first draft of the LCAP template was released and we began preparing our districts at that point for the anticipated changes specifically around those mindsets.
I really appreciate Member Burr's comment about the heart of the LCAP.
Those three areas were exactly the mindset shifts that we started to focus on months ago.
In November, close to 300 County Office of Education staff were trained on the draft LCAP template.
This initial two-day training focused on developing a common understanding of the design of the new template, planning for how to best support districts, supporting those productive mindsets.
A second two-day training will take place next week to revise and to train on the revised LCAP template.
Thank you.
Good morning, Andrea Ball here on behalf of the California Association of Suburban School Districts, a diverse group of large districts across the state, and we support the recommendation, urge you to adopt the revised template.
I want to echo or especially thank the comments from board members Burr and Strauss about this really being an evolution, but we're involved and engaged in continuous improvement.
So, I think this strikes the right balance, as my colleague said earlier.
We're happy to see that it does further the recommendations of increased accessibility for stakeholders.
Our districts are growing in their diversity, language, ethnicity, demographics, so language that is more accessible is really important.
We look forward to continuing to partnership with you.
I want to call out the staff of the CDE.
I used to work here.
I haven't come back yet, but I know these people and how hard
They work.
And I really commend them for the outreach and the online opportunity to comment and then showing us the results of some of the surveys.
That's pretty bold.
I really commend you.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Eduardo Munoz, an assistant professor at San Jose State and also an advocate with Californians Together.
But importantly for today, I'm an ILAC and DILAC representative for my home district.
First, I would like to start by appreciating the hard work that has gone into the template.
But also, continuing with my role as a parent representative, I want to emphasize and recommend that there is an inclusion on page 11, bullet B. Please insert after English Learner Advisory Committee with written response to input.
Even though that is current statute, unfortunately, it is not happening as much as it should.
And if we are really to show parents that communication with them and their input is important, we should not miss any single opportunity to make explicit what's already in the statute and make that an accountability element.
Thank you very much for your time.
Hello, my name is Cherise Gara.
I'm from SEAL and also representing Californians Together.
And like everybody else, I want to echo what a great job the revision has taken on, especially after the meeting on September 11th, and including today's revisions that were proposed.
Originally, I was going to talk about adding the word specific to priority two, so that's been taken care of, which is a great thing.
The one thing that we would recommend, though, is on page three, the prompt above the second box, adding the word each.
So now it would read a summary of feedback provided by each specific stakeholder group.
This would capture each specific stakeholder group's input, allowing for transparency and voices for each stakeholder represented.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Stephanie Segata.
I'm a parent of four at West Contra Costa Unified.
I'm also speaking here on behalf of Californians Together.
I've been serving this year six years on the district's local control accountability plan and also have been the MDAC or DLAC co-chair for the past 10 years.
Unfortunately, even though I appreciate that it is in the language, the written response should be given to our committees.
Unfortunately, at our district, up until last year, I finally received the written response for our MDAC committee.
Though it has not happened, this is the one year that all committees, English learners, African American, special ed, and the DL CASP committee will be combining to have recommendations set to our district.
So I do hope the county and the state holds them accountable to make sure that we do get ready response, because we do know.
We know that there's PTA and those are parents up in the hills in our area, but we as parents of the Flatlands know what our kids need, and we want to build that partnership with our district.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Ruth Barajas and I'm a former principal and educator teacher speaking on behalf of Californians Together.
I'm speaking about the goals and actions section and on page 13 under measuring and reporting results it states it stated that LEAs were quote encouraged to identify metrics and it now now that they should identify metrics for specific student groups and expected outcomes to narrow the achievement gap.
We are grateful for the change that now intends to address the closing of the gap that underlies the equity principle of LCFF.
But are good intentions enough?
When we tell someone that they should do something, do they do it?
They might.
But if we say shall do something, then we expect it.
And we are asking that the language and the instructions be considered part of the LCAP template, and that we include should, or excuse me, we replace should with shall.
And we believe that now is the time for you to use your flexibility of authority to make this simple change.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I am Catalina Rupert.
I have two children in public schools and I was a former EL student who struggled throughout the California system.
I'm here representing also Californians Together and I'm a volunteer but most importantly I'm a voter and the voter that cares about school system.
We appreciate the use of words such as should instead of encourage, which we hope now will guide the districts to set differentiated growth targets for students subgroups.
The legislation gave you all wide flexibility to develop the components of an accountability system which would support the accelerated growth for the unduplicated students and other subgroups.
We believe one of the basic principles of the LCFF law was to attend to the student subgroups with a history of performance gaps and provide extra resources for that purpose.
It's 2020.
Let's move forward with a clear vision of expectations and actions.
Thank you.
Good morning, happy new year.
My name is Olivia Yaya and I'm the president for the California Association of Bilingual Education.
On page 15, actions for English learners, we are recommending that the required language for all school districts with a numerically significant English learner population subgroup
30 or more, as shown on page 15, be separated and included in two other areas of the template.
The language requiring a description of the district's language acquisition program should be moved and included in the summary page 1.
The description of this language acquisition program is really not in action and is better served as an introductory material to be read as context in the summary and for the total plan.
However, the language about the professional development for teachers of English learners should be in the action section, which would clearly show that this is to be tied to the goals of English learners.
And we really appreciate the clarification that county offices has to implement the language.
Thank you.
Will the next group of speakers please line up at the podium?
Karin Satang, Pecola Manigo, Monica Green, Carlos Machado, Savannah Campbell, Angel Ann Flores, Leticia Garcia, Samantha Tran.
Good morning.
My name is Carolina Serna.
I teach at Biola University, and I'm here representing CABE as a board member.
We have read and reviewed the LCAPs for three separate years to document the goals, actions, and services for English learners.
And in all of the reviews, and especially in year four LCAPs, the most consistent finding was that 92% of district LCAPs had a rating of weak or no evidence for EL student outcomes on academic achievement data.
To further the need for this specific direction to districts to set differentiated growth targets the 2019 California State Auditor report stated that only one of the districts that they reviewed quote had a goal that was specific for an intended student subgroup English learners.
Therefore districts consistently and we know we recognize that districts consistently write goals for all students as opposed to subgroups of students.
So we are asking that in requiring the setting of differentiated groups should be placed in the instructions.
Thank you.
Good morning and Happy New Year.
My name is Carlos Machado.
I'm with the California School Board Association.
CSBA represents about a thousand school districts and county boards of education statewide.
CSBA supports the work of staff and the board and their efforts to engage stakeholders on this item.
The final output reflects this hard work.
We're happy to see this go forward and we'll continue to work with our members as this rolls out.
Thank you very much.
Good morning.
I'm Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
I'm speaking now on behalf of the Equity Coalition, some of whose members were here today.
We do the best job that we can to try to reflect the needs and interests of communities who don't have a voice here.
With regard to the stakeholder engagement section of the template, that is clearly meeting the needs of district staff.
And for folks who aren't experts on the instructions and the CDE website and the audit guide, they're going to look at that and say, oh, I guess that's good enough then.
And in terms of identifying gaps between student groups in the goal section as well as identifying goals to close those gaps, it's good to be encouraged and told that they should.
We think that that's not the strongest language the board could use to exercise its authority.
We really appreciate the collaboration of staff, both with state and the department, and look forward to continuing.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Happy New Year, y'all.
Karn with Californians for Justice.
Our students throughout the state knew that for LCFF to be successful, students who were most impacted needed to be involved in every stage of the planning process.
In 2014, CFJ along with our partners launched our student voice campaign where we eventually won new LCFF regulations which put some of the most impacted students at the center of these decisions.
Five years later, like with anything new, there are some growing pains.
We appreciate the efforts of CDE and board staff over the last five years to work with us to address a lot of these issues, many of our concerns, but we also know it can be better.
The section of LCAP around stakeholder engagement is designed for needs of school district and county offices of education staff, not parents, not students or community members who have really struggled throughout the LCAP process, but who should be part of that LCAP process.
It prompts districts to summarize without a lot of directions.
Students, parents, and community stakeholders who are new to the LCAP process could read this section of the LCAP and not see themselves or their needs reflected.
Our students feel our education system is something worth investing in, and if we're going to do this, then we want to be able to do it right.
This can't happen without making sure that we're doing everything we can to engage the students and families that our districts have traditionally not done a good job engaging.
Thank you.
Good morning, Samantha Tran with Children Now and I wanted to round out the kudos and appreciation, the work with staff and board members on this has been tremendous.
We're really appreciative of all of the progress.
I think you heard from other speakers there are tweaks that we could do to improve the template but mostly today I just wanted to thank you for many of the revisions including
Many of the audit findings are clearly represented, the inclusion of foster youth, which we truly appreciate, and more timeliness around the data.
So thank you so much and appreciate your time.
Hi Angel Ann Flores from Stockton Unified School District and chair of our EL committee in Stockton.
And I am here to speak on behalf of stakeholder engagement and the process of advocating for the inclusion, participation, and involvement of parents, families, and guardians of English learner students
is so important because it is together as a partnership in which the capability of the academic systems and experiences can truly support the multifaceted and differentiated needs of students whose primary language is not English.
The more opportunities for feedback, input, collaborative discussions that exist means the more inclusive, welcoming and empowering the educational setting and environment that we are developing.
in partnership with one another to ensure that all students are provided with the resources, experiences, and knowledge needed to make their dreams become realities on their journey to graduate from high school prepared for college careers and to be productive member of community they choose to live in.
Thank you for your support.
Good morning.
My name is Focolia Manigault.
I'm a school site council chair.
I'm also the mother of three public school students in Oakland.
We're here again today.
We appreciate all the work that's been done since September.
We heard ourselves really feeling frustrated with the process because we've worked very hard with you and staff over the years to ensure the alignment with regulations passed in 2014 and since then.
At the end of the day, we're all here because parents and students want to feel heard and they want to feel respected.
And we cannot lose sight of that.
This template is less about how county offices and about districts being able to just fill it out as much as it is that the system of California has to prove that it is equity focused.
And as long as we are continuing to keep that at the forefront, I think the little bitty changes that are needed to move this template forward will be easy to achieve, and we won't have to be back here every three years.
But with that said, we're not there yet.
You have not yet exercised your authority to the fullest extent, and we as parents across the state need to step up and do that.
This is not the time to continue to compromise on equity.
and we have said this for five years ongoing and we're going to continue to say it.
Please step up, use your authority, make the changes and align the language between the instructions as well as the template so that parents and students know and see that you want our voice to be heard.
Good morning.
I'm Monica Green from Oakland.
I served on the very first Parent Advisory Committee, Parent Advisory Committee for the LCAP in Oakland.
A lot of the work has gone in for the engagement.
I'd like to speak to that.
That should be the norm.
It should not be the exception, but that should be the standard.
It takes work to get parents to hear parents' voice and to respond and to say, this is what the response was, this is a change we made.
That should not be something we say, oh, that's great.
This is what should be standard expectation, engagement with families.
Hear our voices.
We love our children.
We want the best for them.
And we want you to use all of the authority you have to help our voices be heard.
We want that when the rollout comes on, the training looks good.
Where are the parent organizations that are going to be trained in the rollout?
So that we know what to expect, so that we also can say, not should, but must and shall.
Time.
Thank you.
Hi there.
Good morning.
My name is Savannah Campbell, and I'm here on behalf of EdVoice.
EdVoice encourages the board to amend the language in the LCAP template instructions to reflect a key recommendation from the auditor regarding how an action is principally directed towards and effective in meeting the LEA's goals for unduplicated students when district-wide expenditures occur.
In its report, the auditor found that the information reviewed in the LCAP was not sufficient to determine whether district-wide services on which LEAs plan to spend SNC funds would principally benefit intended students.
To address this, the auditor recommended that the board revise the instructions for the LCAP template to include key specific information from the CDE stakeholder complaint decisions about how LEAs can demonstrate that they have principally directed district wide services towards intended student groups.
To that end, Edvoice recommends that the board include specific instructions and examples that direct, require justification for services on a district-wide basis to distinguish between services directed towards intended student groups and services available to all students.
For example, roaming math is funded from district headquarters and principally directed to help those math achievement gaps would be different from district-wide salary increases.
Thank you for your consideration.
Hi, good morning.
Leticia Garcia on behalf of Riverside County Superintendent of Schools, Dr. Judy White, here in support for the revised LCAP template.
In our view, the revised template achieves the goals outlined in statute that both streamline the content and the process of the LCAP to make the information more accessible by parents and local stakeholders.
and also to present the information in a more digestible manner, in a more clear manner, in terms of how funds are being used to target student subgroups that more clearly reveal how districts are going to use those dollars, whether it's at a school site level or an LEA-wide basis.
We also recognize that the revised template highlights the many challenges that we've had over the years.
And many of the comments that we hear from many of our school districts, which is that we can't create the perfect LCAP template.
We can't have something that has brevity and accessibility and also that documents and memorializes every detail that is required.
So for these reasons, we believe that you should support the revisions to the LCAP.
Thank you.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond, members of the board, John Affeld from Public Advocates.
My limited time doesn't permit me to engage in all the kudos to the staff for engaging us in this process.
There is one sentence that needs to be added to correct a legal insufficiency in the instructions, and that is that after a reasonable period of implementation,
If an action is not effective, it cannot be continued with supplemental concentration funds.
That sentence was in a draft and taken out.
Currently, the instructions say, if you have an action and it's ineffective and you explain why you want to continue it, you can effectively continue an ineffective action forever.
That needs to be changed.
There needs to be a sentence that says, after a reasonable period of time,
If an action is not being effective, you cannot continue it with supplemental concentration fund.
Base funds, federal, whatever you want, but not supplemental concentration.
Time.
Thank you.
Come to the conclusion of public comment, it looks like, right?
So we're now open for discussion.
Members of the board?
Member Rucker?
Others who want to get on the queue here?
Member Ortiz-Lacombe?
Member Patio-Bronson?
Member Sun?
I have two points that I'd like to make in this discussion.
I'll start with the easy one, and I'll hold my comment on the stakeholder piece, which is not the easier one, to let everyone have their opportunity to make their first comment.
So let me start with the comment that I want to make, which I think is the easier one, is where we started, Jeff, with my clarifying question.
And it's regarding the long-term English learner.
whether or not the guidance and the template actually fully implements the board's authority from the statute concerning what has to actually be developed or drafted into the LCAP.
And so I want to make sure, from the public comment, we heard people making comments or making suggestions for making edits on page three concerning input or feedback from each stakeholder group.
from page 11 concerning the District Language Acquisition Committee, from page 13 and page 15 where your work has already been done.
And so what I said earlier was that I'm not sure in the language that's been added to try to clarify what has to be reported.
I think the confusion that I so appreciate David for clarifying on what we can ask for, I don't believe we asked for it.
And so, having said that, I want to make sure that where there is a requirement,
in districts that have at least 30 students who fall into this subgroup category.
On these pages where that work concerning English learners and those long-term English learners have to be addressed, I would like to see the language explicitly state what they must write because it's not clear that it explicitly requires them to do what the statute says.
David Sapp, Council for State Board.
Again, I guess if you could provide a little more information about that, because the text in the instructions exactly tracks the text in the statute, which says the board shall include this language in the statute.
And that's what is included in the instructions of this template.
Okay, but where I got confused was we also can't ask them for more information.
It's not clear that they, how they're prioritizing or making these determinations in their plan about the English learners unless we ask them for something explicitly or give them an example of what they should be providing.
And I don't know how to do that.
without violating the law and seeming like I'm asking for something I shouldn't ask.
That's why I asked that clarifying question.
I think that, yeah, the revised template goes a long way to making clear that there's this expectation about what districts are supposed to do.
It's not clear what that means districts are actually supposed to write.
So I think one way of thinking about it is that people may be criticizing what the statutory requirement is.
Could be one way of thinking about it.
I'm not.
I understand what you're saying.
I agree with what I understand what the statute says.
My concern is not a criticism of what the statute does or does not say.
What I'm saying is that I am not certain this is going to fix the problem that we're hearing right now.
about whether or not the board has fully used its authority to dictate to districts how they should be addressing their English learner issue.
And I'm choosing to call it an issue, not a performance.
Right.
And I think just as a legal matter, I think the use of the term dictate how they will address is the thing that the board does not have authority to do under existing law.
Okay.
That the board doesn't have authority to prescribe the type of services programs action to professional development that is included.
There are actual statutory requirements that are referenced in this language education code section 306, which defines what a language acquisition program is.
And then it also includes the requirement about required professional development related to supporting English learners.
That's what's included in the instructions.
All right.
And so this will be the last statement I made.
And I will stop on this point because, again, I'm not saying that we need to dictate what the program is.
There needs to be guidance to make clear what you have been doing isn't working.
What are you going to do now?
Something needs to say.
that.
I'm not saying this is the only program you can adopt.
I'm not saying the board will stay in the plan.
This is how you're going to go about doing it.
I'm saying it's very clear that over the life of the previous six years we've had this LCAP that we now have a problem emerging in your local concerning English learners and long-term English learners
What you have been doing isn't working.
Tell us how you are going to make a determination to make those changes.
I don't think the guidance goes far enough to hold them accountable for the fact that they are not paying attention to their data.
and making the appropriate decisions to change their process.
It goes back to what John from Public Advocates said, that there's some practices that clearly aren't working and they're still doing those things and not paying attention to what their data says.
So no, I'm not saying we're going to dictate the program.
We need to be clear in the guidance.
You're going to have to do something else because you now have a problem that has emerged.
Thank you.
I want to thank all those that provided some public comment.
I think there was some comments that were related to policy in the template and some that were practice-based.
And I think that when it comes to the practice, we definitely need to keep an eye on that because then it's jeopardizing the policy, right?
But when I'm looking at this template, and I do appreciate all the revisions we've made,
I have, I'm struggling with understanding why we can't include the word shall versus should.
Given that as a supporter of LCFF, I believe that the premise and the heart of it was really to eliminate achievement gaps.
And that's why we're providing additional funding for the student groups that were identified under LCFF.
So, it's almost a given that districts shall be looking at ways to narrow achievement gaps and provide resources and direct those resources for those student populations.
Why are we, what's the hesitation?
I mean, is it that legally if we add the word shall, we could get sued?
Sue me.
If somebody sues us because we're trying to bring equity to schools, that would be very hilarious to me.
So one, I wanna know why can we use the word shall?
And two, why did we remove the statement that John pointed out from public advocates if it was initially in the template or in the instructions?
the statement that if after a reasonable time, if an action is not effective, it can no longer be funded through supplemental concentration funds.
Why would we delete that?
So first the shall, please.
And then the clause.
So a couple reasons for the shall versus should is if I can direct your attention to the needs assessment, and pardon me for going quickly.
Here it says this is a shall because it's in the instructions under identified need.
I don't know how to fix that.
Sorry.
While we're waiting, it's in the plan summary, the instructions on your reflections identified need, and it specifically says that LEAs must look at dashboard data and identify any student group that's in red or orange or if there's any, is it up now?
Okay.
in any performance gap in students.
So there is where the shall is.
And if you look at it holistically, they will and they shall look at that.
I think looking to that one statement is, did I pass it?
I apologize.
Fundamentally, then, as county offices have said, and we have said that the LEAs, as they develop the LCAP, they must follow the instructions, and the instructions are full force, and they're part of following the template.
How would a county office
then monitor and verify this.
It becomes kind of a practical implementation and compliance aspect, if the word is shall.
It's like, well, how do you prove that you looked at this?
and look at these student groups.
Again, I'll defer to counsel.
I believe the word shall goes outside the scope of statute.
Again, can defer to counsel on that.
But practically, it would be almost impossible to monitor and enforce.
How does one prove that they looked at this?
when one would develop goals and actions to meet the student groups that would be reflective in the identified needs in the plan summary.
That's my best answer that can do, but I believe, again, the word is outside the scope, but in general, LEAs, as they look at their data story, will be looking at this, and they have to address it within the plan summary and in the identified needs.
Sure, so I don't remember where it was in the statement.
I know that in looking at the planning group and talking to the advisory group, I think legally it is problematic.
We did try to address it, and we believe that we addressed it in the language of carrying it forth.
Again, that I talked about, I'll find it.
actions continued from one LCAP to the next, it is, that is that opportunity then, because you can't necessarily, I'll finish and then, you can't necessarily, actions may or may not be effective after one year.
This is a three year LCAP, this is a long term goal, this is where do we want to be three years from now.
And so that allows that flexibility within the confines of the three years.
They still have, the LEAs still have the responsibility to review and analyze and that's in the annual update and the goal analysis to whether something is effective and make any changes to it.
But this does take that, make that break from the 2023 LCAP or the 17-20 LCAP, thank you.
to the 2023 LCAP, we just can't blindly keep doing it and saying it counts, right?
If you want to, if you think that we're making progress and you want to still continue it from the last LCAP, you have to explain why.
And you just can't blindly, you can't blindly continue on.
And so I think the after a reasonable time is problematic, but again, this allows for
that long-term goal, where do we want to be three years from now, and we just can't keep doing, I heard a long, I won't go there, sorry.
You just can't continue on from the old template to the new template and say we're just counting it as contributing to.
You have to take that break, you have to look at it, and explain if you're gonna continue, why, and we believe that that is sufficient in that.
And I would just add that I think
This document is a legal document as well, and there are duties that attach to the words that are used in this document, both for a district and for a county, and potentially for the California Department of Education in adjudicating an appeal of a complaint that might be filed.
I think it is an important reminder to just note that the statute does include that relief.
I think a number of the public comments raised concerns about whether things that are legally required are occurring.
There seems to be some specific examples that the commenters had in mind, for example, of not responding to the comments of
English learner parent advisory committees, there is a remedy that is available to address those concerns that is built into the law and it is worth reminding people of that.
On this particular issue, the proposed language is not objective.
It was very difficult to discern what an objective standard that a district
or a county or a stakeholder, like I think, you know, four different people might have a different view on how long is reasonable and how long is long enough and whether something is being effective.
You know, if you see slight progress, it's showing progress, but maybe it's not as much progress as others would like to see.
And so I think that the language that was
And in a draft that was shared before it had been fully vetted, and this is one of the downsides of being very transparent and open with stakeholders, is that sometimes there are drafts that get shared for feedback and then there's further discussion and reflection and there's issues that are then identified.
with that language, and that's why there are staff ultimately recommend changes to the final draft.
So I think for the reasons that Jeff identified from a policy perspective, but also I think there are very significant legal concerns and problems, and it is essentially, you know, concerns that people may have about attorneys filing things and getting attorney's fees.
This would create a litigation morass, potentially, the language that was being requested in this regard.
Um, can I just highlight 2 recommendations that I heard that I thought we should consider 1 was a reference guy for stakeholders.
Uh, I think that would be really.
Really great for us, although I also heard people saying, let's just roll with this.
Let's implement.
Let's move away just from redesigning the template.
I'm afraid that.
That as we're doing this now, there's already a potential changes coming our way.
So I don't know that this will be the template, but I do think that we need to be as transparent, informative with stakeholders.
So they understand what this process looks like.
And also the other recommendation was parent training as we're rolling out.
I do think that we need to consider parents in this process so that they understand what can they, as parents, expect from their LEA.
And when they're not included or they're not receiving information and writing, what can they do?
Thank you.
For the parent training, I could just point out here on this slide that we do have a training scheduled with the California Parent Teachers Association and have partnered with them to provide training.
And it is a step along with these other groups to get that information out.
And as far as the reference guide, certainly part of implementation and rolling this out would be something to certainly consider and be part of that implementation process and training process.
And thank you for that.
I've got Member Patio-Bronson and Sun, and then I'm adding Member Sandoval-Navo.
So I wanted to return to this question of should versus shall.
Is there a statutory reason why we cannot say shall?
And so maybe this is a Dave question.
I think so.
Don't get comfortable, Dave.
Yeah, just making sure you get your steps in today.
I appreciate that.
Thank you.
So I, I think one of one of the issues that
Yes, so I think there is an issue with using Shell about requiring a review of a particular student group.
And I think what's underneath all of this is that there was a great deal of feedback that was considered at length in the development process and the advisory group.
And I think that some of the comments that we heard today about requiring districts to include performance gap narrowing goals or focusing a goal that focuses on an individual student group in particular that that should be required and that goes beyond the scope of the statutory authority.
That is not something that is permitted under the statute in view of council.
And so I think that one of the concerns that arise
I'm asking actually if there's a statutory provision, though, if you can point me to.
I'm just looking at the statute, right?
Oh, sure.
If you look at Education Code 52064D2, which says that the state board shall not require school districts, county offices of education, or charter schools to provide any information in addition to the information required pursuant to Subdivision B. And so the issue is if there is a shall, and some would argue that that is then something the counties must check,
as a part of the template review and approval process, and so this would require districts to essentially, as Jeff alluded to, what is the level of documentation needed to reflect that they address this, and what we have in the current template in the plan summary is the requirement that's existing and is authorized.
by the authorizing statute of the plan summary that requires districts to call out and identify on the dashboard any indicators where there are significant performance gaps among student groups or low performance on the local indicators or other performance gaps.
But so part of what I'm trying to understand, I think, is what is the alternative?
If we make this should, it becomes permissive, right?
And so is the message that we're sending that it's optional to set growth targets for subgroups?
Well, I think this, you know, without getting into a separate item for Bagley-Keene reasons, but there is also this question of when you're, right now, and I think this goes back to the original adoption of the LCAP, the statutory requirement is that the goal, that the LCAP include goals for all students and student groups.
and if there is a goal in three years we want to be at X level of performance when one looks at the individual performance of student groups that also includes the recognition of a need for differential improvement for the district to actually get to that goal and I think that is a construct that the board
sort of incorporated in the original adoption of the template is that a goal that addresses all student performance does include performance goals for individual student groups as well.
And I think that as a part of doing that work, that setting this is what our goal is includes understanding what that means for all the student groups.
But I think that the concern here is that by saying, if this becomes a shall, and this is also in a, the header of this section you'll see is purpose, this is a general framing, what's the point of this section.
Throughout the rest of the document there is no shall, there's not a shall statement and this sort of framing, this is the purpose or goal.
the so what of why this section of the template exists.
This would be embedding a shall statement, which in this section in particular, and it's also a shall statement that carries with it additional requirements.
And I think that there is this concern about what is the degree of documentation that is necessary to show that this has occurred.
I'm  and I'll cede the mic in a second.
I just think that there's already language  for example, will clearly communicate is the verb tense at the beginning of this prior paragraph  that makes it and takes it out of the sort of ambit of being discretionary, sort of if a district or  chooses to incorporate a subgroup goal.
I think the other section that I'm looking at around specifying that school districts should prioritize the focus of goals, specific actions, related expenditures, seems to give us the authority, and this is, I think, to your question, Board Member Rucker, around what is the scope of what we can require, at least in terms of reporting, not in terms of prescribing any particular action, but saying that there has to be
a setting of focus, specific actions that are targeted to the subgroups.
And I think the audit report certainly highlights the degree to which this isn't being done.
So language suggesting should strikes me as insufficient to the task of taking a default, which is that most districts are not actually setting subgroup targets, to actually setting it in the opposite direction.
As I read 52064D2, it says anything
We can't require additional information that's not already required.
But this language that is in the statute already includes a lot of that data analysis of how we're doing on the dashboard.
So it doesn't strike me as a new requirement.
It's actually just requiring it to be articulated in a different place.
But that's already under and I'm looking at E1.
E3, excuse me, of the statute around specifying specific actions, goals, and related expenditures that are already previously named in the statute.
Yeah, I think that E3 language, the statutory language actually uses the word should as well, which is I think something that we looked at in assessing this language as well.
It says the instruction shall include a statement that is a should statement.
E3 says shall.
Shall specify that districts should.
We can marinate on this point and I'll go to Member Sun and then I'll go to Member Sandoval and Member Navo.
Thank you.
I just want to add my kudos to the hard work and the thought that went into this design of this current template for the LCAP.
And, you know, I've stated in the past, as someone who has to be working on this, and I look at it from a lot of different perspectives, from the policy perspective on the state level, as well as someone who has to actually complete this.
And I also had stated early, when we talked about this in September, that it is very difficult for us to try to come up with a template for
the wide diversity of LEAs that we have in the state, from LEAs that have one school to LEAs that have 1,000 schools.
And so trying to find that balance, I agree with many of the stakeholders who said that this strikes the right balance at this point in time.
I think it is the best template we have over the last couple of iterations.
And I do think that it will lead to more transparency and the guidance that is currently provided will lead the LEAs and the charter schools and all those who have to complete this, provide more specifics and more transparency.
I understand the conversations around should and shall that come with some observations that not all LEAs are necessarily setting the right targets or maybe they're off or they're not getting the stakeholder input.
I think that that's not the majority of LEAs.
I think we are, we do have districts who are truly want to engage stakeholders and are trying to do the right things.
And I sometimes worry about some of the assumptions that we're saying about some of the districts that
Oh, if we don't put shall versus should, they will never do it.
They'll just do the opposite.
And I just don't think that's the correct way to frame it and look at the hardworking educators in the state.
The second piece I want to also say is someone who has worked with the evolution of this.
This LCAP template works side by side with the evolution of our accountability system.
In the last three-year template that we had, if you remember, we didn't have the chronic absenteeism on the dashboard.
We did not have CCI.
And so what I was finding that made it difficult to set targets and goals, even in the last template, was the ongoing evolution of accountability on the state end.
And so there were sometimes goals that I had to add in the middle of the section and had to explain,
why we added this new one or why we tweak the other, something else.
So I think that as our evolution of our accountability in the dashboard becomes much more stable, that this will also add to that, naturally add to the transparency and the review of the data and being able for all of us to see where districts need to go.
I also want to say, you know, the LPI is, ELPI is going to also be coming up as well as another area that will bring some transparency on our performance of our English language learners.
So I think that we have this combination of different things that is going to help make this design work.
It's got to be the combination of our assessments, accountability, and this LCAP template.
It's not all going to be on the LCAP.
Thank you.
Member Sandoval.
Thank you very much for your presentation.
I just wanted to follow up and support member Ortiz-Ligon's call for parent training and the necessity for that.
And I think it's fantastic that the PTA is connected.
But I also want to ask that there be continued support for engaging members of our Indian tribes in California, more than 100 in the state.
So I think that's an important stakeholder group as well.
for reaching out to parents.
And then other community-based parent advocacy organizations that go beyond.
We heard from one of the stakeholders talking about engaging parents on the flats as well as the parents in the hills.
And I think that's really important to listen to and to follow up on, especially as it involves supporting people in our communities.
to engage in this process and to understand the document and how things are changing so that people are all, we're all together in that.
Thank you.
So I want to offer kudos to you in this what is a heavy lift in trying to balance, I think, the tension between what we actually have teeth and we're able to do legally and the flexibility that was intended in the statute for districts.
And I think that there's a theory here that all improvement is definitely incomplete and probably wrong.
until you use it.
And when you use it, those incompletes and those probably wrong assumptions become more clear.
And so the idea for me here is that if I step back and we think about what we just had the opportunity to celebrate with the state superintendent, we improved across the state without a template.
We were able to move the needle.
It's not the template that drives the improvement.
It's the process that the districts are engaged in, whether that's incomplete from our perspective or incomplete from the county's perspective.
I believe that is the mechanism.
And the districts and the counties struggle with this language as much as we do because counties would love nothing more than to not be the leverage
for every conversation that needs to be had on you should do this.
but the districts say, I don't have to do that.
So I think that the language transcends for us across the state as difficult, but what I would add is that we've made improvements without, and the comments that were given today, I do like the recommendations on the glossary.
I think that the four more template had some appendices that were helpful for counties and districts that would be helpful, and I think the key here is the stakeholder engagement and training.
that is going to come with this and the guidance to counties.
But I go back, the statement that was made from San Jose around we need to move forward beyond the template and we need to give our local LEAs time to engage in this process.
And through that, I think if we model continuous improvement, we obtain the stakeholder engagement, the assumption that this template is one and done would be a gross miscalculation on our part.
So I think that the idea, we test, modify, we test, modify, we test, modify, without overburdening the districts with new templates every year, rather than every three years.
So what I would add to this is a contribution of just thought, is that the template is not the mechanism for improvement, the process is.
And we've managed to gain improvement across the state without a template.
That isn't 400 pages long.
And so what I would step back and say, I approve the template as is.
I think that we have good legal guidance at this point, the best legal guidance we can get regarding the language.
And I appreciate Sue Burr's comments around the template calling out specifically prioritization of goals and reflection.
So at this point, I do approve the template as is.
I actually was going to make the motion if we're ready to do that.
I just wanted to make sure that Jeff put it up there.
And just before I do that, just say I appreciate all the comments.
I do think that the department staff and the board staff listened carefully to them.
and made the changes where we could and that's what's reflected here in the recommendation for the motion.
I would just also emphasize I do think that we really need to encourage training of all stakeholders.
I know we sort of, you know, we have the usual suspects and that's a little bit of what we see here.
I've said this before, and I'll reiterate it.
We do have a community engagement initiative that is running through the collaborative, and I think it's important to engage them and ask for their advice about what kinds of groups, how do we make sure that folks who are involved in this and feel like their voices aren't being heard, how do we make sure that that happens?
So I would just add that.
And if you're ready, I would move the recommendation of the department to approve the template.
So I want to begin by saying thank you to all the folks who come here at every board meeting as stakeholders to talk to us about what their experiences have been with the LCAP and the LCAP stakeholder process.
And so the second comment I said that I wanted to make and address or speak to was about the stakeholder issue.
I recall, and I was sitting here trying to find it in the red folder,
from the November board meeting.
There was a letter that came from a stakeholder and in that she expressed her frustration with the stakeholder process and said that she altogether was ready to just simply walk away from the LCAP and the LCAP stakeholder process because it was not working in her district.
So I'm not making any assumptions as I sit on this dais about the motivations or the activities
of the leadership in the LEAs where this work and this very important work has to be done.
But I am affected and I am truly deeply impacted by the parents who come here at every board meeting and all the stakeholder groups who come and tell us the stakeholder process is not working.
And so I'm impacted by that.
So, what was important to me as I look through the instructions and the guidance here, there are some very important statements that are made in the document.
It says that the LCAP is a document, not a process.
I have no problem with that.
I agree.
The purpose of the LCAP is to document the work that is being done about the norms that are supposed to be changing and improving
about the conversations we have about school programs.
But what the stakeholders keep saying is that they do not see themselves or the outcome of the process or the work that they have done, they do not see it in what is being captured in the document.
And so what I do appreciate that you've attempted to do in the stakeholder process and in what you're asking LEAs to document is what you did with your stakeholders.
What I'm still hearing the stakeholders say is we aren't doing enough.
So their comment is not a criticism about the district.
Their comment is not, well, they probably are criticizing the district, but it's not intended to say, well, we just don't like the district.
This is about leadership.
You know, and I have said before, power concedes nothing without a demand.
We have stakeholders who are demanding that the hard work and their concerns need to be reflected in this document.
Even if it is only to say the stakeholders asked for this and we decided not to do that.
This is what they are saying is not happening.
That they do not see where the district paid attention to them.
They followed a process and then nothing changed.
And so while the LCAP itself can't fix that problem, the LCAP as a document can't fix that problem, I think that we have some authority where we can.
And maybe the conversation is not about a mandate to districts, but maybe we need to think about what we are tasking county offices to do.
And I hear board member Novel saying county offices don't want that role.
This is about leadership.
They're being given that money to have that role.
I didn't mean that to be funny, but OK.
And maybe the mistake we're making today about the shooting and the shelling
I hope that wasn't profane when I said it that way.
Maybe the conversation we're having about the shooting and the shelling with LEAs really needs to pull back to the leadership we're actually expecting to come from the county offices in their relationship as facilitators and in providing guidance.
and that maybe after we approve this template and do the work to move forward on the template, we need to have a different conversation that is within the statute and that we can have some flexibility and authority to impact, that we need to provide better guidance to the counties about what they are doing in their roles with the districts, that maybe where the improvement process needs to be is with the leadership we're expecting counties to enact.
And I know
We have some authorities to do some shooting with those counties.
So I am with board member novel and saying that it's about the template is the document and not the process.
I think our relationship with the counties are about the process.
and that may be going forward.
That's where our conversation has to be.
That's a harder conversation.
And I have had those conversations with several folks at CCESA.
I think we need, and we have talked about what that means and what needs to be different.
And I know that they have made some commitments to do those things, but they need us to tell them what that needs to be.
So I am challenging my colleagues on this dais, let's take on that part of the leadership
That's where the void is right now, and I want the stakeholders to know I understand what you're asking for, but I think the place for this is not in the document, but in the process of helping to develop leadership that works in the way you need it to work.
Thank you.
Member Ortiz-Lacombe?
I just wanted to add my thoughts after hearing board member Navo mentioned like we didn't need a template to have the modest gains that we had at the state level.
I think that the reason so many of us are wordsmithing this document, if a district was doing well by all students, nobody would care if the LCAP was on a napkin.
Really.
But the reason that this becomes central to accountability is that it's so interconnected.
When we think of the dashboard, we think of the LCAP, we think of the funding, we think of even, you know, you mentioned LP.
Well, there's some dissatisfaction with that too.
And so it's all going to roll into one big conversation about what is not happening or who is not happening for, right?
And so we have to consider this.
This is essentially the receipt.
People are looking to see, well, I'm looking at my child's performance, I'm looking at my student group here, and I don't see the gains.
So let's go back to the LCAP and see what the district said they would do.
I guarantee you that if there was equitable outcomes out in the field, people would not be looking at this template so closely.
At the same time, this template is not going to get us there just because we mandate it.
It has to be a combination of leadership, best practices, honest conversations.
We talk about route analysis.
We never get down to structural racism.
We have these superficial conversations that don't always change the practice.
And so there's a lot embedded in this LCAF template.
It's only a template, but it's a template that means a lot to a lot of people.
There's funding attached and we have done, there has been some continuous improvement, but not enough.
And it also has to do with the technical assistance.
So because it's all intertwined, this becomes really high stakes for a lot of us.
And so we hear you, and I know there was a parent, a mother, it's a strong parent, you called us out, and good for you for calling us out.
And I understand the frustration, but it can all happen here in Sacramento, right?
We're not the ones implementing, we're not the ones that are actually guiding some of the districts, but we could set the vision, and I think that's what they're asking us to do.
Thank you.
Member Pango-Lenok.
I would definitely like to agree with Board Member Rucker in the sense that the county offices are really, or the leadership is where, that most of these changes are gonna be made, because I definitely see, as a student and a member of a community, I see the issue with the stakeholder engagement piece, you know,
in the instructions it says that these groups must be reported, right, but there really isn't necessarily, you know, how deeply do they need to be reported if they say one sentence that students were met with and they said this.
Is that considered enough?
And I think that, you know, that's a really big concern and a valid concern from stakeholders, and I don't think that it can necessarily be fixed in this template, just like you said before, but I think it is,
a key thing to look into moving forward because, again, stakeholders want to see that their voices are actually being used.
And if it's not being reported in this template, I think it's important that counties and school districts are kept accountable for that.
I think we've heard all the discussion that's on the table, so we can move forward with the motion.
So, Member Byrd, do you want to reiterate so we all are with you?
Right.
So, it's shown on the screen for people who can't see it.
The department's recommending that we adopt the revised LCAP template with revisions that were made on pages 3, 10, 11, and 12 of the posted version.
and they reflect the conversation that we had today, and are consistent with statute, and then allow the department staff in collaboration with the board staff to make any necessary typographical or formatting corrections.
And that we would also recommend, or the department's recommending, and my motion is that the department adopt the 2019-20 LCAP annual update template.
All right.
All those in favor say aye.
Any opposed say nay.
Any abstentions?
Motion carries.
Congratulations.
Thank you very much Jeff and staff for getting us to this place and we're going to take a five minute break and we'll be back here well let's say 11 15.
We'll give you eight minutes.
All right, don't take advantage of those extra five minutes.
Here we go.
If you are finished with the items that you came for, you can move on.
Otherwise, please take a seat so that we can begin the next item.
I like the way that Patricia is sitting and David.
Thank you, Jeff, for being so attentive.
Gavin, we are ready to start.
All right agenda item 3 is the mathematics framework item.
The CDE recommends that the state board take the following actions approve the curriculum framework and the evaluation criteria committee guidelines for the 2021 revision of the mathematics framework for California public schools.
K-12 as recommended by the IQC, and appoint candidates for the mathematics CFCC recommended by the Instructional Quality Commission.
And this item will be presented by Shanine Coates of the department.
Shanine, please begin.
So today we get to discuss a topic that we can all be excited about, mathematics.
So the process of the 2021 revision of the mathematics framework is underway and today we'll discuss the focus group input as well as review and hopefully approve the draft framework guidelines and provide you with some highlights
as well as provide you with what we hope will be the appointment of the Mathematics Curriculum Framework and Evaluation Criteria Committee, otherwise known as CFCC, members as recommended by the Instructional Quality Commission.
So before we sort of jump into those things, I want to talk about where we are.
In September, you revised your timeline of significant events.
And we have since then from May to August of last year, we posted the CFCC online applications.
So I'll talk a little bit more about that as we move along.
Also, during the month of August, we held a series of four focus groups.
throughout the state with help from our county office of education partners.
And we engaged in discussions about the current mathematics framework and how it could be strengthened.
We also, for the very first time, held student focus groups to talk about their mathematical experiences because we wanted to be sure to include the student voice.
We compiled and sorted all of that information, and it's reflected in the focus group input report, which you received early on, as well as the guidelines and reflected in the IQC's recommendations.
So we've talked about already the 2019 dashboard and the achievement gap and how we are making some progress, but that the achievement gap does persist.
And so I think we can agree that it is imperative that we continue to provide our teachers, administrators, and other decision makers with up-to-date guidance, research, and best practices.
for a more effective and equitable implementation of California's common core state standards in mathematics.
And the 2021 revision of the mathematics framework aims to do just that.
So, before we sort of go any further, I do wanna take a moment to say, to give a little bit of very, very small, extremely small sample size anecdotal information that the mathematics framework for 2013 is working, so our California's path is working and we're beginning to see some progress.
So you may say, Shaneen, what is that a picture of on this SVE slide?
And so I'm here to tell you it may look like a shabby dinner napkin, but it is not.
This is the masterpiece of a third grader.
So let me provide you a little bit of background on this.
Yes, so a few months ago, when I first began this position, I began rereading all of our documents, including the 2013 framework, and as we were having conversations with the stakeholders, this issue of how we think about fluency continued to come up, and the educators really wanted to ensure that we knew that fluency is not just about time and drill, right, it's not about how
quickly you can state your multiplication facts.
It's about knowing some answers immediately, knowing some answers from patterns, and knowing some answers through the use of strategies.
That's what we stated in our 2013 guidance.
And so when I had a conversation with my third grader, I wanted to know, I wanted to test that, and I wanted to know if I asked for a multiplication fact that she did not know, what would she do next?
And so we are having dinner and I said, you know, did a few facts that I knew she'd be comfortable with.
You know, she felt great.
And then we came to nine times seven, she paused.
She pulled out the dinner napkin and she began to do this equation, this workout.
So she knew how to use this strategy to decompose the problem.
I didn't know she knew that, right?
So that tells me, that just gives us some hope that she will be part of that cohort that will be taking the CASP this spring for the very first time and this is what we want to see and this is what we're going to continue to do and develop with the 2021 revision.
So back to the focus group input and why we're here today.
The teacher focus groups took place either virtually or in person throughout the state with the help of the county offices of Humboldt, Shasta, Fresno, Santa Clara, San Diego, Los Angeles, and Sacramento, as well as some local school districts.
We also attended the Mathematics and Science Community of Practice to get their input, and we received input from the California STEM Network as well as the National Council of Teachers of Mathematics.
The hundreds of comments from those experiences were distilled into the summary report.
And so these are some of just highlights.
The full report is available, but there was general consensus that the frame,
that the framework has a strong K through eight component, and that is a very strong document, that it has many useful examples, many appreciated the sequential organization of skills needed to master, that students need to master as they progress, and the teaching practices are presented alongside content.
There was a strong desire for a user-friendly and interactive framework,
And there were some questions that have arisen and asked to address the high school pathways, including the integrated pathways as well as traditional.
A particular highlight from our student focus groups is that it is evident from their comments that students are beginning to embrace a growth mindset in math.
So many of the students that we spoke with commented on their comfort level with making mistakes and learning from their mistakes as a normal part of mastering math concepts.
And so I think that is something that we should highlight.
So as I mentioned before, the focus group input was the basis for the draft framework guidelines which are before you today.
And these are literally just a few highlights, but the full document is available as an attachment.
The guidelines emphasize that pedagogy is just as important as the mathematical content.
And we know and we heard it directly from students that their math teachers' ability, skills, and indeed their enthusiasm for math instruction are crucial in determining student success.
There, again, the framework guidelines address the nine through 12 course pathways.
They require that this framework incorporate the latest research on learning progressions, mindset, and growth mindset in data science.
They emphasize using the standards for mathematical practices which describe the varieties of expertise that math educators at all levels should be able to impart and develop in their students.
And specifically, what we've been doing at CDE is ensuring that the recent frameworks that we have put out just recently in 2019 and also moving forward, that they not just have a section on
equity and access and inclusion, but that that is embedded throughout the document.
And so this mathematics framework will do that as well.
Also, the guidelines call for us to make math come alive.
And one of the ways that we will be doing this is through illustrating the connection between math and other academic disciplines and how they support one another.
Just to call out a few, the CTE Pathways and the Next Generation Science Standards.
And we will include greater clarity and examples of formative and summative assessment.
So now on to the CFCC.
The CFCC is a group of educators.
They are tasked with bringing their extensive knowledge and expertise and work collaboratively to assist in the process of developing and refining the framework.
The CFCC will hold a total of two six-day, excuse me, six two-day meetings in which they will read.
That would be a long meeting.
in which they will read and recommend edits and revisions to all of the draft chapters numerous times.
And at the end of that process, they will make a recommendation about the draft framework to the Mathematics Subject Matter Committee of the Instructional Quality Commission.
Before you, we will have, let me just, I'm gonna go back a bit.
So the application period was May 15th through August 15th.
We received a total of 65 applications and the IQC is recommending 20 of those for you today.
The requirements in California Code of Regulations is that the majority of those CFCC members are teachers and that they have at least one, the regulations state that at least one have experience in providing instruction to English learners and that at least one have experience in providing instruction to students with disabilities.
But I am happy to stand before you today and say that all of our candidates
have experience and or expertise in providing instruction to English learner students and students with disabilities.
So just to tell you a bit about what's next, we talked about the meetings.
They'll focus on reviewing the draft chapters, providing edits and recommendations.
The draft framework will go out for two public comment periods.
And then we hope to see you for your action on the draft framework.
in May or July 2021, but we know that we are partners and we will be involved throughout the work together.
So we hope to also see you at the CFC meetings as well.
I am available for any questions.
Hi, I was just wondering in part of this process in reviewing and revising the framework, will the committee be looking at our current data on math, maybe looking at some disaggregation of that data where our students overall in California seem to be weaker and need more areas of support, and that could be addressed in this new framework?
Yes, and that's part that's part of the sessions that are underway already.
Yes.
And I think 1 of the areas that was also called out, not only just those maybe specific standards or areas that that groups are struggling with.
So that piece, but also I'm strengthening the 9 through 12 component as well.
And I forgot to ask Member Rucker, as our liaison, if she has any initial comments before we get to public comment.
First of all, Shanine, I just want to thank you for the work that you've done in making the presentation.
I was at the IQC meeting, and so she actually covered some of the comment that I was going to be making as part of my liaison report, so I want to thank you for that.
What was really important in the conversation, particularly about
creating the criteria for revising the math framework.
It is really important to emphasize that the feedback provided by the stakeholder group truly informed the deliberations of the IQC.
And not only were they guided by that feedback, but they were intentional
in making the revisions and the suggestions for adding to the criteria and for giving guidance, particularly in paying attention and highlighting and putting greater emphasis on the standards for mathematical practice.
So the stakeholder groups were quite thoughtful and the work of the staff and the IQC
and taking that feedback and creating the guidance that will frame what we do on the mathematics framework was very significant.
So I want to thank you and your staff for the work you've already done, because there was a great deal of heavy lifting that went in to the presentation that we're seeing in front of us today.
Any questions before we go to public comment?
All right, we'll see if there's any public comment.
We have one speaker, Jessica Sacco.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Thank you.
Jessica Sacco representing the California STEM Network, a project of Children Now.
I want to echo member Rucker's comments.
The IQC was amazing in terms of their incorporation and the staff who incorporated all of the feedback that was gained from focus group and stakeholders in order to put forward what we think are a series of guidelines that will truly support and improve mathematic instructions for our student
Particularly, we are pleased to see that the guidelines call out the incorporation of universal design for learning, which will provide supports for all students, including students with disabilities.
Leveraging CDE resources to support English learners, particularly the English learner roadmap, as well as the ELT standards.
vignettes and models of high quality math that do support the implementation of mathematical practice and the integration of practice with content in instruction, as well as equitable access through guidance on culturally and linguistically relevant pedagogies.
And finally, guidance on planning instruction that connects math with other academic disciplines, including science and computer science.
So I urge your support.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
And I believe that's all the public comment.
So, is there any further discussion from the board?
Member Strauss?
So, to Shanine and your department and the staff that all participated, I just really appreciate the vetting process that you went to.
We had great applicants in the pool.
So, and I think the benefit is this was the first framework we did once after the recession, and we've done several since then.
We've gotten better at the framework process, and I think we have a good structure that you will include in the next round.
And the nice thing about this great group of people that you have on the recommendations is some of them served before, and all of them have used the existing framework.
So they're able to really know what needs to be there, what's missing, as Member Rucker and you discussed with what the IQC process was.
So this is really not changing the standard.
It's deepening the guidance document that will really help people.
And I think all of us agree that mathematics is a high priority in the state and teaching content pedagogy, content and pedagogy are really important.
And I think, I don't think we do as good enough job in helping people know that the framework is a resource that you can actually use for professional development.
So I know that's a year and a half down the line once it's all developed, but I think we have a responsibility to help people know
for professional development we're going to help create a really quality resource that you can actually use to grow teacher knowledge and skill set.
So I just really support the process and really I'm excited about the next phase of this.
I'd love to add my thanks to the staff for all the work in getting us this far and ready to go and to member Strauss for her role in helping to interview some of the members of the
group.
I'm excited, you know, having spoken with some of the writers and folks who are getting ready to do this, that the way the guidelines are emerging is really going to take us to sort of the cutting edge of mathematics instruction.
So it's going to be a very exciting process.
We're eager for it.
Is there any other discussion from board members before we move to a motion?
Do I have a motion?
I would move the staff.
I was writing notes in class, I'm sorry.
I would move the staff recommendation.
And I'll second it.
Okay, thank you.
We have a second, we have a third.
Is there any further discussion?
All in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed say nay.
Any abstentions?
Motion carries.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
We're excited about this.
Item 4 is the 2020 United States Senate Youth Program recognition of California's selected delegates.
The California Department of Education recommends that the SBE President and SSPI recognize Violet Wang,
Arushi Avishat, Olivia Brooks-Sally, and Nathan Viotti as the 2020 U.S.
Senate Youth Representatives for California.
And the item will be presented by Dina Fong from the CDE.
Dina, please feel free to begin once you adjust the microphones.
I hope you can hear me.
Yes.
Okay.
Okay, good morning.
What?
Uh oh.
It's fine, thank you.
Is this good?
Alright.
Good morning President Darling-Hammond, Chief Deputy Alcala, Superintendent Thurmond, and honorable board members.
My name is Dina Fong, the U.S.
Senate Youth Coordinator for California here at the California Department of Education.
Today is one of our favorite days where we have the pleasure of recognizing our 2020 United States Senate Youth students.
The U.S.
Senate Youth Program is sponsored by the U.S.
Senate and funded and administered by the William Randolph Hearst Foundation.
Now in its 58th year, the program provides an opportunity to selected students to gain an in-depth view of the Senate and the federal government as provide a foundation for those considering a future in public service on the local, state, or national level.
High school juniors and seniors are nominated by their principal to apply for this highly competitive, merit-based program.
To qualify, students must currently be serving in an elected or appointed leadership position in student government,
or a civic or educational organization representing a constituency and serving others for the entire school year.
Our students have gone through a rigorous application process and were selected based upon their leadership qualities, academic achievement, school and community involvement, and commitment to public service.
The last phase of the program is to formally present our 2020 United States Senate Youth Delegates and Alternates.
These students are among the best of the best in their school community and the state and there is no doubt that they will succeed in whatever they do and will serve their communities with passion.
Our two delegates will represent California during an all expenses paid trip in March in Washington, D.C.
where they will hear policy addresses by senators, cabinet members, federal agency leaders, and more.
The delegates will each receive a $10,000 college scholarship for undergraduate studies with encouragement to study coursework and political science or history.
Now I'd like to take a few minutes to introduce each student.
So if Violet Wong can come forward.
Our first delegate is Violet Wong, a senior at Casa Grande High School in Petaluma.
In her letter of recommendation, she has been described as a natural leader with a strong dedication to service who will lead and create change.
She currently serves as the co-chair of the Petaluma Regional Library Advisory Board and is lead commissioner of the Petaluma Youth Arts Council and the youth representative on the Petaluma Arts Center Board.
She is a seasoned journalist writing for her school's newspaper and anchoring their weekly news broadcast and was selected as one of 41 students nationally for recognition by the Asian American Journalism Association, J-CAMP.
She is also co-captain of the academic decathlon team and co-captain of the varsity girls swim team.
She has a strong commitment to her community and volunteers at the Petaluma City Schools, Petaluma Valley Hospital, and the Asian Art Museum.
That's to name a few.
She hopes to study history and public policy on an Army ROTC scholarship.
She is a strong social and political advocate and wants to serve her country as an Army officer followed by law school and then run for Congress or become a judge.
Congratulations to Violet.
Next up, Arushi Avichal, our second delegate.
Our second delegate is Arushi Avachat, a senior at Foothill High School in Pleasanton.
In her letter of recommendation, she's been described as a team player and a leader who leads by example, who is tenacious, compassionate, and humble.
She serves as vice chair of the Pleasanton City Youth Commission, where she advises the Pleasanton City Council on youth-related issues and helps run monthly commission meetings.
She founded a nonpartisan national nonprofit organization dedicated to youth activism called Students for Social Change, which she leads as co-president.
She is also a founder and president of the Foothill Writers Group, a creative writing critique group at her school, and is also involved with speech and debate, yearbook, and choir.
She has won numerous awards for her creative writing including a National Gold Medal from Scholastic Online and interned for an Alameda County Superior Court Judge.
She desires a future that includes public service and activism and wants to major in English and political science and then hopefully pursue a legal career with a nonprofit organization such as the ACLU.
So congratulations to Arushi.
If Violet or Arushi should be unable to participate in Washington Week, then one of our alternates will take their place.
I'd like to invite our first alternate up, Olivia Brooks-Sally.
Our first alternate is Olivia Brooks-Sally, a senior at Bishop O'Dowd High School in Oakland, where she serves as a student council representative and philanthropy chair.
In her letter of recommendation, she has been described as a high-achieving, well-rounded young woman who is inspired to learn and lead.
Olivia serves as student activities lead and is also the founder and president of Dragon Democracy, the largest club at her school.
Other activities include varsity women's rugby and string orchestra.
Her community service includes being a special needs elementary school music teacher, an intern for various political campaigns for local, statewide, congressional, and presidential races, and Miss Contra Costa Outstanding Teen 2018.
A national merit commended scholar and AP scholar with honor, Olivia wants to double major in public policy and political science, followed by a law degree or master's in public policy.
After that, she wants to serve her home state of California.
Thank you and congrats to Olivia.
And our second alternate is Nathan Viotti.
Nathan is a senior at Menlo Park, Atherton High School in Menlo Park.
In his letter of recommendation, he's been described as an extremely intelligent, responsible, and motivated individual who is highly respected by his peers.
He serves as the Northern California Director of the California High School Democrats, the official high school wing of the Democratic Party in California.
He is also editor-in-chief of MA Chronicle and The Mark, his school's newspaper and magazine, which have been awarded third best high school news site nationally.
In addition, he is the founder and president of his school's Model United Nations program and a student representative for the 18th Congressional District Student Advisory Board for Anna Issue.
Nathan volunteers as a teaching assistant and debate chair for middle schoolers through the League of Creative Minds and mentors local exchange students for the American Field Service.
An AP scholar with distinction, Nathan hopes to study either political science or international relations while continuing his study of French, Arabic, and Spanish.
He would like to pursue a career within the federal government or a civil rights organization as a diplomat, civil rights lawyer, or policymaker.
Please join me in congratulating Nathan.
So congratulations again to our outstanding four amazing students.
I'd like to also acknowledge their parents in the audience for raising such incredible youth.
Let's give them a round of applause.
What I've shared today is just a small sample of their many accomplishments at such a young age while maintaining a strong GPA.
I don't know how they do it and sleep.
but I think we know our future is in good hands with them and they will do more great things and make a positive difference in this world.
So at this time, I'd like to invite Superintendent Thurmond and President Darling-Hammond to come forward to take photos with the students.
Okay, thank you.
I think we know the right people to get rid of that.
All right, right over here.
1, 2, 3, congratulations.
Let's take one more set.
All right, 1, 2, 3.
All right, thanks.
Thank you so much.
session to discuss and take action on the following litigation.
As noticed on the meeting agenda, LAT versus state, I ask that all members of the public please clear out of the boardroom, turn off the microphones, and then we will grab lunch while we have our closed session.
Bye.
I'm going to reconvene the public session in closed session.
The board discussed and or took action on the following case LTV state.
And we'll now take up item 5, our mega assessment item.
The CDE recommends that the California State Board approve the following.
Propose changes to the CAST design and blueprint.
Delay the implementation of the multi-stage adaptive test until the item pool is of sufficient size to measure the range of students' abilities.
Eliminate the use of a screener.
Revise the CAST blueprint as described in attachment two.
Reduce the number of standalone items in segment A and segment C.
Add a third performance test to segment B to assess all three science domains and eliminate matrix sampling in segment C. The CDE further recommends that the SPE authorize CDE staff to make technical edits as necessary in the documents associated with the recommendations.
Again, above the item will be presented by Michelle Center.
Please begin.
So, well, hello.
I am presenting my last board item, and I love all of you, but I still may glow a little bit when I think about it being my last item, so I will try and contain that.
So I was going to go over the recommendation, but President Darling-Hammond did that so well, we'll skip over this slide.
I do want to talk about the background a little bit so you understand the design of our science test because it is unique.
And I know some of the board members were not here when we took some of the actions that we did.
So I'm going to take a little bit of time and talk about those for you.
So, you all know, as board members, that the California Next Generation Science Standards, known as the California NGSS, they are very innovative, they're rigorous, and we strive to put forth a test design that was consistent with that rigor, consistent with that uniqueness that are in those.
And I believe we did so in a manner that has California recognized as a national leader in its science.
approach to assessment.
So I'd like to note that the science recommended changes that you're going to see and that I will go over because I know that there were some letters and so forth.
They do not necessitate a change in the standard setting that you already approved.
So I want to get that out there so that's not lingering in the back of your mind as we go over these changes.
You might recall there was a prior presentation that I did to
providing you information and data regarding a dimensionality study that provided us with the rationale to make these changes without necessitating any standard setting.
So I just want that not to be lingering in the back of your mind as a question for me.
So as a reminder, in March 2016, this board approved the high-level test design to measure the full range of the California NTSS.
Then in November 2017, this board approved the CAS blueprint.
A blueprint is used to document how test forms for a test will be assembled.
In this case, it includes rules for how the assessment of the California NGSS performance expectations will be assessed on our state test.
When we went about this work, we also gave ourselves goals to strive to before we came up with our design.
And those goals are still relevant and important today and relate to some of the recommendations that we're going to provide to you.
We wanted to make sure that we provided models of high quality California NGSS assessment questions.
We wanted to promote improvements to teaching and learning and incentivize the teaching of science instruction in every single grade level in California.
We wanted to also make sure that we measured the range as well as the depth of the California NGSS performance expectations and did all this while minimizing testing time.
And when we brought forth this design to you, the goal was a two-hour testing time.
Throughout the development of the CAST, we prioritized involvement with the following stakeholders.
The CAST national design team.
That design team includes national experts, Dr. James Pellegrino from University of Illinois at Chicago, who is here with me in the audience, and I will ask to come up and say a few words in a little bit, as well as Dr. Kathleen Scalise from the University of Oregon.
Other stakeholders have also been consulted all along.
Those include, of course, our California teachers, the California Science Teachers Association, as well as Dr. Helen Quinn and Dr. Jonathan Osborne as representatives of the Stanford Next Generation Science Standards Assessment Project, which you may know as SNAP.
The CDE and ETS have been committed to providing the board with periodic updates, so you've heard me talk about the science test on numerous occasions, and the progress that we have made in the development.
All along that time, we have been dedicated to making refinements and improvements in this test design, and we wanted to make sure we did that utilizing data that we had available to us.
So this, the next few slides are the actual design that you originally approved.
It includes three segments.
Segment A of the CAST is a two-stage adaptive segment.
It contains multiple machine-scorable items that are short answer and selected response.
It's designed to be the broad sampling of standards.
It also was designed to eventually be multi-stage adaptive.
in segment A. And multi-stage adaptive or MST as it might be used in the item before you is really this compromise between a traditional fixed form test where everyone gets the exact same questions and an item adaptive test like we have in Smarter where every single item is adapted based on abilities.
So in the MST design, basically you have chunks of items and based on your performance on that chunk of item,
items, you will get a different chunk of various difficulties depending on how you performed on the prior stage.
I'm sure all the technical experts behind me love that I just used the word chunk in referring to this psychometric process.
So this slide helps explain the use of a screener in the CAS, and that's when a student transitions from segment A to segment B. So a student's performance during segment A may be used to determine the science domain that that student would get in segment B. So in other words, if a student performs substantially lower in a particular science domain,
So, earth and space, physical science or life science, particularly low in one of those relative to their performance on the others, then the idea was that we would screen out that and not give them that particular domain in terms of the performance task.
That, of course, we have not implemented that yet.
It relied on us having operational data determine whether or not that would work.
Segment B includes two scenario-based performance tasks that require students to solve a series of questions about a scientific phenomena and is decided to provide the deep measurement of a targeted sample of performance expectations.
Segment C includes either standalone items or a performance task.
It's a mix of field tests as well as operational items and the operational items would be used to contribute to group scores.
Segment C allowed us to add the measurement of additional performance expectations on a yearly basis.
So in summary, this is the design that the board approved.
The blueprint reflects the depth, breadth, and rigor of the California NGSS.
It reflects the multi-dimensionality of those particular standards.
Segment A sampled the wide breadth of performance expectations.
Segment B was the targeted in-depth.
And C was a mix of both of those.
We also wanted to make sure, and we did so in terms of what you approved prior, to promote science teaching in off grades.
And that was in the test in grade five, for example, covered performance expectations in grades three to five.
The test in grade eight covered performance expectations in grades six to eight.
And the high school test covered performance expectations related to nine through 12.
So that's what you approve.
Now we can go into what we believe we should modify based on data that we have from the operational administration.
After analysis and looking at the feasibility of the MST, that's our multi-stage adaptive testing design, it was determined that currently the item pool is not of sufficient size and is also lacking in a range of item difficulties that would allow us to support a full chunk of second block items.
So this is something that, in other words, we don't have to say we're not going to do.
What we can say is we will pause until we have built up a larger item bank with a broader range of item difficulties to represent what we would need in order to build out the blocks.
So our recommendation is to reevaluate the implementation of the MST when the item pool is more robust.
We also did a content screener study and we analyzed the usefulness of implementing that screener that was going to screen out one of the dimensions in terms of the performance task a student would receive.
And there was no clear evidence that it resulted in improved measurement of student performance as we had originally hoped it would.
This was one of the design elements that was particularly innovative and that we were really taking a risk to see if it would work.
Turns out it's something that we would recommend not doing.
And so our recommendation is to eliminate it and instead add a third performance task.
That would allow all students to get presented with each of the three science domains in the form of a performance task.
The elimination of the screener and the addition of the third performance task will also strengthen the alignment to the California NGSS.
This may result in a better peer review outcome for this test when we send it to our technical reviewers at the U.S.
Department of Education.
Another thing we looked at was the matrix sampling.
So taking into consideration feedback from the field and in conjunction with all the results of the studies and analyses, we recognize that we had to rethink how Segment C was currently implemented.
At this time, our recommendation is to use Segment C only for field testing to build the pool and limit testing time.
ETS and CDE will continue to explore the use of matrix sampling as the item pool grows, but this particular recommendation will also help us potentially implement MST at an earlier date if we use this fully for field testing purposes.
We also looked at the testing time.
So we looked at the mean testing time.
It was found that it did take students more than two hours to take the test, particularly in grades five and eight.
So our recommendation is to reduce the items in segment A and segment C to decrease mean testing time to under two hours while still allowing for the addition of a third performance task.
So now I've walked you through all the recommendations as well as some rationale.
You guys have the long technical reports as part of your board item, but simple explanations for what we are recommending.
So how does that impact the blueprint that's up for your approval?
Well, in segment A, there would be a reduction of items.
Originally, we had a total of 32 to 34 items in every grade level.
We recommend changing this to vary the number of items to reflect the number of performance expectations and testing time at each of those grade levels.
So at grade five, we would go down to 26 discrete items.
At grade eight,
we would move down to 28 discrete items and for high school, 32 discrete items.
In segment B, we will move from two to three performance tasks in order to more equally cover the three science domain.
This ensures every student receives a performance task in each science domain.
We will also shorten segment C and only use this segment for field testing.
Previously, students could have received up to 14 items.
Now, each student only receives six.
So now that I've gone through an overview of the recommendation, I would like to invite up Dr. Pellegrino to say a few words.
Dr. Pellegrino has over 40 years of educational experience in science, learning, as well as assessment.
He's currently the co-director of the Learning Science Research Institute.
Correct me if I'm wrong on anything.
In addition, he's authored many articles on NGSS and is a recognized leader in the field of NGSS assessments.
So we're lucky to have Dr. Pellegrino here.
How do I advance things here?
A clicker, even.
Good afternoon.
It's a pleasure to have a chance to talk with you about the California Science Assessment.
As Michelle indicated, I've been involved with the design of CAST since its outset, and I've been sort of monitoring the progression in terms of
the implementation of the California Science Assessment because I've been very interested in it as an example of what we hope for in terms of science assessment at the large scale.
So I thought what I would do in a short amount of time, try to offer three perspectives on CAST and the current recommendations for changes.
And the three recommendations are set in, let's say, three different contexts that are related.
First, I want to talk a little bit about the larger context of the challenges associated with assessment of the next generation science standards.
The second is on the nature of the cutting edge nature of the original CAST design,
and how these recommendations relate to that.
And then third is to try to put the California science assessment context in the larger context of what I know has been happening across the country as states attempt to develop and implement large scale assessments of the next generation science standards.
I had the privilege of working with Dr. Mark Wilson, who is a faculty member at the University of California at Berkeley, co-chairing a committee of the National Academy of Sciences and National Research Council that produced a report, which you see here on the left-hand side of this slide, on what it was going to take to develop assessments for the next generation science standards.
And part of the reason why this committee was formed was because the next generation science standards are so challenging from a number of perspectives in terms of how different they are relative to past standards and past science assessments.
So the bullet points that are on this slide just capture some of the points that we tried to make in that report about the larger context of constructing an assessment that is connected to the next generation science standards.
And several of you know that the next generation science standards are expressed in terms of what are called performance expectations, which are very different than any prior standards that we've ever had in science because what they do is express very directly what it is that students should know and be able to do
with respect to science, and they also reflect the intersection of the three dimensions of science proficiency that were originally identified in the National Research Council framework for K-12 science education.
Disciplinary core ideas, science and engineering practices, and cross-cutting concepts.
Given that that is the way in which the science standards are expressed, we also realized that it would not be feasible to assess all of the performance expectations at a grade level or a grade band in any given single assessment context or occasion.
If you were to try to do that in terms of actually representing what the standards were about, it would take a very long amount of testing time.
So there are going to have to be adaptations in terms of how the assessment would reflect the next generation's science standards.
It also was indicated that the students are going to need multiple and varied kinds of opportunities to demonstrate their proficiency with the performance expectations at a given grade level or grade band.
One of the other things that we indicated in that report, and I think this is relevant for the state as you think about the task assessment, but as you think about supporting science, teaching and learning in the state more generally, we argued that when you adopt standards like the Next Generation Science Standards and you want to promote
this kind of integrated three-dimensional science learning, you really need a system of assessments.
And this little diagram sort of speaks to the elements of that system of assessments.
One of the elements of that system is classroom assessment.
You really need to pay attention to development of assessments that can support classroom teaching and practice for both formative and summative purposes.
In fact, we argued in the report
that priority should be given to the classroom, recognizing full well that states were going to be mandated to engage in the other part of this assessment system, the monitoring assessment.
And there we made a case that a monitoring assessment like the CAST assessment really might involve two components, something that was embedded out of the classroom as well as an on-demand assessment, which is what the CAST assessment is.
The third thing I want to point out in that system is in order to make sense of the results that come from any assessments, you actually need to have a system of indicators to track opportunity to learn.
It's very hard to make sense of the results of your monitoring assessment without knowing what is the opportunity for students to learn in the classrooms in California, what is the opportunity for teachers in terms of professional development.
So you need to understand CAST as part of what should be a larger system designed to support teaching and learning.
And then obviously CAST is the state's monitoring assessment.
And here again, when we think about a large-scale monitoring assessment,
Again, it's not possible to cover the full breadth and depth of the performance expectations at a given grade level or grade band within a single external large-scale assessment.
There have to be ways to think about doing that creatively.
The other is that the standards themselves demand assessment tasks that will take time to administer and for students to do.
And several of these will be required in order to adequately sample the set of expectations at a given grade band.
It's also the case that some of the practices that are involved in the Next Generation Science Standards in the NRC framework, such as being able to demonstrate proficiency in carrying out an investigation, designing and carrying out an investigation,
would be difficult to assess using conventional formats of on-demand external assessments.
Here is a case where technology can help support some of this by enabling things to happen in the testing context.
And then the last point I wanted to make is that we argued that designing valid assessment tasks and then assembling them into tests, large-scale assessments,
would require a very careful, thoughtful, and detailed approach to assessment design.
So that's a larger context that sits out there with respect to every state that has been trying to develop assessments for monitoring purposes for their standards, of which California and CAST is an example.
So that now allows me to segue to talking about the originally approved CAST design
and essentially why it is at the cutting edge of what's been happening in large-scale assessment.
One, in terms of the idea of multiple segments.
The idea of these multiple segments, I think, is innovative, and I've not seen it in any other design, because each of these segments, as Michelle indicated, fills a specific need to allow for coverage of depth and breadth of the NGSS.
Also, the idea of an adaptive design, which she also talked about, stage adaptive within segment A, and then a screener where segment B content is based on segment A screening.
That particular one was a very bold move in design, and it was one where everyone realized from the outset it was fraught with challenges, potentially, in terms of the feasibility of doing that.
The other is the idea of expanded content representation within segment C through matrix sampling.
One of the things that made the CAS design a really bold one was a mixture of, you might sort of say, a design that involves a fixed form part for the student scoring as well as matrix sampling to be able to cover the full set of performance expectations and potentially allow for higher level group scoring.
One of the things that Michelle didn't mention is that made the California assessment particularly interesting in terms of what has been attempted is the very explicit use of a very principled design process for the assessment, using what's called evidence-centered design, which is really at the cutting edge of the field of assessment development and design.
And it is consistent with the arguments that we made in the larger NRC report.
So how does this all play out?
Well, if we go back now to the three components and the changes with respect to the CAS design, with respect to multiple segments and the idea that each of them fulfills a specific need for coverage of depth and breadth, that has not fundamentally changed.
There's a reduction in the number of items in A and C, but I think the fundamental purposes remain the same.
With respect to adaptivity, as Michelle mentioned, the item pool does not now sustain doing an adaptive design.
It's not currently feasible, but that has not changed in terms of the long-term goal in terms of actually that adaptation.
As I mentioned, Segment B, the idea of a screener, we knew it was a bold move, a bold idea.
The California Technical Advisory Group said, yeah, well, we'll see.
And because, in fact, it was designed with a very specific purpose.
And let me just mention that for a minute.
can we use the results coming out of Segment A to choose assessment tasks to present in Segment B that give the student the best opportunity to show what they know and can do?
So, for example, if a student has not had adequate
instruction in one of the three domains of science, life science, physical science, earth and space science, and they perform poorly in segment A on items that come from that dimension, why give them a more challenging task in segment B in that same domain when we know, in fact, that they're likely to struggle?
So it was actually a great idea and intent, but it's hard to do right now based on the evidence we have.
So the revision is to now make sure that every student gets a performance task in each of the three important domains of science.
Like I said, it was a very good idea and I think the alternative actually has benefits as well because now every student is tested in all three major domains of science.
And then the last part about expanded content representation within Segment C and matrix sample.
Right now, for good reason, I think we move this to a field test only, but this idea of matrix sampling and potentially using that for group reporting is possible in the future.
Segment C still provides a way to cover the breadth of the standards, although not in the original way that was hoped for on a year-by-year basis, but over multiple years.
Let me put the, let me offer the third perspective on this with some of the trends across the country in large-scale assessment of NGSS.
And this is perhaps no surprise.
In fact, as predicted, what we have observed is that valid task and test development
has proven very challenging.
There is no such thing as a perfect test out there.
States have struggled with whether they use groups of teachers within the state or they use testing contractors to develop
high-quality assessment tasks and assessments that really do cover the depth and breadth of the NGSS.
And so this is an evolving technology.
We're learning as we go, but there's still a lot to be done to move towards what I would call the aspirations what we have for a good large-scale assessment of the NGSS.
There are actually multiple design approaches that have been used by different states.
They have varying strengths and weaknesses.
They all have sort of design trade-offs.
I have yet to see one that is as bold as CAST's design and does what things in the way in which CAST does things with the segments.
And so, I would see that the California assessment is in fact, it maintains the right direction in terms of trying to adequately represent the state standards and support science teaching and learning.
The other thing that we're observing, and this is perhaps no surprise, is that students need more time than originally assumed.
And this could be for a variety of possible reasons, one of which is the lack of familiarity with the standards and the assessment formats and the demands of the tasks.
Another is that the items on these assessments are actually doing one of the things that we hope for, which is they're actually forcing students to think about the question that's being posed and reason about the science content rather than simply recall some random science fact that has characterized traditional science assessments.
So one of the things that's happening is tests are being shortened.
Typically, not in terms of the total time that's been allocated.
Most of the states are in the same kind of testing time range that California is, but what's been happening is a reduction in the number of items, trying to then stay within the blueprint framework in terms of sampling.
And then the last thing I'd sort of say is that in all cases, reporting of results
continues to pose challenges because, as many of you know, with every large-scale assessment, people want more out of the assessment than the assessment can often produce in the way of scores and information.
And that same thing is true with NGSS.
Individuals want more information.
They want information about the practices.
They want information in the cross-cutting concepts.
And I think that these are things that are, continue to be in flux in terms of what is the best way to report results from an assessment like the CAST assessment and what's the maximal benefit that can be gained from any assessment that is within a limited period of time.
So my overall reaction to CAST and the proposed changes, nothing terribly surprising given the newness of the assessment as well as the challenges that we know are posed by the next generation science standards, both conceptual challenges as well as operational, especially with respect to a large scale monitoring assessment.
The proposed changes don't fundamentally alter the goals of CAST,
nor its potential to provide a high-quality, large-scale science monitoring assessment.
And my last point is that's not enough.
California science assessment needs to go beyond a single large-scale assessment like CAST, no matter how good CAST is and how good it can become.
it will not be enough to support the goals you have for teachers and students in terms of science teaching and learning.
And I sort of recommend that you think seriously about that other image that I presented on a system of assessments that is really needed to support the kind of standards you have.
So I'll stop there.
And I think, Michelle, you're going to answer all the hard questions.
No, that's what I was going to tell them.
Now it's time for all your difficult questions for our friend Jim.
So any questions on the recommendation specific to science?
I think we want to just first ask member Sun if she has as our assessment liaison some feedback and comments and then we'll take clarifying questions and we'll go to the public comment.
Okay, well first I just want to take this opportunity as liaison on assessment for the last four years to wish Michelle well in her new endeavors.
I can't imagine assessment without Michelle Center.
And I know she's very generous in giving credit to her staff.
I want to recognize her leadership in this work.
And I always say that Michelle approaches assessment with schools and students in mind and heart.
So it's not just about just the assessment itself, but she wants to understand and she wants to know the impact on students and how we can better use assessments to improve performance.
So thank you for that.
So I will just start with a question.
I agree with the proposed changes, they sound, the proposed changes to the CAST assessment.
In the item, it does say that the recommended changes do not necessitate a new standard setting and do not impact the ability to compare results of the scale scores from previous administrations.
And so, if you can talk a little bit more about that, because as we implement this, we know we've already got past assessments, and will that impact
of any kind of comparison.
So we have no reason to think that we cannot compare results from the operational administration that we did and any current administrations coming up.
The results of the dimensionality show that we actually have more of a unit dimensional assessment.
And so making these small changes right now, we don't anticipate having to do that and think we can just do our equating process and be able to make those comparisons.
From one perspective, the assessment hasn't fundamentally changed in terms of what's being assessed.
The only difference that will primarily be the case is that there are fewer items, which will have a potential impact on the precision of the assessment, but it doesn't change the score scale, nor does it change how the standard setting was done.
So with respect to issues of comparability,
I don't think there are major concerns there.
There's issues of comparability all the time even if we had the same exact assessment from year to year.
But I think the point is to recognize by reducing the number of items, that's really the primary change because the score scale is based upon the item characteristics and that's what is critical with respect to standard setting and then
of being able to look at scores over time.
I do wanna come back as the second assessment liaison to some of your comments, Jim, and thank you for being here, about classroom assessment and opportunity to learn, but that does feel to me like it's edging into the discussion part of the session, so we'll come back to that.
Clarifying questions.
Member Felicia Ortiz-Lagone.
Okay, it's a long one.
It's a long one.
Those hyphenated names.
I know, those husbands.
So Michelle, I'm gonna miss you.
I'm gonna miss you and and I want to thank you because I know that we've evolved in our relationship and Felisa 2020 is gonna miss you so I wish you the best yes you're like what about Felisa 2015
My question is around the items that were eliminated or will be eliminated.
How do we decide which ones?
And I totally agree.
I know I have a fifth grade teacher at home who is going to appreciate this change because capping it at two hours, it was really, students were really struggling.
But I'm wondering how we opted on those items that would be eliminated.
How do we decide which ones would be the ones to go?
So the blueprint is not looking so much as at items as it is in terms of coverage of the performance expectations.
So we went back and looked at the performance expectations for that particular grade and
used that to determine how many items would be on the test.
So, for example, fewer performance expectations meant there were fewer items in that particular grade level segment A, for example.
In terms of what items that we select every year, that's a more complex process.
Of course, we look to make sure that our test every year is aligned to our blueprint, and then we also look at the technical qualities of the particular items to make sure that they pass our technical reviews.
Any other clarifying questions before we go to public comment?
And then we're going to save the discussion questions and then we're going to come back to those.
Oh, you have one more item.
I'm sorry.
So we can get clarifications on this and then we'll do the next item and then we'll get more clarifications.
So, I'll save my comment concerning the screener and Michelle's departure for our comment section, but I did have a question concerning the item bank development, what you talked about with segment C. How in the recommendation you're asking the board to approve
What exactly will be altered or addressed with the item bank?
You said that there's a gap in the item bank that's making some, implementing some of this a difficulty.
I need to understand how the recommend, since you raised this as an issue, how is the recommendation addressing that issue?
So as part of our contract, we do have a requirement that we look at the health of our bank, and we look at the needs of our future assessments, and we do this analysis to determine what we need in terms of development.
So that's a separate thing, but I just want to put that out there that that is what we do, right?
We are now going to be able to do more targeted field testing by looking at that plan and knowing where our gaps are.
So when we did the analysis, for example, to look at whether or not the MST would work, it gave us a better sense of what we need to fill in to the item bank in order to be able to implement MST in the future.
So that's what we're going to do.
It was not unusual for California in the very beginning to struggle with item development.
And I was very frank to this board that we were rejecting a very, very large percentage of items.
I think that was very common for every state that was working with their vendors on trying to write these items.
So we went into this, I think, with the idea that we were going to get the same number of items that we would for a regular set of standards.
These standards are so complex, we didn't end up with the number
that we would have needed.
But I have no doubt that you'll be able to implement MST in the future, which will also address some of Jim's comments about precision.
I think one other thing is to, originally as a design with segment C, it would have, it would have freestanding items or performance tasks, but it was designed also in such a way so that it could support both field testing as well as the matrix sampling to provide group level scores.
given the need to reduce testing time by focusing it just on the field testing part of it for now, it is sort of removing the matrix sampling to facilitate group level scoring until the bank gets sufficient to go back and think about how to use Segment C to both support field testing and potentially the matrix sampling and group level reporting, which is a bit of a challenge to do.
OK, so I'm going to attempt to parrot back what I think you said.
So my question was, so how will this recommendation support or address the concern about the development of items in the item bank because it's a small item bank?
And so I heard two very important points, that the process that you are already engaged in, this recommendation will allow you to deepen that work
with the contractors and the practitioner and groups that you're working with.
But further, as it relates to the way the matrix sampling was designed for Section C, it allows you to cast off first the focus on developing more field items for the purpose of doing the group, assigning the group scores, so that you could focus just on the item, use that Section C just to focus on the item development, because that's where I think I got lost.
Not casting off the idea of potential group level scoring.
It is, I would sort of say, putting it to the side for the moment to focus primarily on the field testing to build the bank so that then one could go back and reconsider once you have that.
Because Segment C was always going to be a mixture of some field testing
and then some coverage of the breadth of the standards that would be done in a matrix sample way that would allow for potentially group-level reporting at a level that you couldn't do with just the fixed part, which was the individual student.
I got it.
Okay, thank you very much.
It's complicated and I think it really needs to be understood in terms of Segment C doing a couple of different things
And now prioritizing one of those things.
I'm going to suggest if the good doctor comes back to speak to us again, if he could give us a crib sheet, that would be very helpful.
That would be very helpful to me.
But thank you very much.
That was very helpful.
Okay, I think we want to go ahead and do the second part of the item.
We can take some more clarifying questions then go to public comment.
Yeah.
Okay.
Sure.
We can take it if you want, Jim.
We're going to bring you back when we get into discussion.
Okay.
So, next we're going to request approval from the board for the proposed 2020-21 initial LPAC student score report.
They can be found in attachment three of this item.
I'd like to share the redesign now.
and talk about the stakeholders that helped us get to where we are.
CDE consulted with parents and stakeholders to improve the design of the initial LPAC student score report.
In October, a parent focus group was presented with three versions of the initial LPAC student score report.
The group included bilingual parents, Mandarin English, as well as Spanish English speakers.
And the group provided feedback on preferences as well as readability of the report.
Additionally, the CDE met with key stakeholder groups, representatives from the Californians Together, California Association for Bilingual Education, and the California Parent Teacher Association to discuss the visual design and wording for the new initial student score report.
The result is a parent-friendly student score report that is consistent with the design of student score reports for all of our other California assessments.
This is a design, which you cannot read, on the screen here that is a sample of the LPAC student score report.
So I guess you have to trust me when I tell you that the overall score and performance level is on the front page and uses parent-friendly language written in an asset-based manner.
Additional information is provided in terms of a link to Starting Smarter.
Starting Smarter includes parent guardian resources, including the parent guide to understanding the LPAC.
The initial LPAC student score report is translated into the top four languages spoken by California families, including Spanish, traditional Chinese, Vietnamese, and Filipino.
The new design is also 508 compliant and meets federal requirements for online accessibility which increases usability and readability for our families.
The initial LPAC student score report may be sent to parents along with the required parent notification letter.
This letter informs parents of their child's identification as either an English learner or initially fluent English proficient and the English language development programs available at their particular LEA.
A template letter is produced by the Language Policy and Leadership Office of the department and can be found on the CDE's website.
So I was gonna pause here, President Darling-Hammond, and allow for clarifying questions, but I also have updates to provide.
If you'd like me to pause here, I can or I can keep going.
updates on this item on this on this item but not on this action these are the only two actions you have before you okay why don't we if the updates are on this topic maybe we should hear them and then take clarifying questions the updates are on CASP and LPAC okay but not necessarily the student score report let's take clarifying questions just on the student score report okay any clarifying questions on that
We are perfectly clear, so you can give us your updates.
Okay, so now we'll move on to that and we'll start with the California Spanish Assessment or CSA.
I'm happy to announce that we're making constructed response full write items available to the field this month.
The purpose of providing these constructive response items is to provide an option for our teachers to administer them locally to gather more in-depth information about students' writing abilities in Spanish.
These items will serve as models of Common Core State Standards en Espaol aligned constructive response items that assess writing.
Again, local, optional use.
As a reminder, the California Spanish assessment currently assesses writing mechanics and does not include a constructed response full write item.
That said, early on in the development of the test, constructed response items were developed in the event that these items could be made available to the field.
And we also field tested the items in 2018.
So these would be another optional administration for our schools and teachers along with the test itself.
If ongoing funding becomes available as part of the state budget to fully develop and include constructor response items in the CSA, we will bring back to this board a revised blueprint for you to consider that includes a full right in the blueprint.
Currently we are not funded to support the continued development and scoring of a Spanish full grade.
This slide is intended to provide you with an update on the incorporation of the summative assessment results in the California Educator Reporting System.
Remember that is our one-stop shop for local educational agency staff to access individual and aggregate student results on CASP and ELPAC.
The results from the Smarter Balanced Interim Assessments are already in the reporting system.
We are currently loading historical summative assessment results in waves.
And then after that, we will start our daily feed of test results.
The first wave of summative results loaded were LPAC historical test results.
These results were made available to LEAs in November.
The next wave of summative results to be loaded into CSRS will be the Smarter Balanced Assessments in ELA and Math, the summative assessments, and then the California Alternate Assessments for ELA and Mathematics.
For those assessments, historical data will be made available this month, and then in the next coming months, we will transition to providing our additional summative assessment results in CSRS.
Now I want to share with you an update on the Smarter Balanced Digital Library.
Over the past year, the Smarter Balanced Consortium, in collaboration with its member states, has been working on the development of a new enhanced digital library portal.
Its new name will be Tools for Teachers.
The Tools for Teachers portal will meet web contact accessibility guidelines, feature an improved design that makes it easier for teachers to identify resources that meet their instructional needs.
In addition, each individual resource will provide step-by-step directions with formative assessment strategies embedded throughout the Tools for Teachers portal.
Instructional options and ideas for students with different levels of need will be specifically called out in this new site.
The new design will more closely align with the content explorer that we demoed, I believe, at the last meeting for you.
So this month Smarter Balanced will start with support from the state network of educators and the state leadership team and they will begin testing this new site.
The members of these two groups include educators from Smarter Balanced member states as well as department staff.
Then Smarter Balanced will host a series of workshops to develop and revise or review resources for tools for teachers with those exact teams of educators.
During the last workshop, which was held in November, 18 teachers and curriculum coaches from districts across California participated in that workshop, as well as our state network of educators.
Also, three of my CDE staff participated as members of the state leadership team and they provided guidance and support in developing instructional resources for tools for teachers.
The next workshop will take place next month as we continue to prepare for the launch of the portal.
So going forward this spring, Smarter will decommission the digital library portal in May.
I know, you guys don't look that sad.
and host a grand opening, yay, for Tools for Teachers in June.
They're gonna do that in conjunction with the 10 year anniversary of Smarter Balanced.
I know, I know.
That's right.
So we will do a live demonstration of Tools for Teachers at a board meeting and we're thinking probably that will happen in May by someone else.
So I'm happy to, so I can answer any clarifying questions that you have.
Otherwise, I will leave the slide up with the proposed recommendation.
I did that quickly.
And I'll just check if there's any other clarifying questions.
I want to get to public comment at that point.
All right, public comment.
We have five speakers for public comment.
Carolina Serna, Laura Dupre, Carla Herrera, Jessica Sacco, and Cameron King.
Please line up.
Good afternoon.
I'm here representing CABIT.
First of all, we want to thank the work that the department has done in developing and conducting a review of the prompts and scored responses of the constructed response full write items.
We understand that these items can be used as item samples in a practice test for an augmented CSA.
We are thankful that the department had the funding to do the work.
Currently, only writing mechanics is assessed, as was mentioned.
presenting a very narrow picture of what constitutes proficient writing.
Therefore, we recommend that the CBE work with the Department of Ed and the governor to appropriate funds to augment the CSA with constructed responsible write items, which would set an expectation for development of an authentic writing for our students.
To not augment the assessment with CR items creates a lower standard of writing in Spanish compared to what we expect of students in English.
on the ELA CASP.
Thank you.
Yes, my name is Laura Dupre.
A little higher.
And I am the liaison from CTA to Caticell, and I'm also a 41-year public school teacher.
And I have been working the last five years in a dual immersion school in Fallbrook, which is in North San Diego.
And so I wanted to come and take the opportunity to thank you for guiding and overseeing the implementation of the Spanish, California Spanish assessment.
My colleagues and third, fourth, fifth and sixth grade and I will be administering the CSA this spring.
And in order for my teachers to properly prepare their students just like they do with the ELA CASP, we would like more than just practice tests, but we would like release constructive response items when they're available.
Additionally, the writing portion of the test should include not just mechanics, but it should include actual authentic and functional writing.
And without this, the results are not reliable or valid.
Writing in both English and Spanish need to share the same rigor to meet our vision of our students being high achieving bilingual, biliterate leaders.
Thank you.
Hello.
Good afternoon.
My name is Karla Herrera, veteran bilingual educator representing Californians Together.
I'm currently working with the SEAL BTPP grant and a former IQC member.
Last August, I participated on the California Spanish Assessment Standard Setting Panel for grades three and four.
I'm encouraged the CSA can be a positive, albeit incomplete, stepping stone towards the seal of biliteracy.
I ask you to support the development of a full writing constructed response assessment to set the expectation as well as guidance to teachers so that students demonstrate writing proficiency by actually writing instead of answering multiple choice questions about writing.
Counting syllables or identifying a misspelled word does not indicate how students can express themselves through their own authentic writing.
Please augment the CSA with constructive response, full write items to promote and assess proficient biliteracy.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Liz Guillen with Public Advocates for the Equity Coalition.
Just in support of the comments you heard from both CAVE and Californians Together about really using your position and your voice to support our efforts to get the money to do this, to create the additional assessments that need to be done.
Thanks.
Good afternoon, Madam President, members of the board, Cameron King with the California Science Teachers Association.
We appreciate the opportunity to come before you today and express our gratitude and support for the outreach and consultation that CDE staff has taken the opportunity to
conduct relative to the revisions within the CAST and the CAA.
We are overall very supportive of both of those, but also recognize that this needs to be an evolutionary process in which we are evaluating the ongoing results that are coming in.
and have the opportunity to evaluate those as a collective organization, as well as with stakeholders and for the better of students.
So we look forward to continued dialogue and evaluation necessary to future edits, amendments, and changes.
As we also look to the release of the assessments, we want to ensure that the opportunity for parents to have the opportunity to look at these and see these as a collective for the evaluation of their students.
So we encourage the release of the CAA and CAST results with a Smarter Balanced scorecard.
And with the last second, I'd like to thank Michelle Center for her leadership and wish her all the best.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Jessica Sacco representing the California STEM Network, a project of Children Now.
Best wishes, Michelle.
We will miss you.
In regards to the blueprint proposed changes, we are in support of those proposed changes.
And as you heard in the presentation a couple of times, these are
An assessment that will change in the future as more items become available, the conversation around frequency, length, time for these assessments I think needs to be an ongoing one and we would be happy to engage in that conversation whether it's additional monitoring assessments or how the state can support more high quality assessment in classrooms through development of item banks and other tools that might be available to support teachers in assessing them.
Pleased to see California continue to be a leader in the assessment, and we look forward to working with board and U.S.
state leaders in order to elevate the need to support implementation of the science standards at the state level.
As we have seen at the local level, it is still lagging.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Carrick Ashley, happily retired Deputy Superintendent.
I'd like to just echo the comments from Member Sun and the comments this morning, the kind comments from President Darling-Hammond about the state of our assessment system in California.
I believe California
has the finest and most comprehensive K-12 assessment system in the nation, and much has to do with the leadership of Michelle's Center.
One of Michelle's greatest traits is that she has embodied the spirit of continuous improvement, and she continually asks herself and of her staff, how can we make these assessments better?
And she's never just satisfied with successful implementation, which we have had, but always asks the question of, how do we make this better?
And especially, how do we make it better for teachers and for students?
So these results can be used for teaching and learning.
So thank you for your service, Michelle.
OK, so now we're open for discussion and I would like to start before Jim has to catch a plane or whatever he might have to do to go back to the first item on science and ask for a little bit more.
insight on, not on these proposed initial recommendations, but on the bigger picture of the assessment system that you framed, which would include classroom assessment that engages kids in doing science and being engaged in it and assessed.
opportunity to learn standards and I know you know you've worked on this for many years I know Michelle has been full of good ideas and you know we've been trying to move pieces of this needle forward in California and it would be helpful for us to think about both what is possible there what some other states are doing California is a member of the
State Performance Assessment Learning Community, which has another 20-some states, some of whom are creating assessment banks of tasks that are classroom-based and doing other pieces of that fuller picture.
So could you talk a little about that?
And I'd invite Michelle to add on, because I know she has some great ideas that we want to hear before she leaves.
I think that really the core idea that, and one of which you've written about, I've written about, the assessment committee wrote about, is really that for standards like the Next Generation Science Standards, one of the things that we want to make sure of is that teachers have the resources they need to do quality assessment at the classroom level so that they can really engage
in monitoring the progress of their students.
And that doesn't mean that the assessments have to just look like what's on the large-scale standardized test.
In fact, in many cases, they should look different in the sense that there are particular kinds of performance tasks and activities that really engage students in the thinking and reasoning that's needed.
And the design of those tasks, as you know, and as that consortium of states
is a challenging thing to do, to design and validate them, but also the training that's associated with supporting the teachers in both understanding, developing, and then implementing those.
I think what we've begun to see is there are resources that are being developed in various groups.
As you know, I've been working with a group in the Next Generation Science Assessment Project to provide
technology-based assessments that teachers can use and it's available on a website.
And there's actually many teachers in California that use those tools.
I think the challenge is to get that information out to the teachers.
to make it accessible and to provide some of the training that's critical.
The National Center for the Improvement of Educational Assessment has done a compilation of a variety of assessment resources that have been developed by groups like SNAP, like our NGSA group, by people like Bill Penwell, but there's a lot more that needs to be done and I think
the challenge might be is how does the state promote this in some systematic way so that it isn't just what teachers hear every now and then.
I would also point out that the teaching, teaching towards the standards is a complicated activity.
The performance expectations are very challenging and they reflect the end point of a period of teaching and learning.
And so the kinds of assessments that can help support that aren't just focused on the end goal, but they are focused on the progress that students need to make along the way so that teachers can engage in a formative assessment process.
So I don't think there's any secrets out there.
This is challenging work to do.
It needs to be done with groups of teachers.
uh, in collaboration and, and then promoted by state agencies and districts because that's really where, um, when we think about system of assessments, we can think about state level district and classroom, but the greatest coordination we can achieve is between the classroom level and what the district does because that's connected to whatever their curricular resources are and their instructional practices.
Michelle, do you want to add anything?
So, I mean, I think that we have promoted across the state the value of a comprehensive assessment system and not thinking about assessments as an end-of-year test.
And unfortunately, California does not receive equal funding for science assessment as it does for ELA and math.
For ELA and math, we received funding to really engage in the work that is needed to promote and develop a comprehensive assessment system and provide the professional development that goes along with that.
I wish to say we have that same level of resources to contribute to science, and we do not, and it's not for lack of asking.
So that being said, we've tried to think creatively.
What can we do with the little bit that we have?
And so we have started some work.
We are going to start working on some
Formative assessment resources probably in the form of sample performance tasks that we are going to develop with groups of educators and put forth in the new tools for teachers.
We can do that little bit of work on the amount of resources that we have.
I think very strongly that we also need to start thinking outside of these boxes of labels of this is science and this is math and this is ELA.
And so that is part of the conversation that I know I have led along with the other members of the executive committee with Smarter Balanced on how might we start thinking about things that are cross-curricular because that is really what we do every day in the real world.
Correct.
So I think that's another movement.
And so we do have all these movements going on that might eventually get there.
But unfortunately, I think because of the lack of resources, it hasn't been as systematic as what we have been able to do with ELA and MATH.
So I just wanna, we'll come back to this conversation.
I don't want us to go deeper than we have time to go, but I think it's a really important piece for us.
There are states like New Hampshire where in the innovative assessment districts every year, all kids get inquiry-based science tasks that are part of the system.
They're both part of what counts and what is used for teaching and learning information.
In Kentucky, they asked all teachers, teachers developed tasks, developed a bank, asked everyone to use at least three inquiry-based performance assessments, which means science project activities that are assessed, a year.
And then the State Department gave feedback on the quality of the assessments.
It wasn't used for any kind of
hard-edged accountability, but really for getting inquiry science into the classroom and giving people opportunities to use good tasks that could help structure the work.
I think it's gonna be really important for us because we actually, and we'll see when our science results come out, that we didn't teach science in a lot of schools for a long number of years, and inquiry science of the sort that NGSS calls for is gonna require us to be really
purposeful about giving teachers those tools and organizing the professional development and the strategies for accessing a coherent set of projects and tasks over time, and it will require resources.
I'm hearing you in that regard.
But I think it is part of a whole system, and we definitely, I know that we've been taking some steps in that direction, and we'll need to figure out how we really bring
science teaching and learning and assessment in a very integral way into all of our elementary as well as secondary classrooms in a state that is STEM dependent, STEAM dependent, you know, for its economy.
we really have to figure out what we're going to do to enable teachers to get access to the kind of tools they need.
So I'm delighted that we're started.
I'm delighted to have it on the table.
I don't know if you have anything else to add, Jim or Michelle, on this question of states that are engaged in opportunity to learn indicators about science.
teaching and learning access, but that would also be interesting to know.
I don't, at the current time, know whether there are particular states trying to do that.
As you know, that's probably the last thing that many policy makers actually want to delve into because, in fact, it has implications of accountability.
in ways that are oftentimes challenging and problematic for those in the policy arena.
But I think it's actually another example of a place where there's opportunity for states to take a leadership role to think about what would be the kinds of evidence.
And there is a
There is a report that was commissioned by NSF about sort of thinking about what would be indicators of opportunity to learn or implementation of practices along with the standards.
The extent to which any state has acted on that is I'm not certain about, but it's certainly worth delving into.
Well, I hope we can come back around to these questions in a later agenda item and, you know, continue to develop out our sense of the system.
I want to stick to the science for a moment if there's any further discussion and then shift to the CSA of the LPAC so that we're all in sync.
So, we'll start with Member Rucker and we'll come around this way and don't be shy on this side.
We'll get around to you.
Let me just say I am disappointed right now that the screener is out primarily because of the work that's being undertaken now in developing the item bank and some of the conclusions that have been found from the work you've done.
For me, in starting out with the blueprint, this was probably the most exciting part of the assessment design, not just because it was bold or innovative, but because I've always believed, as a classroom teacher, the best kind of test is a test that allows students to show what they actually know and understand.
So I thought the screener served a purpose in a very innovative way, and we're going to lose that.
But that said, I will get over it.
As it relates, you know, to understand how my mind works on all this assessment stuff, you know, for me, at 2 o'clock in the morning at a four-way stop, that stop sign's a suggestion, not a mandate.
So, for those of you who are wondering what I'm doing out at 2 o'clock in the morning, get your mind out of the gutter.
So I like the point that you made about how the standards reflect an end point of a period of teaching and learning.
And up to this point, that's kind of how we've treated assessment also.
That's something that happens at an end point of a period of teaching and learning.
And so the idea you have about being more holistic about what we think about assessment, this is part of the reason why I'm so sad to see Michelle Senter leaving her position.
Because what she actually ushered in into California, we stopped just simply adopting a test and we started building the architecture of an assessment system.
So becoming more systematized, not only in what we do in assessing and testing students, but understanding what we do within that system to report on it, to study it, and to turn around and use it to inform
teaching and learning practice is how we've actually changed our assessment conversation.
Michelle, you and your team, your department, led that work.
But in thinking about what we can do with science assessment, we are still compartmentalizing
the topics of conversation around assessment.
So I'm going to harp back on something I always say.
I want to remind you, we adopted two sets of standards.
I keep saying I'm from the South, English is barely my primary language.
So we adopted the Common Core Standards for Mathematics, but we also adopted the Common Core Standards for English Language Arts.
And what becomes important in that title is what comes after the and.
Literacy in science, history, social science, and technical subjects.
Let me suggest that maybe another way to think about how to fund the science assessment is to look at it as a literacy assessment of the anchor standards, because we adopted the anchor standards separately.
from adopting the Common Core Standards and if we look at how the Anchor Standards also inform the assessment of science, that's another practical way of looking at not only developing the assessment itself, particularly in Segment C and using that screener that I'm really in love with,
but also to think about what it means to assess in science.
We're not just assessing the content standards of science.
Our goal long-term is to assess students' literacy and the way that they engage with the questions and how they persist in doing the problem-solving that the questions task them to do.
So if we think about the ways the anchor standards
live in that document and in the way we're trying to do the assessment of science, that's another approach you could take to not only looking at how to develop the test, but let me also suggest how to fund it.
Member Ortiz-Lacon.
I have a question about the results.
And I know I have it on page eight here, and somebody asked, I believe it was the male educator, who said, why not release it when we release SBAC scores when students take the assessment?
So I'm wondering the same thing.
Why don't we release the SBAC results for students at the same time as the science results?
Because these are forthcoming, right, in January?
So the public release is in January, but the individual student results are already out to our schools and districts.
And it depends on where the test is in terms of its development to determine how quickly you can get those results out.
And so given Smarter Balanced is pre-equated, you can turn that around rather quickly.
And eventually you'll get science results out in a quicker timeline.
Eventually, they will be simultaneous or at least simultaneous.
I'm not sure if they'll be simultaneous, but they will have a quicker turnaround time.
It could be something we aim for as we see how it unfolds down the road.
Yeah, I think so, and I agree.
We do need to invest a lot more in science and not just the assessment, but I don't think we've seen an achievement gap until we see these results.
To be honest, if we think we have achievement gaps in SBAC, math, and ELA, I have a feeling that we're really going to be struck by what we see.
I think we still have some work to do to analyze the items and whether or not they can be machine scored or in human scoring, and that will really impact the turnaround time.
Okay.
Member Strauss.
So let me just say I so appreciate Michelle and Dr. Pellegrino the presentation and how you helped us understand the complexities of the test development, the challenge of implementing assessment, fair and reliable assessment on next generation science standards.
But when you talk to the field about implementation, I was with the Science Collaboration Committee, which helps plan the science community of practice.
There are science leads around the state, and when you ask them kind of where are we statewide in implementing NGSS, what they say is, and we know this, not everyone has even purchased aligned materials yet.
They're still reviewing them.
They may purchase for
2021, but the chance of everybody having them in their hands is more likely fall of 2122.
So when we take a look at how long it takes from the time we adopt to develop the framework,
to get aligned materials, to take a look at it, and then to help teachers understand this is a huge shift from what we've done in the previous set of standards like 20 years ago.
And so I appreciate the challenge of implementation, especially take an elementary teacher who's still learning ELA and ELD and mathematics we know we have issues with and history, social science, all of our standards.
So I think this is a long-term process.
That being said, I agree with what Member Rutgers is talking about is the use for teachers, and you were talking about that, tools for teachers, helping them understand how to do this.
It's not a one-shot deal.
It's the ongoing work of their instruction.
As part of observing the standard-setting process, I just have a lot of confidence in what your recommendations are, understanding that the work of the leadership has been thoughtful, it's been
It's been thoughtful and paced in a way that you're trying to give us logical recommendations to consider and that will help us develop it.
I also appreciate the understanding of how long it takes kids to take this test and where you get to a point where you're exceeding a reasonable amount of time for a fifth grader to sit and take a test like this to actually show them kind of what they need.
So again, I fully support the recommendations that you're making.
I just so appreciate this discussion and also the
commitment to get more valid and reliable items in the item bank as well.
So I'm looking forward to tools for teachers and the next stage.
I think teachers want to do this right.
This is hard and we need to provide them with the resources that they can use and then the professional development time to fully implement it.
Thank you.
Are there other points of discussion?
Okay.
We may wait and do the whole set of recommendations together in terms of a motion since we're not hearing any specific tweaks.
And so let's go on now to the LPAC recommendation.
Yeah, Jim, you're off the hook for the moment.
And see if there's any further discussion around the student score reports for LPAC.
I'm not hearing any.
Yes.
Okay, and then the next thing is just, I think if there's feedback on the updates, there were some public comment, and I think I have a question that came out of the public comment, and others may as well.
And my question was really about the CSA, and the comments about the nature of the writing tasks on the CSA, and so I'd like to hear what's planned, and I think the comments were, you know, the request for authentic writing tasks.
And I wanted to hear more about what's currently planned and what the need is to get from here to there.
So we were funded one-time money and so right now it was the development of these along with the ancillary materials that go along with them in order for people to use them and score them.
And these are?
The writing tasks that we're going to put out on a secure portal for teachers to use.
So that set.
And what do they look like?
What is the nature of the tasks?
They are prompts that are aligned with Common Core Espaol that are authentic writing in Spanish.
They are, yes, the scoring rubrics are there.
There's also information on exemplars, for example.
so that they really can be used.
That being said, it was one-time funding, so we have no mechanism to put it into the blueprint or develop any further.
There was also a comment by one of the speakers, I can't remember which one, that mentioned the practice test, and I want to kind of make sure I clarify what that comment was referring to.
The tasks that we are going to put out there in a secure portal for teachers to use, those can be easily transitioned to a practice test and put out for public consumption if we end up adding this, because we get funding, to the actual test.
So they could eventually move over to serve that purpose and that would provide
on-ramp if you will to the work that would need to be done to get those into the the blueprint and the practice test which is a Representation of what the test looks like and so that's what that reference was was that these would not necessarily be wasted Because there would be another use for them if that funding was secured Any other comments questions discussion member Felice
So what I heard from them was we need the department and the state board to make a case for additional funding.
I know that now these would be locally scored.
They're optional and they would be locally scored, right?
And so I'm wondering if there would actually be
And I know that I attended one of the focus groups and one of the concerns that educators had was that they would be locally scored and there's no compensation, right?
And so there's training that's needed.
And so I'm wondering, I'm gonna direct my question to our liaisons from the state board and how do we plan to join efforts with the department to pursue funding for this?
Or has there been a conversation about this?
I think this is the moment to start having the conversation.
Which is why I asked the question.
Just to clarify, there was very mixed opinions by the high school teachers about whether or not they should score them or not.
There are definitely teachers who feel like that should not be their responsibility because they're not being compensated.
And then there were teachers who were fine with it.
But I think that it was a very,
loud and insistent response that we should be requesting funding to have those scored by someone other than a classroom teacher unless we are going to pay them to do so.
There was also concern about bias, right?
And so it wasn't just, yes, there was also the concern about making sure that they were objectively scoring these.
I'd just like to say in this question of scoring, because it's something I've
spent a long time looking at.
There's a lot of professional learning that occurs when you score performance assessments.
We have had some experience in the state with teachers scoring the performance tasks on Smarter Balanced on paid professional development days when this is part of the professional development.
They routinely say this is some of the best professional learning.
because then you can talk about what is the implication for curriculum and instruction, and that may include people scoring their own kids or other people's kids, but this still is a lot of learning that occurs when teachers are involved in scoring.
So, as we think about how this unfolds, both in the CSA context and other contexts,
And there are states that routinely, and countries, in fact most countries have teachers involved in scoring open-ended assessments most of the time because the teachers are part of the assessment process.
It's not something that's outsourced.
And it is a huge part of actually bringing standards and instruction and curriculum and assessment together rather than keeping them separate.
We'll need to look at the various ways that one can think about the funding and the scoring of things, but I don't want to make an assumption off the top that we wouldn't pay teachers if they were involved in it, or that we would want to always outsource
every aspect of testing because it actually reduces the effectiveness of teaching and learning as it integrates with assessment.
So, this is not what was on our agenda today and we just thank you for bringing it up.
I think the call for authentic assessment from the people who came and commented is one that resonates with us.
You know, we want kids to be doing real work that
Really demonstrates their skills and we want to begin to figure out how to integrate it more and more into our system and we'll have to have a lot of conversations about what that looks like and how it might be done and and So on and I just thank you for you know, opening the door for us to begin to have that that conversation Anything else on any of the assessment items before we move to a motion anybody have any other comments or discussion needs I
I would love to have a motion.
I will make the motion that we approve the proposed changes to the California science test, cast design and blueprint to delay the implementation of the multistage adaptive test, eliminate the use of screener, revise the cast blueprint.
proposed student and second action item proposed student score reports for the initial approved the proposed student score reports for the initial English language proficiency assessments for the for California or LPAC as described in attachment three.
All right second.
Thank you very much we have a motion and a second any further discussion?
All right all in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed say nay.
Any abstentions?
Motion passes.
Thank you.
I feel like we should take a stretch.
That was a big item.
And thank you, Michelle, for ably leading us through it, and Dr. Pellegrino for participating and assisting.
All right, if you need to take like a moment of stretch, I'm not letting you out of your chair, but you can.
Don't leave the room.
We are going to move on because we have a lot to cover.
So we're going to move to agenda item seven.
And those who are leaving, please leave quietly.
And expeditiously.
No conversations.
I'm gonna do it.
Stand up.
Oh, that's a long one.
Yes, oh yeah, please, please.
Okay.
All right.
We are ready.
We are ready for item seven.
I don't want to mess up the stretching.
Good afternoon.
I need to cue you up.
Those who are leaving, please leave quietly and then close the door behind you.
Thank you.
Don't let it hit you in the rear.
All right, item seven is an update on the development of the California State Plan for the Every Student Succeeds Act.
Approval of the revisions to the state plan for resubmission to the U.S.
Department of Education and the CDE recommends that we approve the amendments to our plan pending the executive director's approval of final revisions requested by the department.
The item will be presented by Julian Cuevas of the California Department of Education.
Do you say Julian or Julian?
Go by both.
All right.
Well, you can choose and please begin.
Well, thank you so much.
Good afternoon Yes, my name is Julian Cuevas the director of government affairs for the California Department of Education Today, I'll be providing a general overview and timeline of the amendments that the state board already approved in 2019 in relation to the consolidation of California's every student succeed act state plan and
The information that will be presented to you today is not new, but it will hopefully serve as a summary as you consider approving the plan as a whole today.
Now as a brief overview, the Every Student Seeks Act was signed into law by President Barack Obama in 2015.
It reauthorized the Federal Elementary and Secondary Education Act and replaced the No Child Left Behind Act.
The purpose of ESSA is to supplement state programs by ensuring educational equity and opportunity for our disadvantaged and high-need students.
Now, referencing this table in front of you on the screen and taking it back to 2017 for a moment, the ESSA state plan was first submitted in September of 2017.
In July of 2018, the U.S.
Department of Education approved the state plan.
And in November of 2018, a revised consolidated state plan was submitted to the U.S.
Department of Education and was approved in December of 2019.
Now today I stand before you on behalf of the California Department of Education with the recommendation that the State Board of Education approve the amendments to California's ESSA State Plan for submission to the U.S.
Department of Education pending the State Board Executive Director's approval of final revisions requested by the State Board, correction of any typographical errors, any necessary non-substantive clarifying edits.
Today's item provides an overview of the amended Every Student Succeeds Act state plan based on the actions taken by the State Board of Education in 2019 related to California's accountability and continuous improvement system.
This item includes the following amendments, excuse me, attachments.
So attachment one is an overview of the approved amendments to California's SSA state plan, and then attachment two reflects the approved amendments to the SSA state plan compared to the state plan approved by the U.S.
Department of Education.
Now as a quick buffer, here is a snapshot of the actions taken in 2019.
In July of 2019, the State Board approved the extended rate for the graduation rate indicator.
In the September 2019 meeting, the State Board approved raising the low graduation threshold to below 68%.
This action was in response to adopting the combined graduation rate methodology at the July 2019 State Board meeting.
At the November 2019 meeting, the state board clarified revisions to the current definitions of an ineffective and out of field teacher in efforts to provide the most accurate data to improve technical assistance and to support the field and ensure equitable access and positive outcomes for students.
These amendments in the state plan capture the full range of credential and authorization statuses that teachers can hold.
The State Board approved the methodology for using the ALPI and school identification and the status cut scores for the ALPI which is used to identify schools for support under ESSA.
The State Board also adopted the long-term goal for the extended graduation rate be set at 90.5% as compared to the 90% goal that was established for the four-year cohort graduation rate.
Other approved amendments include an update to reflect the incorporation of the participation rate into the calculation of the academic indicator, revisions to reflect the evolution and additional details regarding the system of support, and other non-substantive typographical corrections.
Now, as a side note, the revisions do include change for the English learner progress indicator into the dashboard.
This review will include the status cut points used based on the third year of data.
So once again, the California Department of Education recommends that the State Board approve these amendments to California's S.S.
State Plan for submission to the U.S.
Department of Education pending the State Board Executive Director's approval and final revisions of requested by the State Board correction of any typographical errors, any necessary non-substantive clarifying edits.
And to help answer any questions you may have, I have with me today Cindy Kazanis, our Director of Analysis, Measurement and Accountability Reporting Division.
Thank you.
So first we're going to take clarifying questions from board members before we go to public comment.
Ting, would you please like to make a comment?
The only comment I have is Julian has reiterated or said that these are changes that we have already approved.
This is just consolidating everything so that we're clear what changes have been made moving forward.
Correct.
Thanks, Member Sung.
Any clarifying questions or comments from board members regarding this?
Okay.
Okay, so we'll go to public comment first.
We have three people for public comment.
Shelly Spiegel Coleman, Carla Herrera, and Savannah Campbell.
Please line up.
Good afternoon, board members.
Shelly Spiegel-Coleman, Executive Director of Californians Together.
I want to address the methodology for setting the status cut scores for the LP recommended for submission with a revised ESSA plan.
We suggest that prior to you submitting the plan, the board and department review the results and adjust the cut scores for the LP performance levels.
After our review of the data dashboard of 53 school districts with the largest English learner population, 5,000 or more in the state, we found that only one district out of the 53 fall in the very low level, meaning that they would be eligible possibly for differentiated assistance or there may be implications for CSI.
Your rationale, and these districts enroll 47.2% of all the English learners in the state.
the rationale for the six levels of the LP to allow more students to show growth and to be consistent with the research on attaining English proficiency.
We are asking, why would we set an expectation at 55% of a performance level when we want 100% of the kids to grow one at high?
We urge you to raise the very low level to at least 45% so that 15 out of the 53 districts would be designated.
Thank you.
Hi again, Carla Herrera, Californians Together.
I echo the consistent concern about accountability for ELs that has been voiced ever since the initial development of the ESSA plan.
The definition of the academic indicator for ELs and the effect on the lack of attention to ELs and LCAPs has been documented over three years.
The lack of a primary language assessment in the accountability system and now the LP indicator status scores are masking the needs of current English learners.
It has been stated repeatedly that the LP indicator would reflect the current needs of ELs in the accountability system, but that is not evident.
Before submitting this revision of the ESSA plan, we urge you to adjust the LP status scores with the suggestion that low and very low be considered for DACSI and ATSI.
Thank you.
Thank you, Carla.
Do we have another speaker?
Carolyn, is that it?
There was also Savannah Campbell.
Savannah here?
She didn't line up.
Okay, so that ends our public comment.
I'm going to ask Cindy Kazanas to come back up, if you would please, smiling there, because I believe we as a board did talk about the issues that the public comment and the letters had raised.
regarding a chance to revisit LP CUP scores and the plan for 2020 to address it as we got more data.
Sure, Cindy Kazanas, Director of the Analysis, Measurement, Accountability, and Reporting Division.
This is my first time up, that's why I was smiling.
I didn't have an item at this meeting.
So I brought up slide 10, which you can see on the slide deck, hopefully, which very blatantly says that we will, we've talked about this when we brought forward, sorry, this microphone seems to be echoing.
We brought forward the English Learner Progress Indicator, the status cut scores for approval in November.
We will bring this back again to you probably this next November as we look at the change cut scores.
We will need to revisit this.
We have done this before.
We will revisit the status cut scores.
So that will be the opportunity to have the conversation.
We have obviously already released the dashboard.
Districts have been identified under this measure.
We will be releasing the comprehensive support list at the end of the month.
rather the eligibility, you'll see districts that, or rather schools that are identified as a result of this measure being included for the first time with the new assessment.
Thanks, Cindy.
I know you weren't expecting that, but I really appreciate it because I think we did make a commitment on the board that we would come back and revisit this and I wanted to make sure that it was really clear.
So I appreciate that.
So now we'll do board clarifying questions.
Any comments or questions?
Member Teasley-Cohen?
First of all, welcome Julian or is it Julian or Julian?
Yeah, let's keep it as you were baptized Julian.
So, welcome and I want to say that before Julian and before the release of the data dashboard, we did have this conversation.
I think that the reason it's coming back up, and correct me if I'm wrong, is that even when we had the meeting back in November,
there was a sense that we were setting the thresholds too low.
And that given our thresholds, a student who was L1 would not reclassified within the allotted time, which was seven years.
So then we would fall into long-term ELs.
Then the dashboard was released, and from what I heard, out of the 53 districts that have the highest concentration of Ls, only one met the criteria of very low.
So again, there was like I think a hunch that we were setting low thresholds and then it was confirmed with the data from the dashboard.
I do think we're a little past, unfortunately, it's a little hard for us to go back now because we've already released the data, we've already identified.
By the way, how many total districts were identified with very low for LP?
I don't have that much information handy.
We can get it for you.
Okay.
Yeah, that would be great because I think it will relate to my item eight, which I have concerns about.
But part of it is that we need to have this conversation about how low is too low that we won't identify and support or how high is too high that we're actually never going to reclassify students.
So, I'm glad that we're going to have this conversation again, but I want, again, I want to reiterate why the concern has sort of heightened, and it's because with the data dashboard, there was a, what I think is under-identification.
One, under the academic indicator, the clustered, now the LP, which is where we were supposed to meet and address the needs, is also under-identified.
Thank you.
The next person was Member Rucker.
I'm actually glad board member Ortiz-Lacombe spoke first because I have some questions since the dashboard was released and again in November I had some hesitation and some concerns and I'm not going to say I begrudgingly voted to support the recommendations that were made.
I voted to support the recommendations because I have a belief that we're going to continue to live with this question.
Then the dashboard got released and so now I have more questions.
So knowing that there is going to be this list, you know, because we're following this timeline in our process about the dashboard being released and then we identify these schools based on the criteria we have in place.
We already know only one school that is going to be identified or the schools that have been identified is really low.
One school seems to have this issue about LP based on what we heard from the public comments.
So what I'm going to ask as part of the conversation, living with this conversation, you said that we'll come back and look at status and change in the fall.
That is a long period of time for this question to remain in suspense.
And so I think that what I would like to ask the staff to do, I have a number of questions that I would like about the data.
concerning the list of schools that will be released at the end of this month.
And I know standing here today, you can't give me those answers.
So for purpose of public transparency, I'm going to ask these questions.
And then long before November, as a way of doing an analysis about what it is that's going on with this information and the questions that are being raised,
about whether or not we have artificially inflated what the priority in this performance means, I want to ask the department to give us a report about this.
So these are my questions.
In looking at the schools and districts that you're going to be doing this review and releasing the list on, how many of them actually received a very low status rating on the LP?
How many of them are there?
and what percentage of EL students are actually enrolled in those schools.
We heard in the public's comment that that's almost 50% of students who are being currently served in a number of schools that are already
receiving some kind of comprehensive support, we don't know.
From an earlier item, at the risk of violating Bagley-Keene, we talked about the fact that we don't know how districts are paying attention to this data about their English learners, and so that's the reason why I'm asking those two questions.
In reviewing the schools that are going to be designated for CSI, I would also like to know where is, how is LP a factor for those schools?
And if we keep 55 for a high rating, can the department do a run to find out how many EL students after six years, and that's going to be down the road, how many EL students after six years would remain as long-term English learners?
In the same way that every kindergartner is a high school graduate, long-term English learners become long-term English learners
long before that label is applied to them.
So we should start recognizing what the profile of the performance of those schools and those school programs look like as those students fall into that category.
So we should be monitoring and tracing.
That goes back to the conversation
we had earlier today about leadership and the type of monitoring that county offices are supposed to be tasked to do.
So that's why that question is being asked.
And finally, as it relates to the school graduation rates for CSI,
Why do we think they're going to accept 35% for students, for LP students who are identified at these comprehensive schools if 67% is actually the floor?
Why do we think they're going to accept a much lower graduation rate for those students?
The ED.
I'm sorry, I'm not following you with that statement.
Because the requirements for CS, in order to get into CSI, you need to, the first one we look at, of course, is under 68%.
And then we move from there.
So I'm not following on where you're getting the 30.
So there's, in the recommendations that were being made, there's a recommendation to differentiate what the rate would be.
So below the 68%, it seems like what I read, we're differentiating this for ELs.
That's not correct.
Okay.
So that's probably, if there's a specific page number we can reference, it's probably
The MIPS, it's probably our measurement of interim progress that we have to address.
You have to, you have to talk about your basics.
So that is, that is consistent with how we have applied the methodology in the prior amendments to the state plan or actually our original state plan was based on
Where are you at?
Where do you where do you anticipate you'll be in in three years?
That's what you're required to do under that state plan So we and I want to be very direct about the methodology that you voted on in November that was based on methodology We used for every single other indicator where the where the cut scores fell fell out it was based on real data and the distribution that we saw for for every other indicator, so I
I would agree, but my problem is what came out in the December dashboard
was very different than what I was expecting or what I believed I was going to see.
So the big rosy picture or my belief in what was going to be the sustained effect of our decision didn't kind of match up with the data that we then got in December.
So that's why I'm having some, it's moved beyond some angst now.
I actually regret that vote now.
Okay, we have some other folks who are waiting.
I think member Sun and Matt, were you trying to get in?
No.
Okay, you had a flag that you wanted to add one other comment.
And I would just reiterate that the data in here and I also want to just also remind us that the data for the LPI is not complete.
We're waiting for the change piece of it and I have a sense that once the data is complete that we would be identifying more schools as it is because it's only half of what we're using for accountability right now.
So I understand that, and I understand the angst.
We are going to bring this back.
We had fairly extensive discussion about this at the time as well.
So I think that it really  we need to have the complete set of information and the data with the next  this year's administration of the test.
Did we have public comment while I was taking yes, okay So do we have a motion though?
So with that I will move the department's recommendation That we approve the amendments of the ESSA state plan for submission to ED and we have a second.
I'll second.
All right Thank you any further discussion All in favor say aye any opposed any abstentions motion carries.
Thank you.
Thank you
We'll now move to item 8 which is the approval of local education agencies comprehensive support and improvement plans pursuant to the Every Student Succeeds Act section.
And the item will be presented by Jeff Breshears of CDE.
And I'll just encourage others, I took my own individual break as needed.
You may do the same as you need to take a break, because we're going to try to, you know, muscle on through.
We have a lot of items still to get through today.
So, when you're ready, Jeff, you can please begin.
So good afternoon, I'm Jeff Breshears again still from local agency system support office.
I'll be glad to, you'll be glad to know I don't have 67 slides again.
We can go through this.
Item eight is really a continuation or the culmination of an action and process that the state board approved last January, January of 19 to the process of approving CSI plans.
So section 111.
One of the ESSA requires that schools that have been identified for comprehensive support and improvement, that they develop school plans to meet and to address those items for which the student outcomes, to improve student outcomes for which they were identified.
And with that requirement is the state educational agency approved those plans and for California, you the state board are the SEA.
So it's more fully discussed in the item, but in June, July of 2017, the State Board approved the applicable indicators and the baseline methodology consistent with ESSA to identify those schools in needing of improvement.
And then again, like I said, in January of 19, the State Board adopted the proposed revised LCAP plan
the plan summary to include these CSI prompts to meet the ESSA CSI school planning and approval requirements consistent with our California state plan.
Just as a reminder, here are the prompts that you approved to put into the LCAP plan summary, talking about identifying the schools that have been identified for CSI.
And then the description of, because the requirement is for the LEA in conjunction with stakeholders and the school leadership at the school site to develop a school level plan that meet the resource inequities and the identification and how they would support that development of the plan and the implementation of the plan.
and then also how they would monitor and evaluation the implementation and effectiveness of those CSI plans.
So again, approach in December of 18, the December 18 dashboard is the first determinations of school eligibility for CSI.
Again, you took action in January of 2018 to address this requirement through this process that we're talking about now to approve those three prompts, which is again, is a summary would act as the summaries of those school CSI plans, I apologize.
And then just to note the charter schools that were identified for CSI, those CSI prompts and not the entire LCAP because the LCAPs are approved for a charter school by their governing body.
But for the CSI prompts, if they've been identified for CSI, that they would submit those CSI prompts to the County Office of Education in the county in which the charter school resides for approval of those prompts.
So here's the process that that gives the state board approved last January is to the LEA again in partnership with stakeholders the school site council at the school level to develop the school plan which includes to address and meet the CSI planning requirements.
The LEA school governing board approves and approves that school plan.
Then the LEA would then summarize its support as we talked about in those CSI those three prompts in the plan summary for the LCAP.
The county office would approve those LCAPs, including those CSI prompts, if there was any county office that were identified for CSI or those schools, those LCAPs would come to the CDE, specifically my office, for review and approval.
And then the CDE would recommend to you, which is where we are here today, to ask you that you would approve the plan summaries, which would constitute approval of the plan, of CSI plans.
And that's that.
So with that, the CDE recommends that the State Board of Education approve the CSI school plans as represented by the CSI plan summaries for those LEAs that are referenced in Attachment 1.
All right, I wanna turn to liaison Sue Burr to comment on this item.
So I think, Jeff, you mentioned this, but I wanna reinforce that we developed this process to be consistent with LCAP and our whole philosophy of having an integrated system so that we weren't taking schools down a different path from what we're doing in LCAP.
So now we're seeing the manifestation of this and so I just want to emphasize that in this little chart it talks about the county office approving the LCAP which includes the CSI plan summary and consistent with our conversation this morning, the counties are the responsible entity.
Then it comes up here and it really is
It's kind of I don't want to say pro forma But the the main decision is being made at the local level and then we're as at the State Education Agency responsible for saying yes, that's Good, and that's what you see manifested here, so I'm ready to make a motion when we're ready As are there any clarifying questions for Jeff
We'll hold on to that.
We'll get there.
Then I'm going to ask for a public comment.
Do we have any?
We have four people signed up for public comment.
Jennifer Hicks, Ruth Barajas, Savannah Campbell, and Samantha Tran.
And please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Hello again, Jennifer Hicks, Assistant Superintendent of Curriculum and Instruction for Placer County Office of Education.
I'm here again on behalf of CSESA and county offices.
I'd just like to share some perspective on how COEs are supporting our districts and the development and implementation of their CSI plans.
Training for COEs on approval of the CSI prompts was done in collaboration with CDE and included calibration of that review process.
While the role of COEs includes approving the three prompts included in the LCAP, the primary support and guidance actually happens at the front end of the process.
Using our model of continuous improvement and support, COEs work with districts during the development of their CSI plans, just as we support districts with the development of their LCAPs.
For example, in Placer County, staff supports districts who were both in DA and a CSI school during the differentiated assistance process to ensure that their plans are aligned and coherent.
During LCAP development, staff worked with districts to refine and improve responses to the CSI prompts through coaching and feedback.
Thank you.
Hello again.
My name is Ruth Barajas and I am speaking on behalf of Californians Together.
On page two of this item in the paragraph that describes the process that county offices should use in supporting districts with CSI schools we recommend that the language be inserted directly directing the districts and county offices to address the needs of the student subgroups for which there are performance gaps.
and needs that could exist at a more intensive level than that within that district as a whole.
For example a CSI school could have a high percentage of African-American students with significant performance gaps that does not surface at the district level but should be addressed in the CSI plans.
This is an important distinction.
It could apply to any subgroup and we believe that it should be contained in the directions in this board item.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Samantha Tran with Children Now.
We are concerned that there is not enough oversight on the CSI plans.
We really appreciate the prompt that was included in the LCAP because it allows for community engagement but worry that that summary language as an approval mechanism at the county level is not sufficient to make sure that the ESSA requirements are being fulfilled and so would encourage the State Board to have LEAs send those plans to counties to be able to review it for legal
making sure the legal requirements are actually being met.
Thank you.
Hello, Liz Guillen with Public Advocates speaking for the Equity Coalition.
So, are these, the schools represented on this list are the ones that have been, have, where their LEAs have already failed them.
And so your oversight of them by the acceptance of these plans is that the counties did what they were supposed to do in reviewing those plans.
We have always been skeptical because there's so many.
We know that it's a lot of work.
But we would still like to see the board pursue a more direct review.
And we request that you make a future agenda item to discuss how our system of support, our one system, really meets the federal education obligation to these neediest of our students.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, I'm Savannah Campbell on behalf of EdVoice.
I'd like to echo the concerns of public advocates and children now.
These counties essentially only provide a compliance review of our CSI plans and LEAs only provide brief summaries of their approach to monitoring these plans.
For example LAUSD summarized its entire CSI support system for 47 CSI schools in only one short half page.
The board should pursue further action to ensure CSI plans and CSI schools SIPSA plans are reviewed for effectiveness in California's system of support in order to ensure that the needs of our most underserved students are being addressed.
Thank you very much for your consideration.
All right, seeing no more public comment, I think we are now open for discussion.
Okay, Member Burr, I mean Strauss.
You're sitting so close together.
I always see you, Sue, when I'm looking at it.
So I just want to make a comment about the process that we established, and now we're taking a look at the plans.
And I think, you know, there's local stakeholder input, there's school site council, and there's a plan that's developed
With our best intents that they're using data to inform it.
I just think we want to make sure that there's an external perspective on the development.
I just believe like, if districts.
If they knew what to do differently, I believe people would do it.
I think people are working really hard to try to address the needs that they have.
Overall, we know we have capacity issues.
We know we have stability issues.
We have new teachers.
We have training, but I think people are going through the process and then the county office is reviewing it.
And I just want to make sure going forward that we think about how do we make sure it's a quality plan that actually it's a good strategy.
I mean, there's lots of strategies, the school districts and schools I work with, we talk about coherent focus, like focus on a couple things and stay focused to make the difference.
So I think, I know we're following a process that we've already established and we're looking at the plans and they had to submit it, but I think down the line we need to take a look.
And I appreciate the success of comment about how they're reviewing the plan, but sometimes they're reviewing it after they've gone through all the steps of the stakeholder input.
And so how do we help them?
I appreciated that some county offices are working with people to help develop their plans before it gets approved.
But in this system of support process, I think we need to continue to think about the role of using high leverage practices,
working on capacity and helping develop a plan so that we do make a difference for the most needy students in the most needy schools.
a comment and then take other discussion, you know, we heard from the commenters, you know, that we, you know, want more detail about school gaps, you know, how do we have more direct review?
Is it only a compliance review, et cetera?
And that's the process that we have right now.
And so this is something that, you know, all these ideas are going beyond the item, which is an item that, you know, we need to approve.
But I do think to follow up on
Vice Chair Strauss's comments that, you know, we should be thinking about as we unfold the system of support, what do we want the review process to be?
Some states use a school quality review for schools that are identified for support and intervention, which brings in some expertise with, you know, a panel to look at a diagnostic of the school and maybe the district as well because the district may
in fact, be part of the problem for that school or not able to give them all that they need.
And then with the diagnostics, they can then really think about what's the strategy, what's the plan.
Sometimes when you're the fish in the water, you can't even see what you need unless you get some additional expert advice and counsel.
I know that CCEE has been in some cases working to create a very interesting and
intensive diagnostic process which is really producing more you know elaborated and informed ideas for the follow-up plan and that does include the district as well as the school and it's in line with our attention to districts as well as schools and we should be thinking about whether we you know want to expand something like that or do
You know, create a process by which it's more than a compliance review.
So, I just want to echo what Eileen said and encourage us to bring this back for further deliberation later while we, you know, move forward to approve this item, which is exactly the process that we have in place right now.
Any other discussion?
Yes, Member Felice.
Felice Ortiz-Lacon.
That long name.
You know, I, I struggle with this item and I actually reached out to staff because I said, what am I voting on?
And the reason why is that I went to the pre approved plans that were already approved.
I forgot about the process.
I mean, I knew that under the 1 system of.
accountability.
We wanted to be coherent and we wanted to streamline.
We are the SEA, so under ESSA, we have the responsibility to approve these.
But I asked, what am I voting on?
And then my next question was, where can I see the plans?
What can I see what they submitted?
If I don't have a link to see at the very least what was submitted, if I have no idea what was approved, I'm not going to read all 300 or so.
I'm not.
But will I look at a good number of them?
I would, just to see, whether it be because I'm a policymaker and responsible for this, because I'm a parent or in a public or a chismosa.
Whatever the reason is, I was going to go and click and see
Who are the student groups that are triggering identification, which is something that the LCAP template does not address under CSI?
Why are they?
What was the academic indicator?
What was the state indicator that prompted this?
Again, that's not included on the LCAP.
So for me, I have a really hard time knowing that that was the responsibility that was given to me by ESSA approving this when I've never even seen one of the plans.
I can't even click on something to say, well, here it is.
Look at it.
I have a hard time with that and I'm not sure how we could improve.
I do think we need to improve the process because we should be aware of what was reviewed at the local level.
What does that mean?
Are we seeing trends across the state that we should be aware of?
I have no information about that as of with this item currently.
Well, for the reasons that board member Ortiz-Lacon outlined, I was actually looking forward to and excited about this item and I'm still excited for those same reasons because this is our opportunity as the state education agency to learn in real time
about what our role and responsibility in this process actually means and actually looks like.
And so we are learning in real time.
What's one of the first things we just learned?
That in preparing for this item and in receiving this item that we're going to vote to approve,
It probably would have been a good idea to give a profile about the schools and the sites that have been identified in this process and whose plans were approved by the county offices.
It probably would have been a good idea to answer the questions that she raised.
It's not something mandated in the statute.
It's not something required or laid out in our plan.
But as the state education agency, we should know
something about what is going on as a trend in these schools and what's happening across the state in these schools and in these programs.
Who are the student groups?
What are the issues?
What was the criteria by which these schools were identified?
Are there differences among the counties?
Do we see some identification criteria happening more frequently than others?
That's something we weren't thinking about at the time we approved this process, but now that we're sitting here looking at this item, it becomes clear these are some questions we would like to know.
So that, I mean, that doesn't require a change in the plan.
That just simply means down the road, the next time we're looking at this, that's some kind of information we should have.
And then, how are we going to hold the county offices accountable for what they did in this CSI process?
You know, is there, even though we're not going to read all of the CSI plans, is somebody going to look at what the county offices actually did in their relationship with these schools to approve those plans?
And is there some guidance that we want to improve
or some additional guidance or criteria that we want to consider.
So again, we're learning about our role in real time and having an opportunity to say, okay, so now these are some questions that have arisen for me.
So I'm satisfied with the process that we're implementing, not because I think the process is perfect, but because we are moving forward and boldly implementing the process.
We're stubbing our toes and instead of just simply saying, ouch, and going on,
What I'm hoping is that because we're stubbing our toes and finding ourselves asking some questions or saying, here's what we forgot to ask about, that as we go forward and mature this process, our role and responsibility can mature as well.
And we improve not only what we ask you for, but also we understand the questions that we now know we should have asked about.
So I actually am ready to approve the item to go forward, but know that we're going to make some changes on the way we went about this work.
I think you, Board Member Rucker, I think she covered what I was going to say.
I simply would add that I think with, there's two issues and one is approving the plan and in the weeds approving the quality of the plan is really tough.
And I think if we could bring that back for a discussion in some way around the quality assurances that we can provide counties.
so that they can provide the quality assurance to the districts around when you submit these plans, we would expect that there's certain things that have been done in terms of the quality and effort to resolve the issues would be incredibly helpful because across the country, what you're seeing is as states are identifying TSI, CSI, and ATSI schools, California files right in the average.
And we're in good company with good states, Missouri, Michigan, New Jersey, Massachusetts.
They've got some good quality, some good things happening.
And then you've got the other skew.
You have a state that identified 100% of its schools to 50% of its schools, and they can't manage it.
So I think that
What's happening is in terms of being able to manage this improvement efforts that states are making, those that have identified on the high end are really struggling.
We have an opportunity because we haven't over-identified and we haven't under-identified in comparison to the states across the country.
But if we don't take advantage of this, I think very quickly, we're gonna get more CSI schools with no intensive guidance, and it could potentially, we could fall on the high end.
Well, you know, aside and apart, that's a good point.
Aside and apart from how many schools we identify, the question is, are we enabling them to have good plans and good supports to improve?
And I don't think from the distance of the state, one can know whether the plans are good.
We could ask Jeff to read more closely.
We could ask him to bring us more data.
data, but I actually think we have to think about the process that goes on at the school level and how we support that process at the school and district level to come up with the right diagnostics, to come up with the right kind of plan that will be helpful, and then to support them in being able to implement that plan.
So that's that bigger conversation that we're, you know, engaged in over these years and, you know, I think we want to continue to have that conversation and make sure that
that we're really enabling that for however many schools are identified.
That said, we appreciate the work that has been done in the department to review these and member Burr would you like to make a motion?
I'd just like to suggest that perhaps when we have an agenda that would allow for a more robust conversation about how this fits into the system of support, because I really appreciate that, and I know she was rushed, but the Deputy Superintendent from Placer County started to talk about how they're doing a lot of work around this.
That might give us some level of comfort.
I just have to say, for those of you who know how much I like ESSA, one of the reasons we did this was to make sure that the federal system was not overtaking the state system and that it fit appropriately in that system.
So I know we all still want to have comfort around that.
I would assume, I just want clarification either from you or Cindy, that if people really want to see these plans, they can look at the LCAPs for the districts because they should be part of that, right?
Sure, certainly the schools are identified within the LCAPs and then the plans themselves.
There is no statutory requirement to post the school plans, but they certainly can go through that to reach out to the schools to see those plans through the county, yes.
Well, so maybe that's something we want if people want to see those school plans, but again, I think the information is there.
It would just be helpful for us to learn more about it.
And with that, I would move the CDE recommendation to approve the CSI school plans.
I know that when we take this vote, this will close down the work on this item, but I really do want to say it is important for us to come back to the questions that have been raised that we forgot to think about.
And we need to figure out when we're going to have that discussion.
I think that's very important.
I think we're going to definitely loop back to that.
And with that, all in favor of the motion, say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed, say nay.
Nay.
One nay.
And any abstentions?
All right, motion passes.
Thank you.
The next agenda item is number nine and this is a public hearing.
It is an appeal from an action of the San Bernardino County Committee on school district organization to disapprove a petition to transfer territory from the Fontana Unified School District to the Etiwanda Elementary School District and the Chaffee Joint Union High School District and once we have finished our little shuffle, we will ask Larry Shirey to present.
Good afternoon.
Larry Shirey, School Fiscal Services Division.
As noted, this is an appeal of an action by the San Bernardino County Committee on School District Organization to disapprove a transfer of territory from Fontana Unified to Etiwanda Elementary and Chaffee Joint Union High School District.
The territory in question is part of a relatively new development that was built right on the boundary line between the districts.
About half the students are in Fontana Unified.
half across the boundary in the other two school districts.
The residents of Fontana Unified School District parcels have requested that their territory be transferred into Etiwanda for a number of reasons.
One is they think that everybody in the new development should be in the same districts.
Two, they claim that the Fontana schools are further away from their home than are the Etiwanda and Chaffee high school district schools.
And they also claim that it's less safe to travel, get students to the schools in Fontana.
Fontana Unified opposes the transfer.
Etiwanda and Chaffee are neutral.
We have three findings.
One is that, as you know, there are nine minimum threshold criteria that need to be met for each district reorganization.
We find that all nine are substantially met.
We note the second issue is that we note that there is considerable change going on in this area of Fontana Unified.
Thousands of new homes are being built.
next to and very near this area that's proposed for transfer.
New schools that will cover all 13 grades will be within, will be closer to the transfer area than any current school.
And with the development, of course, will come the improvements in infrastructure, sidewalks, bike paths, streets.
And this construction mitigates, has been mitigating because the construction is ongoing right now.
So, we feel, we find that this construction has mitigated and will continue to mitigate the concerns that the petitioners have raised regarding the transfer of territory.
489 new homes will be going in right next to this transfer area.
They'll be the neighbors of these petitioners and they're in Pontana Unified.
As I mentioned, two new schools closer than any school they have right now will be built close by.
And of course, the infrastructure will improve the sidewalks and the bike paths and the streets that lead from the homes in the proposed transfer area to Fontana Unified Schools.
And finally, we don't find any reason that's any local educational concern or reason that's substantial enough to warrant overturning the county committee decision to disapprove the territory transfer.
Given that, our recommendation is that the State Board affirm the decision of the San Bernardino County Committee on School District Organization to disapprove the proposal to transfer territory from the Fontana Unified School District to the Etiwanda Elementary School District and the Chaffee Joint Union High School District.
If you have any clarifying questions, I can take them now and of course I'll be here for other questions after the public hearing and public comment.
Yes, and I think we are going to hear from the petitioners on both sides so that a lot of our clarifying questions might get answered.
So, I think we'll move right ahead.
I'm going to hereby open the public hearing at 3.03, 3.02 p.m.
First, we'll hear from the petitioners.
The petitioners will have 10 minutes.
Then, we will hear from the county or districts that are opposing the territory transfer.
They will also have a total of 10 minutes.
After the presentations from both sides there will then be an opportunity for public comment from any individual who has not already presented for one minute each.
So we'll hear first from the petitioners and I assume our colleagues at the front table will time the presentation.
Do we have petitioners?
We have no petitioners.
Do we have opposition presentation?
The petitioners didn't come.
I guess not.
Do we have a presentation from the opposition to the petitioners?
Okay.
Yeah, so we'll hear your 10-minute presentation and then we'll take public comment.
Thank you.
Thank you, President Darning-Hammond, Board of Education members.
My name is Randall Bassett.
I'm the superintendent of schools with the Fontana Unified School District.
I've been with the Fontana School District.
I may be a little bit of an anomaly here with some educators, but I've been with that particular school district for nearly 25 years.
And I have been the superintendent of schools for the past three years.
During that time, we've seen a lot of development, a lot of changes in Fontana.
Fontana, if you know anything about it, at one point in time was a steel town.
And when Kaiser Steel went away, there was a lot of changes with what happened as far as values and properties, people that's lived, and there's been a lot of changes during that time.
I'm here today to encourage and support the recommendation of the San Bernardino County Committee on School District Reorganization and also the CD staff in denying the transfer.
Another reason I'm here is I want to take the opportunity to just share how this affects students within our district and how it affects districts.
A lot of times with those little nuances that we don't always understand how transfers affect everyone.
When this process started, I was the associate superintendent of business services for the school district.
I'm very involved in this.
We really received two petitions.
The first petition we approved and we saw a clear dividing physical boundary.
A street splits that development that was talked about.
We saw that on the other side, the west side of that boundary, that there were homes that you would see the backyards that were cut in half.
So you would have a few homes that would be in the Chafee School District and the Etiwanda School District.
Then you go to the neighbors, they'd be in the Fontana School District.
and it was just a switch back and forth.
We decided to approve the petition as far as those that were on the west side of the street that was the divider there.
But when the additional 59 came, we really do see that there are some challenges with that.
One of the biggest things, one of the most important things that we see is not just the financial, but it is really the diversity within our district.
People may not always consider that, but the value of the students that are within those homes are so important to our district, and what they offer, offering different opinions, offering different perspectives, and really, that is what builds up our students and makes our students stronger.
I, all three districts, the Fontana School District, the Chafee School District, and also the Edwanda School District, I believe are incredible districts, and there are complete desires to do what's best for their kids, and I think they're outstanding stewards of their resources.
And they approach those things in different ways.
And it's based on the needs of their students.
You even look at some of the things that are going on.
The Chafee School District just approved a bond for $842 million to improve their 12 schools, and that's something that's incredible that's going on.
Edwanda did, I believe it was $140 million bond for their K-8 schools.
And it also points out where we are in the Fontana School District and how this affects us as well.
There is a definite difference in the students that are served right now in those districts.
There is not just a difference as far as ethnicity.
There is also a difference as far as socioeconomic diversity.
The average income, according to census data, of the homes within that area that are proposing to be transferred, the average income of the household is $117,000.
The average income of zip code 92335, which is the primary zip code in the Fontana School District, is the household income is $48,000.
So there is a big difference and sometimes we look at what we want to see in schools.
I mentioned those two big bond issues.
Those were recently within the last couple of years within those two school districts.
The last time that Fontana was able to issue a bond was 2006, and it was for $275 million.
Just to put that into a little bit of perspective, if you break that down, it is about $35,000 a student that's being allocated within the Chafee School District for their high school district.
It is about 14,000 within the Etiwanda School District per student to help improve those facilities.
And remember, these serve the same areas within the Fontana School District.
Ours, with what we issued back in 2006, it's about $7,500.
But the values of the homes have not increased as rapid a pace as originally in plan.
So we were only able to issue $5,500 per student.
Now, that's for 46 schools.
It's a much larger district.
So that creates a lot of concerns.
Why I want to share this with you, it's not about the money, but in some ways it is about the resources that we provide to each and every one of our students.
So when you see things and funding discussions that come before you, the state has done some incredible things as far as with local control funding formula and with supplemental and concentration grant to address the needs of students that are served.
Facilities is still a huge issue because if you're in a district
that has lower housing values, which is typically where students of need reside, your bonding capacity is completely based on the value of your homes.
Completely based on the value of your homes.
So our ability to go out and do the bonds is limited.
So we want to make sure that our students have those resources.
And we are working and we're moving forward and making sure that the students that are there and that we serve, those students within that transfer, have all the opportunities and they have the opportunity to interact with our students as well.
We brought a lot of programs and opportunities.
We mentioned a couple new schools that are coming in.
We've already built a new school, a dual language immersion school, offering that opportunity and that's just been
there's a waiting list of 200 students just to get into the kindergarten within that dual language immersion school.
Another school that we're building within that area is we are building a design school that is focusing on emerging technologies that is a magnet school that they will be able to participate but be exposed to experiences that they may not be able to be exposed to in other schools.
So we're really trying to think about what are the opportunities that our students
see, what do they face, and it's something that has really changed how our staff approaches things.
It has changed how our students approach.
When you start approaching different opportunities and different perspectives, it was mentioned earlier, one of the key things that supports our state's economy is, it was referred to, the Silicon Valley.
Our students hadn't always been exposed to some of those things that maybe students that from higher incomes have been exposed to.
When we bring those together, we see opportunities.
We recently sent from one of our school sites that has a free and reduced lunch rate of approximately 94%.
We sent a team of four students to compete on the world level.
They won the international challenge at the World Robotics Organization, teaming up with a team from Nigeria and a team from Germany to bring home, if you want to say the gold, on an international level.
These four students, I won't get into the details, but they are the students that
We have English learners on that, and they were very positive, and they have, with those experiences, they've been exposed to things that they've never been able to be exposed to before.
We have made sure, done everything that we can to make sure that the schools and the students in this area are safe.
We just don't want to see a domino effect happen where if we say we're going to approve these 59 schools because we feel that we fit in this area.
We don't want it happening with those additional homes so that we delay bringing resources to other students within our district.
That is
a major consideration for our students, for our Board of Education, and making sure that we are able to provide not just those resources, the facility resources, but also the resources where they could truly work in a diverse environment that benefits them and gives them exposure to students from different ways of life.
Thank you very much for listening and consideration.
I know that this is a difficult decision, but we appreciate that you're willing to consider what we have to share.
Thank you very much.
So now I want to ask Matt Navo as our SBA.
I'm sorry.
Is there any other public comment?
All right.
Matt, as our SBA liaison, if you have any initial comments and then we'll
I think what what is Important for us to recognize in this petition that is different than maybe the last petition We had is in this petition.
What I understand is that the petitioner neither Neither that neither of the districts is asking for this change Right.
Yeah, and it's not a developer that's asking for the change and the petitioner is not here and
And I think what might be important is the petitioner continue to live in either of the districts?
It's our understanding that the petitioner no longer resides in the state.
I think at this point, I think my recommendation is we affirm the county committee's recommendation.
So I just had a couple of clarifying questions for Larry, if that's okay.
I know we've heard these before with neighborhoods and blocks and not wanting the neighbors across the street to go to a different school.
You said that this request actually met all nine criteria and that the construction and ongoing development was actually going to eventually address the issue.
That was in part of your early presentation.
Right.
The nine conditions are minimum standards and they're very difficult not to meet in small territory transfers like this.
The petitioner's primary concern was that they had that the sidewalks weren't fully built, they had no bike paths, that there was not a four-way stop at the corner where they came out of their development or weren't marked crosswalks.
A lot of those things are already, I mean, there is now a four-way stop, there are now crosswalks, sidewalks are being extended to the area, bike paths are being built.
They also made the issue, claimed that schools were closer in Etiwanda and Chaffee, which is not quite true, the elementary school.
in Etiwanda is closer than the current elementary school in Fontana.
The middle schools are about equidistant and the Chaffee High School is about twice as far away as is the Fontana High School of residence.
The development is coming in, building, there's a lot of empty space there, obviously, when you're talking about thousands of homes that are being built within a mile and a half or so of this residence.
It's at the base of the Angeles National Forest, northern part of the city of Fontana, if you know the area.
So, it's, the development is bringing houses.
in Fontana Unified closer to this transfer area.
As I said, some 489, I believe, will be right adjacent to the proposed transfer area, right on the same street that the superintendent mentioned was the dividing line.
So for me, I think the superintendent said I know it's a difficult decision.
No, it's not.
It's going to be 500 new homes that are built.
They just, they bought in a newly developed development.
But we knew, when did we know he wasn't or she wasn't showing up?
Because I'm wondering why we didn't pull the item.
It's, you know, we, all the mail that we were sending out was, was not being returned.
And I just got, we just got kind of concerned because we hadn't heard from the petitioners.
So we talked to the county office and they indicated they hadn't.
If I could back up just a moment.
Now, often you have more widespread support in a community for this effort.
In this case, our understanding is this pretty, pretty much a one-person effort in terms of getting the petition going, gathering the signatures, presenting to the county committee and making the appeal.
And now she's not here.
So,
We just were a little, I don't want to use the word suspicious, but a little concerned that we hadn't heard from this individual.
County office and their discussions were also concerned.
So we made a phone call to the number on residence and the person who answered indicated that she no longer was a resident of the state.
And that was in October.
The home just recently sold we understood that's why the mail what mail wasn't returning So it was it was in October this year when we when we Last year, we could spend time on that detective Hunt, but I think we have a consensus about this item And what we should do with it, so I'd love to hear a motion.
I
Emotion okay, thank you very much any further discussion all in favor of The CDE recommendations say aye any opposed say nay any abstentions motion carries.
Thank you very much
Item 10, is this one still, this is on and complete and in full?
Yeah.
Yes.
Right.
We had two CTE items so I just want to be sure I'm on the right one.
Item 10 is the development of the draft federal Perkins five-state plan for career technical education and this item will be presented by whom?
Well, I'm going to acknowledge, Ting, are you going to take it from here?
You're the State Board Liaison and you will introduce the chair of our committee.
Yes.
Thank you.
All right.
Yes, I am the State Board Liaison to this item and I am very pleased to start this item by introducing to you Jolina Grande.
Jolina is a faculty member at the Cypress College in Orange County and a member of the California Community Colleges Board of Governors.
And more importantly, she has been the chair of the California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee, which has been leading this work.
And so I'd like to introduce Jolina to you and she's going to say a few words as an introduction.
Well, thank you.
Vice Chair Ting Sun didn't mention that I am only trying to emulate her footsteps that she chaired the Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee in 2017 and 2018.
So I merely am trying to do the ominous or the beneficial job of following her lead.
Like she said, my name is Jolena Grande, and I am a faculty member of longstanding in the North Orange County Community College District.
And since 2018, I've had the privilege of serving as one of the appointees to the California Community College's Board of Governors and serving on the Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee.
I am joined with two other members of the Board of Governors, Bill Rawlings and Alma Salazar, currently.
But I want to recognize the contributions of our former Board of Governors members on the Workforce Advisory Committee, Dr. Joseph Polanski, Dr. Mon Fon, Pam Haynes, and Amy Costa.
Because we, as members of the Board of Governors, have been beyond fortunate to work alongside the state board members, Rucker, Ortiz-Lincoln, and Sun.
in shepherding the draft plan that is your agenda item number 10 being presented today by Dr. Pradeep Kottamraju.
It is only through the incredible collaboration of the staff and other personnel of the California Department of Education, the State Board of Education, and the Community College Chancellor's Office that we have the federal Perkins application for your consideration today.
and I hope you'll find the work product captures California's plan for ensuring all elementary, secondary, and post-secondary students in our collective K-14 college and career pathways across the state can participate in established, new, and proposed programs of study that will take them from cradle to career, if I borrow Dr. Cocteau-Merjue's term of endearment.
I use cradle to grave in my profession.
and leverage our state's infrastructure to create careers and jobs for the 21st century.
Because I am privileged to say not only am I a product of the K-14 voc ed system, but being able to teach in the mortuary science and funeral service education programs at Cypress College has really allowed me to shepherd in what are the future practitioners in healthcare.
So thank you very much, and I hope that you'll have plenty of questions for us.
I doubt there will be 26 public comments all lined up.
Well, we don't know yet, although there's hardly 26 people here, so.
Thank you very much.
All right.
And I'd like to acknowledge Kai Jackson, Deputy Superintendent of Public Instruction at CDE, who would also like to make some introductory remarks.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond and board members.
I really want to echo the comments of Chair Grande and note that what you'll hear today from Dr. Kodum Raju is really
a reflection of the intense work between the SBE staff, the community college staff, the CDE staff, and as a reflection of the guidance and leadership of the joint workforce board.
And really we just want to let you know and on behalf of
Vice Chancellor Weber who was not able to be here with us today that we really hope this gives you some insight into what this will do in ushering in a collaborative system across the educational system and the workforce system for a Perkins 5 plan and eventually a California state plan for CTE.
And so with that I turn it over to Dr. Khodumraju.
Thank you very much.
And we invite you to begin.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
My name is Pradeep Kutmarju.
I'm the director of the Korean College Transition Division.
I don't have the luxury to gloat like Michelle Center, because this is my first time in front of you.
And good luck, Michelle.
Just to set the stage here, as has been mentioned before, this is a collaboration between three agencies led by the State Board of Education, who is the eligible agency for the federal Perkins funds.
The Department of Education is the fiscal agent.
and the Community College Chancellor's Office is the primary partner responsible for the implementation of the law at the community college level.
What I will be providing to you will be a brief history of the Perkins V Act.
And we'll review each major strand of the draft Perkins plan.
And when I come to the accountability section, we'll talk about the addendum item that's in front of you.
In addition to that, you also have
The agenda item, you also have two attachments.
One attachment is a page reference guide for the draft plan, and you also have a timeline with that.
You also provided a December memo that described a lot of the things that I will talk about today.
Just to set the stage here, I'll talk about major changes in the law.
We'll talk about the transition plan.
And we'll move to talking about the different strands.
And one of the things that we've done to sort of have an interactive discussion is after each strand, we will break and allow you to
provide comments to this so it doesn't mean speaking for the next 45 minutes and we can have an interactive discussion.
I should point out that this is really just an information item and there's no action to be taken right now.
The action will be taken at the March State Board meeting.
We will talk about the project timeline and then discuss the next steps.
One of the intent of this
draft Perkins V state plan is to provide a basis for a more larger, comprehensive state plan for CTE as we move forward, and we'll come and talk about that when we discuss the timeline.
So talking about the major changes from Perkins IV to Perkins V. Perkins IV was, the legislation was authorized by Congress in 2006.
Perkins V was authorized by Congress in 2018.
And the difference from 2006 to 2018, both nationally as well as within the state of California, is markedly different.
In 2006, we were going into a recession, the Great Recession.
In 2018, we have a skills shortage, and the focus on equity, not only in California, but nationwide, is paramount.
The changes from the two pieces of legislation is in the Perkins V legislation, there is more explicit definition of various terms that follow either definitions that were in ESSA or definitions that were in WIOA, the Workforce Innovation Opportunities Act.
Meeting the needs of special population is introduced as a separate strand.
There is a new strand on teacher and faculty preparation, and there is a new requirement to develop a comprehensive local needs assessment, which is new for
in the Perkins plan.
And finally, there's an inclusion of accountability indicator projections and the process of negotiation with the United States Department of Education.
One thing I would, and that's when I will talk about the addendum item.
Prior to Perkins V,
The way we negotiated accountability was we talked, we had conversations with the U.S.
Department of Education every year, and we set the targets for the accountability indicator.
That is no longer the case under Perkins V. It is really a state-determined effort to move the accountability forward, and as I'll talk about later,
how we're trying to take the CTE data and aligning it to the larger effort on the California accountability model.
The development of the plan was, as has been pointed out, was led by the California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee.
Staff from SBE and CDE and the Chancellor's Office jointly worked
on the Perkins V State Plan Development.
States have the option to either complete the plan, a four-year plan, or submit a transition plan and then complete a four-year plan.
All states, including California, chose to submit a transition plan, and that was approved by you on May 8, 2019.
We then move forward to developing the full four-year state plan, and once again, it was led by the California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee.
Just for brevity, I will refer to them as the Joint Advisory Committee.
Here again, the staff continued to work.
The staff from the three agencies continued work to develop.
the draft Federal Perkins V State Plan, and we held stakeholder meetings and key informant meetings in the fall of 2019.
We took information from that stakeholder key informant input and included where relevant within a draft plan for the Perkins V State Plan.
The joint advisory committee approved the draft Perkins plan on November 25th, 2019, and moved it forward to public comment.
Here are the major strands for the plan.
Perkins five state state plan and we provided the pages for you that is in reference within the plan in in your attachment one that you have there is a link there for the entire plan and those that's what's referred to those page numbers are referring to.
So when we looked at basically how we started through, before I, looking through this, we started this full planning process in June of 2019.
And we went through various drafts of this plan until we brought it forward on November 25th, and essentially moved that forward for approval.
So there was a lot more, there was,
tremendous activity that was going on between June and November in terms of the different iterations that we had to go through in terms of meeting the requirements, the federal requirements of the state plan.
So the first strand that I would like to talk about is essentially the plan development and consultation.
That is referred to in the legislation as stakeholder and key informant consultation.
What drove that, the whole process of plan development consultation, were the guiding policy principles and the essential elements of the joint advisory committee.
In the plan, we talked quite extensively about the joint management team, which is essentially the staff from the three agencies, and we discussed the stakeholder meetings and the key informants, the input within that section.
We also, within that section, described the public comment period.
The public comment period basically went through the month of December.
We just ended last Friday, and we're just getting that information and curating that information, and we'll be having a
all-day meeting on Friday to look at that information, and we will bring that information first to the Joint Advisory Committee, and we'll talk to you about that in March.
So I'll stop here, and if there are any comments for the Plan Development Consultation, I'll announce any questions.
And I would also invite my colleagues on the advisory committee if they had any comments as well.
And I just again to just frame this conversation for my fellow board members.
What we're commenting on today is the Perkins State plan application.
It is a federal application for funds.
The work of the committee has been broader, has been looking at larger career pathways, CTE pathways, and how statewide we can work more closely with a community college system.
But this one you'll find a little bit more narrow in the scope.
and in the application than some of the larger conversations we've been having on our committee.
Just to add on to Member Sun's comment here, in 2008 when Perkins IV was, 2006 when it was authorized, the ratio of state funding to federal funding in California was, I'm only looking at the CDE portion, was one is to one.
the ratio of Perkins funding to state funding for CTE under Perkins 5 when it started in 2018 is, and I'm being conservative, it's between one federal, four state funding.
So there's a lot more state funding for CTE than there was at the time of Perkins 4.
And so we do have to look at this CTE in California more globally and rather than just this federal piece.
And as I said before,
intending to do that.
That's the idea, just so that it would be interactive.
I just want to be sure that... Some global comments at this point.
Yes, go ahead, Felisa.
Actually, I'll wait for public comment because I have a very specific question.
The next section of the next strand that was discussed in the plan talks about essentially the linkage that is made between the different state efforts, not only at the K-12 level with the
post-secondary side, but also with workforce development and business industry.
And undergirding all of that is, as we've said before, is the Joint Advisory Committee's guiding principles, policy principles, and essential elements.
And that, through our stakeholder group, led to the creation of a vision that
that is in front of you and basically talks about it is a vision that was essentially developed at a stakeholder meeting and then refined and crafted and included within this plan as required by the legislation.
So once again, I'll again talk about any comments on the vision.
I think it's important here to make note of the fact that while there is the mandate in the federal statute about what our vision has to be concerning career technical education, we also have some existing state policies and mandates that also inform this, so I think it's important
going forward to make sure that they understand that.
And this is really a bow to my colleagues, Board Member Sue Burr, that we were very careful in looking at those state requirements that what became the defining frame for us was our overarching state policy.
So I think it's important to make sure we do make that point here for our colleagues on the board.
One of the things I would say as you've gone through the plan, the guiding policy principles and the essential elements are strewn throughout that plan in different ways.
And I think that was the intent in some sense.
And I've heard from others who've looked at this plan that they appreciated the fact that we included that within the plan.
Any other comments?
So this is the largest strand that we had to address, as you can see from the page numbers, it was basically two-thirds of the plan that we had to address, which has talked about the description of the different CT programs and programs of study.
Most of the programs were not only long-standing state programs, but also the newer state programs that have come online.
We talked about program approval,
And we talked about, and in that, both in terms of both secondary as well as the community colleges, and we talked about the different electronic products that we use to inform about the, like CTE Teach Online.
California has been recognized for the CTE Teach Online as a model professional development electronic product.
And throughout this strand, we talked about the predominance of state programs.
The one thing I would like to make was made throughout this, as Member Rucker just pointed to, is we tried to balance between
where there needed to be state leadership and where there needed to be basically local control in some sense.
And we tried to sort of strike that balance, whether we did or not in the document, is something that we will continue to strive towards.
But that balance was very important.
for the joint advisory committee members and we wanted to make sure that that balance was struck.
We also had a discussion about dual enrollment and we talked about the role of not only the eligible agency, the State Board of Education, but also at the local institution in terms of how programs are implemented at the local level.
We also talked about dual enrollment.
We then talked about the stakeholder input and included information from that stakeholder input where relevant into this strand.
We have a lot more stakeholder input.
We intend to use all of that when we develop the comprehensive state plan for CTE.
The section also talked about a local application process.
The local application process has always been part of Perkins legislation.
But what is new under Perkins V is this comprehensive local needs assessment.
And what that comprehensive local needs assessment does is essentially
require local recipients of Perkins funds to develop a stakeholder group at the local level
have a local needs assessment, discuss this local needs assessment, and then use that information to inform the local application plan.
And one of the requirements would be to looking at, for example, looking at the discrepancies or disparities between performance gaps among subpopulations and using that to allocate funds towards that.
Well, it's early right now, but I think one of the things in the future, and as we talk about the comprehensive CTE plan, aligning it with the LCAP and the LCFF is something that we'll be looking towards as we move forward.
So once again, I'll stop here.
Any discussion on
I have a clarification question on that last local needs assessment.
It's a discretionary call as to whether the disparities data would be made available or that is already something that's baked into the proposal?
So there is a whole section on accountability that Perkins is required to collect and that's the data.
And when the data is reported to the federal government, we report not only the overall
accountability indicators, we also report performance in the sub-indicators as well.
And so they will have that information as part of their discussion at that stakeholder group in terms of looking at the, at the performance gaps and that's the, that's the role of the state in providing that information.
I think it's important to share with the board also that in the development of this particular section of the plan, this is probably the part of the document that's intended to be a living document.
There's an opportunity as we move through
the from the doing the planning and drafting to implementation, there's the opportunity as we learn about the implementation and what is going on to make revisions and to do an update that reflects the reality of what the implementation looks like.
So while the plan may look good on the drawing board,
We actually, just as we learned in our previous item, we thought we had figured out what was going to work and we figured out, oops, there's something we forgot to ask about.
This section of the plan is intended to be a living document that we can go back and rework when the realities of implementation actually are, we're actually faced with those.
One of the benefits of this process versus ESSA was that with ESSA we had regulations, we had adhere by a template.
We started this process before and we really talked about the vision and we outlined some principles that I know all of you have
already read, but one of the things that we really talked about was how do we make sure that this becomes college and career readiness, right?
This is tied to the CCI, so it's not just its own standalone independent thing that's not part of our larger system of support, accountability, and LCAP.
So with that said, we really focus on equity, and I'm saying all this because I'm looking at this now, on the performance levels.
And so I missed the November 25th meeting.
One of the things that we, the state board members, really emphasized was if this is really college and career, then we need to have equal expectations and performance levels for students that are pursuing a college path and students that may want to pursue the career pathway.
Otherwise, we're going to develop a tier system, right, and a hierarchical system.
And so, why did we not up the graduation rate for the four-year graduation rate?
I'm just going to get right to it.
It's 90% for our high school students.
That's our graduation rate, 90.5 for extended.
But if I'm looking at this here, and we had an in-depth discussion about this, I thought it's 86% in 2020, 86.6, 88.5, but it doesn't even reach 90% by 2023.
So if we want to really create a system that is rigorous, career pathways, that set expectations at our college and career, then we shouldn't have differentiated expectations for students that will graduate through career pathways.
And I think that we need to make sure that before this comes back to us in March, that we do up that four-year graduation rate to reflect the conversations that we had, robust conversations I would add, during the joint commission.
Thank you.
Other board comments?
OK, so you want to.
I was going to say something.
Oh, I'm sorry.
It's here.
So I don't know if you want to address that now or do you want.
Can I wait till we get to the accountability section and talk about that, because we'll be talking about the update to this table and talking more about this table.
Put it on your list of items.
OK.
All right.
So please continue.
The next trend is to talking about the meeting the needs of special populations.
Historically, the federal Perkins legislation has always focused on a special population, the underserved populations.
And in fact, until the Perkins legislation itself,
It was really a set-aside legislation all the way back to the Vocational Education Act of the late 50s and early 60s.
So it's only in the Perkins era that there was a much more cohesive approach to looking at
overall student performance, but still retaining the special population as an important focus within the legislation.
And there is a section or strand where we have to address the special populations, but like the special populations
was addressed in several places within the document itself.
And the focus this time around, how do we link the needs of special population to high-quality CTE courses and programs?
And we included stakeholder comments as part of that section.
Once again, I'll just
Yes, and I was reviewing the definitions for special populations, and I was happy to see it be very inclusive, but what I did see missing was incarcerated youth.
And I was happy to see that there were some very constructive stakeholder comments talking about partnering with the Department of Juvenile Justice and making sure
that are incarcerated youth are served as well in this, and so I just wanted to support that because I don't want those students who are incarcerated, and I know it's difficult, especially, hopefully they're not there very long, but some really are there a long time, and it's really important that we include them.
Other comments on this part?
Okay, please continue.
This is a brand new section in the legislation that is preparing teachers and faculty.
Given the shortage of teachers all around, and particularly in the Korean technical education area, teacher recruitment and retention, and I put teacher recruitment and retention
but it also refers to faculty at the community colleges as well.
And one of the things that we have to look at very carefully is how can we incentivize the system?
And the other piece that I think when we come into implementation is because teacher recruitment and retention are
included in several federal legislation now in terms of looking at that in different ways.
And there may be some synergies there in trying to sort of coalesce that together and looking at and braiding funds, for example,
this particular area and moving and looking at teacher recruitment and retention.
The other piece is that the the the CTC has made recommendations on teaching CTE teacher preparation and we'll be taking a look at that as we move forward.
Any comments on this part?
Member Rucker.
So I wanted to ask, is this the appropriate time to talk about not only the preparation issues but the recruitment issues that you raised in the plan?
Because some of the, while we have control over the preparation and support concerns that we're required to address in the plan, there are some recruitment and retention issues that we do
not have control over and you highlighted that.
Could you share some, I think it's important to share some of that information in this conversation here.
I think one of the issues about recruitment and retention is that, as in most states, it's actually in two areas.
One is that the authorizing entity for teachers is the CTC.
And so we have to start with that.
But there are two areas that really in terms of recruitment retention that we have to consider.
One is the fact that there is what are called designated subject areas.
And that is one area.
So there's a fifth year of teaching that is required in some sense to be designated in one of the CTE areas.
But the second area is recruitment from industry.
And while they may have the technical skills for that,
sometimes the pedagogy might be lacking there.
And how we do that, and that's where the incentives come in, is what kinds of mechanisms we can put in there to develop that pedagogy for those who did not come into the teacher education pathway the conventional way.
Am I right that the CTC is working to refine that whole credentialing process?
Because it's quite laborious.
They did make recommendations.
We're still waiting to see what the next steps are.
Okay, so that's an ongoing process as I understand.
Are there other comments on this part?
Okay, please continue.
The fiscal responsibility is a section that we have to address, and just to sort of elaborate on this fiscal responsibility piece, as I said before, the State Board of Education is the eligible agency.
The California Department of Education is the fiscal agent for the $127 million funds that come annually into the state.
and the community colleges are partners of that.
The distribution of funds, without getting very technical about that, is really, you have to think about it in two ways.
One is, it's roughly 50-50 between the two community colleges and the NCDE, the high school and community colleges.
There is, and the other breakdown is that 85% of those funds have to go to the local, to the fields.
15% is kept at the state level, 5% is administration, and 10% is leadership funds.
Those leadership funds are essentially funds that the state can use to have regional or statewide projects on areas of policy interest.
Teacher recruitment retention comes to mind, for example.
Dual enrollment may be another area that's there, whether targeting some special populations in terms of performance gaps.
And even part of that 85% that we send out to the field, the state has the option of keeping 15% of that at the state and then reposition that as either as competitive grants or come up with different criteria.
They're called reserve grants.
excuse me, they're called reserve funds and they could even be competitive and sent out in different ways where you could have like a granting process for that rather than a simple allocation, allocated process that is traditionally used.
And that's something that we might want to look at.
as we move forward in implementation.
The other piece to keep in mind here in terms of distribution of funds is that the distribution of funds is essentially based on, to the local level, it permits consortia.
If, based on calculations, if a recipient doesn't reach a $15,000 threshold at a local school district, let's say, the law requires them to form a consortia with other school districts.
It's applicable in California at the school district level.
It's not because the community colleges are large enough that it's really not applicable to them.
But in California, as many of you know, the State Board of Education has that school districts can petition to the State Board of Education to waive that requirement.
and the State Board of Education has done that on occasion.
There are about 17 or 18 school districts that even though they get less than $15,000 from Perkins funds, are operating as single recipients rather than a part of a consortium.
The last piece I want to talk here is, at the community college level,
The funding allocation is based on, traditionally has been based on Pell grants.
Pell grants in terms of CT.
In California, there's an alternative formula and the logic behind that was to say that it actually made the distribution a lot more equitable and included, if you look at the plan, there is a whole list of criteria that is used to create the distribution to the community colleges.
Okay, Member Rucker, go ahead.
I think it's important to say here that some of what is written in the plan is also reflected in the budget bill and in the budget trailer bills that are under development now because part of that is driven not just by the mandate in Perkins but what we have under existing state law.
So what you read when you read the fiscal plan, a lot of that has been laid out by previous work that was undertaken both by the Department of Finance
and by the Joint Workforce Pathways Group in talking to finance, not only to create the criteria for accountability, and that was something we did in a previous year, but also to address existing state requirements on doing the budgeting and agreements between
the two the multiple state agencies on divvying up those funds.
So I think it's very it's this is something a lot of stakeholder input has already created and crafted and so a lot of those agreements were carried forward in that fiscal plan.
Thank you.
Are there other comments on this part?
Okay please continue.
This is the part that everyone wants to talk about so
So let me, it's a background on accountability, what I'll call Perkins accountability, which is a federal accountability requirement for CT students.
So the first thing to keep in mind is that in Perkins legislation, there is a student who is defined as a concentrator.
A concentrator is basically someone who takes more than simply just one course of CTE in a pathway.
And one of the things in Perkins V is that they actually want states to define a concentrator.
And a concentrator in California has been defined as one of the elements in the data elements in the CCI, which is essentially the CTE course data.
That is really the concentrator that we are going to be using in order to, so that becomes the denominator in some, in the, for all of the indicators.
And as you look at the attachment that you had, the addendum item,
and look at the attachment there.
There are 10 indicators there, that's seven at the secondary level and three at the community college level.
The extended graduation rate is an optional that we can add later on once I think the state sort of firms those numbers up in different ways.
And the quality indicator is the state is required to choose one of those three.
and the state has decided to choose, basically attain post-secondary credits, which in California, it's really the college credit courses that is part of the CCI.
So one of the rationale for using that is in the other two, one, the data is more, there are at least two years of data right now for that,
There are also methodological issues regarding work-based learning and post-secondary credentials in terms of collecting that information.
So we ended up deciding to use attained post-secondary credits, but that doesn't mean we cannot choose all three in the future.
In fact, we can add more, as many as we want within this system,
but we have to account for.
And the reason for being cautious on adding is probably now looking at the table that you were talking about.
So let me just explain how these numbers, I'll only concentrate on the secondary side.
The graduation rate, and I may have to step back a bit here, prior to CALPADS,
The Perkins data was collected separately through what is called an E1 and E2 system.
E1 referred to essentially participation and concentration, and the E2 referred to what is called post-program placement, where did they go after they graduated from high school.
And we collected that separately.
E1 was where the recipients, and the other thing to remember,
It was only those who received Perkins funds that reported data to us, to the CCTD.
And the other thing to remember about this is that basically on the E2 side of the post-program placement, it was done on a survey basis.
School districts sent a survey out to their graduates and essentially got the information back.
What we are now trying to do with the help of AMART and EDD and other data is to look at essentially how can we use CALPADS to collect information for all CTE students regardless of whether
the whether the school district or the consortium is receiving Perkins funds.
So we are starting to put in a process where when school districts go in and enter data, they will be entering CTE data within the CalPADS system from which we can then extract and meet some of these indicators.
So
The member Ortiz-Lacona, I will go back and check on the graduation rate, but the proficiency, the three academic proficiency, are actually the rates that were provided to me by Michelle Center by her staff in terms, this reflects all students in assessment, just not CTE students, and that's the number they projected for that.
So for the graduation rate, we're firm.
It's 90%.
It's what we aim for.
That one should be an easy change.
And hopefully when we come back in March, that is the number that is reflected there.
Because again, I know that we've talked about it at length.
For I'm now reading a letter and I know public comment will probably reiterate this The letter also states that we're not in alignment with our academic proficiency in math in the LA So just something to also look at When you're you go back to Michelle and Michelle make sure well, he said you gave him the numbers so when you go back to Michelle to look at that make sure that Again, what the one thing we don't want to do is lower the expectation for CT concentrators because of the message that we will send is dangerous
you
OK, so I have a couple of questions about the data itself and the role of CALPADS in doing this work, particularly informing the data about secondary programs.
One of the requirements in Perkins is to define a CTE concentrator.
And right now, one of the shortcomings in CALPADS is even though we do report and record
and collect all information about course taking for high school students, there is not a field in CALPADS that will flag that student as a CTE concentrator.
Is that correct?
Actually, we always had that.
We refined that definition.
We actually now have that in CALPADS where we can extract that data from CALPADS.
Okay, so now we are going to be able to do that.
Correct.
Okay.
So, the second thing I wanna clarify is for this information, in the conversations that we have had at the work group, there has always been this bifurcation about what's in the numerator and what's in the denominator as it relates to who are the students we're talking about.
And so, a lot of the conversation we had focused solely on those CTE concentrators.
So,
Based on what you just said in response to board member Ortiz-Lacon, are you saying these numbers are based on a denominator where the denominator is all students?
because this... Let me finish my question.
So where the denominator is all students and the numerator is just the subgroup of CTE concentrators?
It's also all students.
So it's really the data for all students who took assessment tests.
So the logic here that we're going to make is that, as member Ortiz-Lacombe said, we want to make sure that the students are performing at the same level as all of the students.
So we will refine this.
I'm working with AMR to actually
looking at the denominator and trying to sort of look at those students and then get these measures just for those students.
But right now, we included them in this as a way of a baseline because one of the requirements of this table is that
We have to provide this, as you know, as part of the plan.
And we, the baseline that we chose was very similar to what's in either in the CCI or, and using that information other than the post-program placement and non-TRAD program concentration.
but we do have the option to keep the same rate for two years and we intended to do that even though there might be growth every year in terms of looking at that we do have the option to project out and we were trying to be conservative
for the reason that I think when we, and there was a question about addressing disparities and gaps in performance, that's one of the issues that if we fail to perform at any of these targets, there has to be a process of a corrective action plan to put into place
that is required input from the different stakeholder groups.
So these numbers, I would argue, are conservative in some sense, just to make sure that we can refine them because we do not have to report data till December of 2021.
Okay, so then this will lead me to my next question.
I'm absolutely sure now that I've missed a board meeting because I don't remember a board meeting where I voted that the state developed performance level would be 32.5% proficiency statewide for all students.
I don't believe that's what we voted for, but you just explained to me that's what this chart means.
It was just a projection.
It was not something... But you said you got these numbers from Michelle Center.
As a projection number.
Okay.
And we're saying, what I am saying, is these numbers, we're not interested in the projection, we're interested in these numbers showing where the baseline is and the trajectory to meet our state goal.
That's what we keep saying and so we're having two different conversations.
You're having a conversation about projections and we're having and what we are saying with the three of us on the board have been saying is you need to set the baseline and identify what it is and the long-term goal that needs to be specified in this document
in whichever column you want to put it in, outside of the baseline column, needs to be the state-adopted goals for performance for those students based on those assessments.
So we're still having two different conversations.
And so I see... I just want to be clear so we can move on to other topics that you want to be sure that the goals are articulated, not just a projection.
Yes.
Okay.
Are there other issues that we want to get on this accountability piece?
I think the question, and this is for my other colleagues on board, is that on a policy basis, we want to establish for CTE concentrators the same level of performance that we would set statewide for all students.
Now, the practical implications of that, and I think that's the issue, is that we have to report these numbers, and if we do not hit
are aspirational goals, then we would have to do some... There is a corrective action plan prior to this.
Basically, if you did not meet the goals, it was a conversation between the U.S.
Department of Education and the state.
Now it requires, in some sense, to bring back the stakeholder group, have a discussion with them, and put in a corrective action plan.
So there are more steps involved in this process, and that's why I think in the, and Member Rucker, you're right in some sense,
That I think because data is, since we're moving to CALPADS and data is minimal, I would say right now, with regard to CTE, I would say that that's something we're doing in conversation.
All right, thank you.
Michelle.
Michelle, Senator, I just want to make a couple clarifying points.
One, Member Rucker, I think you asked about the baseline, so let me just explain what is in the baseline column.
So for science, the baseline is the impact data that you all saw when we set the standard setting for all students, right, for our first operational year.
That would be the baseline.
You're looking, yes?
And then the baseline for ELA and MAP, instead of taking a single year, we looked across the last four years.
Okay, so that would be the, that is the baseline column that you see there.
Then, yeah, and then I think there is, maybe we might want some direction from you on how to determine what we want the predictions to be, because there really isn't, that I'm aware of,
board adopted target in the same metric that you see in that table, which is an expectation for percent perficient at a percentage level.
That's
We have not come out and said we expect 50% of our students to be proficient in science in a certain year.
So I think that's the part that we're struggling with, not that we want to be inconsistent with things that we've said, but the metrics that we've used are not in the same metrics that you see in that table.
Does that help at all?
That helps but that's again.
I think I've missed a board meeting because I disagree with that I think let's let's get remember son you wanted to say something remember well I think that that so this is While this is specific to CTE concentrators.
It actually asks a much bigger question of us
And one that I think a member of Lisa Ortiz-Lacon has asked, are we going to set measures that we want to try to hit, targets that we want to try to hit?
And in this case, it would be specific to CTE concentrators.
And this might be a start, but where do we want to go with this?
So this is why it's a really critical question.
We can go with baseline, and then as Dr. Kordemadji said, we could put some little targets along the way and try to be conservative, or we could go with what we feel we want to see us as a state move forward in.
And just to clarify, it sounds like if we set targets or goals that are not easily achievable, we will put ourselves into a corrective action cycle with the federal government.
And so I think it's going to be a nuanced decision that will need to be engaged in.
Before I come back to you, I want to see if anyone else has some comments they want to make Anyone else?
Okay, we're good.
Okay member Rucker.
Okay, so this is what?
Okay, so this is where my concern is when we adopted the dashboard
and we look at that dashboard and we saw the five by five color grid, we chose a target, a goal for schools to meet.
And in setting that target and goal, it had two parts, the status and the growth over time.
And so when you look at that target, there is a very specific definition for that box on that five by five grid about what our long term target
was in the academic indicator.
So yes, we did adopt a long-term goal for status and change for the writing and crafting our ESSA state plan, but also in setting goals and targets to implement our LCAP accountability as well.
So yes, we do have a long-term goal.
I was saying we didn't have not done that in science.
Yeah, I'm not worried about that, but what I'm saying is for the two areas where we did, this is not what we adopted.
Right, and so I think the decision that has to be made is how to represent
maybe perhaps what was adopted, but also what seems like a reasonable goal that will not put us into a cycle of corrective action with the federal government on a regular basis because it's so aspirational that, you know, it's not practical.
Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
And Member Navo, you looked like you were about to say something, so I just wanted to give you that opportunity if you'd like to get in, yeah.
So I think the other thing that's confusing us a little bit, at least it's confusing me, is because when we set those targets, they were based on a seven-year span to get to that target.
But it was my question is, what does it mean to go into corrective action?
Because if it's like CSI, where there is no punishment, you're not going to have to return money that was allotted to you.
If it's more of an opportunity for you to come together and be reflective of how are you serving your CT concentrators?
How do we make sure that they are college and career ready then?
I just don't see it so dangerous.
It's probably good for us to still hold high expectations and then allow the community to come together with industry partners, with our community college partners, and really have these robust conversations.
So what does it mean in this context for Perkins to go into corrective action?
It's exactly what you just said.
So there is no, in fact, the federal government no longer has a role in this process.
So they will not have negotiation.
Previously, we used to negotiate these targets every year.
That no longer is there.
We have these four-year targets.
and the plan that is being developed is a four-year plan, and adjustments are made along the way, like it's in ESSA and other federal legislation.
So the federal role has been minimized.
So you are correct in saying that we, I mean, you know, so that we have one of two options.
We either, as President Darling-Hartman said, we have to either have a nuanced approach in terms of looking at
you know, be aggressive on one side, but then be, I'm being conservative, I would admit, just simply because I'm waiting to get more data before we actually get to a more formal place.
And as I said, we have time to do that, and I'm having conversations with the other data reporting and analysis divisions within CDE.
One other thing I would point out is, which is unique to Perkins, it's not there in any other federal legislation that I'm aware of.
In fact, going back to you, so even if you set a high enough
level, you actually are, a state is okay as long as they meet within the 90% of that, that range.
So, for example, if you look at the graduation rate, and I just, I did the mental calculation on 85%, as long as you're between 77 and 85, there is no need for a corrective action.
So you can go as low as 77 before things start kicking in.
there is this provision within Perkins that isn't there in other federal legislation.
So we have to keep, be mindful of that as well.
Because this is what we give, these targets are what we will be giving to the local recipients in terms of, and essentially using that since everyone cannot be above average, so some of them will be below
that number and they would then have to, in their local application plan, address those gaps as they move forward.
You asked my question, so if I understand it correctly,
It doesn't do us any harm to raise these, to match the proficiency percentages with what we've already approved because the corrective action simply leads to a reflection.
And that's where the comprehensive local needs comes in.
So there's no loss of money.
So I was worried that we were going to send us into this cycle of corrective action.
more in line with the reality that those should match together.
The cavalry has arrived.
So there's some confusion regarding the data point.
So the data points are around scaled scores.
and not percent proficiency rates.
So when you say... That's what we've adopted previously.
Right, you've adopted previously the scale score, so that's what this is based on.
So when you talk about matching proficiency, what are you matching it to?
We don't actually have in this metric the goals that would slide right into the table.
or make sure that's clarified, because it's going back and forth and it's very different.
And I would say, and just in trying to help Pradeep out, because this is his first meeting and he deserves a break, the federal government didn't even align what they were requesting.
So what they're requesting in ESSA versus what they're requesting in Perkins, it's not this neat alignment.
And how we measure on the dashboard is school and district performance.
We're not looking at individual students.
everything's aggregated up.
And so I think it's now causing confusion in the field already, and you haven't even adopted a plan yet.
So I keep apologizing to Pradeep, saying it's not this neat crossover.
So then let me suggest that perhaps where we need to start with, and I'm very interested in creating clarity for the field about what this accountability data means.
and what it is the state is actually adopting that they will hold.
locals accountable for on performance, there needs to be some clarity about what it is we're asking them to pay attention to.
Because in the accountability conversation on the secondary side of the equation, districts are accustomed to a specific way of understanding data about their students.
So in the next two sentences, I'm about to say one of them is going to be wrong.
And so in this plan, we are departing.
from what kind of data is being presented about the schools.
And in some way, there is some linkage between what schools already understand in the accountability system that's being reported about their students and what's being reported in this chart
that's different.
So I know one of those sentences was wrong.
So in order to fix the confusion we have here, we need to have a conversation about are we going to use common data to talk about the same students because these are the same students in these schools or are we for some reason going to use different data points about these students and what would be the rationale for doing that.
Okay.
Okay, y'all abandoned him now.
I think we've understood the problem a little better and I think we've given you some guidance about the fact that we want to, you know, even though we will not be able to match all of these to something that the board has always adopted in this format, we want to be sure that we're being thoughtful about the trajectory and not
I do have to appreciate my colleagues.
And I'm deeply underestimating what might be possible.
Does that help give you a little bit of a bumper guard?
That helps the three of us too.
I do appreciate my colleagues who came up here because I will be from day one.
I've only been here seven months This is my seventh month here.
And so from day one, I've had conversations with them and their staff about this table I mean and we continue to have conversations and as I said, we have till December 2021 so we can refine
create those guardrails and work through the process.
Okay, thank you.
Can you just then clarify upon how did you do the projections?
You mentioned you got numbers from Michelle and that they're conservative.
They just actually just increased it by 1% just to, because they are, you know, we could have done a little more, but just increased it by 1%.
There may be a typo or something in one or two places where it doesn't look quite that consistent.
Are there other issues that we need or want to talk about with respect to the accountability section or any other sections?
We do need to at some point take public comment, but I want to be sure that and I don't want to wear out our potential public commenters if they're
I'm hanging on by their fingernails.
I know that you have a last section here.
So, accountability is one of the huge pieces and this is just an information item, but I wanted my colleagues to be aware when this does come back to us for approval, we need to work out some of these kinks.
The collection of data has been something that we have struggled with in a huge topic of conversation in our advisory committee.
as well.
And then I do want to go back, and I'm sorry I kind of skipped this, is on the qualifications section on the teacher preparation qualifications.
It was kind of back a little bit, and I should have made a comment at that point.
We were not very, if you can go back one more perhaps.
Was it teacher retention, I think it was preparation of faculty, right?
Yeah, so I just wanted to say that this has also been an area that we've heard a lot from the field around the CTE credential and the difficulty in getting qualified people for a lot of different reasons, but one of which is the certification pieces.
And so this is something that the department is working with the Commission on Teacher Credentialing around.
We're hoping to see some creative solutions that might come from the commission.
I'm hearing about a few of those types of things.
But I think what's really important to point out here is that we need to have those conversations and be on the same page in looking at the preparation of CTE staff and teachers.
And I'll just, if I can just add a footnote to that, you know, there's been an ongoing conversation about the shortages in that field.
I know that the Perkins Act actually encourages people to address shortages and, you know, use some of the money in that regard.
And the conversation is
beginning to suggest multiple pathways in for people who come from different starting points and fulfill different kinds of needs in different settings.
So we do wanna encourage the forward movement that has been going on in that conversation to get us to a place where we can more productively look at the competence that people bring, take advantage of that competence and make sure that we're filling positions in ways that don't pose unnecessary obstacles.
that are not related to competence for educators.
So that will be something we'll look at when it comes back to us.
Member Rucker.
And I'm looking at a letter from one of the stakeholders.
There's a difference in the teacher recruitment issues for the community college that's very different
from K-12 because in community college, they don't need the CTE certification.
But the pipeline issues tend to seem to vary according to this letter with the industry sector.
And so the example they give is in the clinical nursing program.
So there is some law right now in California that puts a limit on the percentage of hours
that part-time or temporary employees can teach.
And in the clinical nursing program, many community college districts employ practicing clinical nurses because that's a requirement for the certification program that the course has to be taught by a licensed practitioner.
And because of the way the rotation works and the long hours required in the clinical component,
A lot of these part-time faculty have to exceed the 67% cap.
And so an exemption is necessary for that cap in order for community college districts to be able to employ those nurses.
Well, that's just the nursing program in the community college district.
What is it for the mortuary science program that our convener does?
Or what is it for the BA programs in some of these other areas that community colleges currently offer certification training is?
I don't, so the point that they made is that it's a one-size-fits-all recruitment process that looks at resolving the K-12 issue, but there are some very diverse and different issues for recruiting instructors in the community college district
for those programs that the plan doesn't contemplate or seem to understand.
Right, so then that's just you know just to flag that this has been an issue with our Perkins plan in the past that the way in which we administered our state plan made it harder to get qualified people who could do the job well from all these different sectors
Into the positions where we wanted them to be so there has been a lot of conversation about how to address these various needs and we just want to be sure that those are really represented in the way that we move forward with this version of the plan and I don't want to Suggest that we would take time to go through all the issues and problems right now but that was a good example of one and there are others that we can I
help get on the table and work through so that we're not sacrificing any aspect of necessary competence, but are opening doors and removing obstacles that have been in place for these shortages.
Are we close to being able to invite public comment?
Because I think the afternoon is waiting.
Just quickly, I just want to go through a timeline here just so you have a sense of, as just looking at the slide, it was the draft for public comment was put on by the Joint Advisory Committee on the 25th.
But we just finished the public comment period last week and we are and then we sent you a memo in December.
We're having this initial input from the State Board of Education.
We will then having taking your comments and the public comment and other comments that are coming in and comments that were made during the 25th meeting that didn't quite get into that plan because of time constraints
We have to take all of that and bring it forward to the joint advisory committee for their look, the updated plan, and then we'll come back to you in March 2020 for an approval of the draft Perkins plan.
A new thing in Perkins V that wasn't there before is that the governor has to approve the plan and it has to go to the governor's office and the governor has 30 days for approval.
And so basically we are, State Board of Education and staff is having conversations with them through this process as we go through the next couple of months so that when they get that they're aware
of what's in the document.
And then April 15th is when we submit both the Perkins Five-State Plan to the Department of Education as well as our federal taxes.
The other thing I want to say and Dr. Kodumaraju is actually being quite humble on this.
In having the last meeting where our work group met and looked at the draft, one of the things we agreed was that the draft itself was not perfect but that we would take advantage of the stakeholder process and the public comment that would be coming and ask the stakeholders themselves who would respond to help us with some of the naughtier problems that we just said here.
and have a longer conversation on.
So we're looking forward on the 31st to hearing how the stakeholders identified or gave recommendations on some of the very issues that have caused us some angst here at this table.
And so that was our plan all along, knowing
that the stakeholders may also see or raise the same concerns and have the same concerns that we had.
So I think he was very cagey and very astute in making the decision to let the plan go out that way so that we could see what the stakeholders would say and use that as a problem solving opportunity.
Thank you.
The last slide here, just to indicate to you that we are developing a more comprehensive state plan for CTE and the timeline is out there.
This sort of emphasizes the state effort that is going around CTE and looking at that and some of the issues that were brought up today on accountability, teacher recruitment, alignment between the two systems, community colleges and us, I think is something that we will be looking at in that larger plan.
Great, thank you.
Would you like to tell us who would like to give public comment?
Sheila Whitley would like to give public comment.
Thank you Sheila for hanging in there.
You know, teachers will always hang in there when it comes to helping our students.
My name is Sheila Whitley, and I'm here representing the California Teachers Association.
And we appreciate the opportunity to provide public comment on the Perkins V draft plan.
We would like to give three specific pieces of feedback for the plan and two of them have been discussed at length up here.
First of all, there must be a concerted statewide effort to recruit and retain qualified CTE instructors.
A well-qualified workforce should be the foundation of this plan.
Otherwise,
It's based on a false promise.
Secondly, while we commend the CDE for portions of their outreach, we must call out the fact that the statewide advisory group included over 90 program administrators, yet there was only one current classroom CTE teacher.
It's impossible to understand the reality in our schools and what we face without the voice of current classroom teachers.
Time.
Third, there must be an alignment between the accountability for results portion of the plan and the state's current accountability system and goals as defined within the LCAP and the California dashboard.
Otherwise, the state runs a risk of creating a lower performance expectation for CTE students.
And we do not believe that that is the state's intent.
Thank you very much.
OK.
So seeing no other questions.
Public comment will now open for board discussion, but I think we've had quite a lot of it I do want to recognize Brenna and any other last Comments and as you know, this is being presented for information and not for action.
So, please
Thank you.
So I just wanted to make one comment, and I don't know if this is something that is being more pursued in the statewide plan, but I do think, I mean, specifically in this plan, I think that one thing that might be lacking attention is career education and early education.
So I think it was only referenced maybe twice, so on page 17 and a little bit in 76, but some may believe that
career technical education in early education might not be as important because it's not the actual technical skills of learning a job.
However, another recurring theme in this is that equitable access and providing opportunities to those special populations.
And one could also argue that that's impossible without addressing things early on in early education.
So whether that be for disadvantaged students,
by the time they're making it to those amazing opportunities in community colleges, they probably already had different experience or exposure to even having those opportunities available to them.
And it goes back to also the idea that there's a hierarchy in college or career pathways
And if you're exposing that earlier, maybe more students will take advantage of those opportunities that are aligned or that are specifically stated throughout the entire plan.
So whether that be a part of this plan or the statewide plan, I think that's an important thing to mention or take note of.
Thank you.
Yes.
Excellent comment.
Thank you.
All right.
Have we given Pradeep enough of our insights?
I believe we have.
Is there any other discussion?
We thank you for all the good work to date and all the intensive and good work that will occur between now and March.
And there may be some of these comments that you can pursue with folks as needed in that interim.
So thank you, Pradeep.
And we will adjourn today's meeting and reconvene tomorrow at 830 a.m.
It's so weird.
As soon as I touched it, I'm all paranoid.
You know, we self-diagnose all the time.
Us Mexicans.